SUBCOMMITTEE FOR WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
BASS COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENT TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY YOU
ARE IN LUCK ALL OF THE CURRENT
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE
HERE IN THE HINDU HEARING ROOM.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE TO COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
RECKONED THAT YOU USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO IN MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT A NEED BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ARE
WORSE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WITH WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6360 FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX FOUR FIVE
SIX FIVE FOUR. TWO EIGHT NINE
SEVEN JUST LIKE YOU SEE ON THE
SCREEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MISS MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING WATCHING THE HEARING
ON PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY
ANYBODY ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE. MEETING SERVICE OUR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTION MUTED I
DON'T EXPECT THAT THIS WILL BE
NECESSARY. WHILE EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS OR ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. BEFORE WE BEGIN WE NEED
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. UNDER CABALLERO
THERE ARE HAVE A PRESENT CENTER
NELSON. SENATOR ROTH THE
FOUNDER PRESIDENT. WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. WE WILL BEGIN WITH A
DISCUSSION ITEM STARTING ON
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISCALE SPECIAL
PROJECTS REPORT NINE UPDATE.
WELCOME. I'LL ASK THE
DEPARTMENT TO PLEASE SPEAK
FIRST THING YOU'RE GOING TO
NEED TO REMOVE YOURSELF. CAN
YOU HEAR ME SENATOR AYE WE CAN
HEAR YOU WELCOME UNDER. THANK
YOU GOOD MADAM AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MIRIAM.
AND YOU NEED OUT AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DOWN WITH ME TODAY IS
KATHLEEN OUR USE MY BUSINESS
PARTNER FROM THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S. AND SHE CAN HELP
ME AND ANY THAT YOU MAY HAVE
PERTAINING SPECIFICALLY TO THE
INTEGRATED SOLUTION OR- THE-
REMAINING. OF S. C. WHAT WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY BUDGET REQUEST I
HAVE FOR YOU THIS YEAR I AM
THANKFUL FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE WITH YOU WHERE WE ARE
AS BOTH THE PROJECT AS WELL AS
THE DEPARTMENT. AS YOU KNOW
DISCOUNT AMONG THE LARGEST
FINANCIAL PUBLIC SECTOR IT
SYSTEMS IN THE WORLD. AND IS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST AND MOST
DYNAMIC BUSINESS TRANSFORMATION
UNDERTAKINGS IN CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY. IN ITS SIX SASS IF CAL
PROMOTES THE INTEGRITY OF THE
STATE'S FINANCIAL INFORMATION.
I HE'S GOING FORCES THE TRUE
ACCOUNTING PRACTICES AND
ENABLES THE FOR CONTROL
AGENCIES TO ENFORCE OUR
POLICIES RULES AND REGULATIONS.
AS MENTIONED IN THE AGENDA THIS
GAL IS A WORKING SYSTEM WITH
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
DEPARTMENTS AND APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN THOUSAND AND USERS
PROCESSING SIX THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IN EXPENDITURES EACH YEAR. AND
THE STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE
ALONE EITHER FUNCTIONALITY
HANDLES ABOUT TWO TRILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE GOVERNMENT
BANKING TRANSACTIONS ANNUALLY.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
VENDORS THAT SELL THEIR GOODS
AND SERVICES TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA UTILIZING THE FISCAL
SYSTEM THROUGH OUR CAL
EPROCUREMENT PORTAL.
ADDITIONALLY THE PLATFORM AND
TECHNICAL SERVICES OF THE
FISCAL SYSTEM ARE FLEXIBLE AND
CAN BE EXPANDED TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL BUSINESS
FUNCTIONALITY AND BUILD RELATED
TO ADD TO SYSTEMS THAT CONTINUE
TO MEET THE STATE'S BUSINESS
NEEDS. BUT SYSTEMS UP TIME I AM
HAPPY TO REPORT HAS BEEN AT
LEAST NINETY NINE POINT 5% OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. AND
IT PROVIDES ENTERPRISE GRADE
SECURITY FEATURES THAT CAN BE
LEVERAGED INTO NEW BUSINESS
FUNCTIONS AS THEY ARE ADDED TO
THE SYSTEM. WHAT REMAINS ON THE
PROJECT SIDE IS DETAILED IN
SPECIAL PROJECT REPORT NUMBER
NINE. WHICH THAT FISCAL
SUBMITTEDTO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY LAST
SEPTEMBER AND WAS APPROVED BY
CDT IN OCTOBER. S. P. R. NINE
OFFICIALLY CLOSED OUT SEVEN
AREAS OF MAJOR FUNCTIONALITY
THAT WERE SUCCESSFULLY DEPLOYED
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR. ANY
ADDITIONALLY ADDS TWENTY FOUR
MONTH SCHEDULE- EXTENSION TO
IMPLEMENT THE FINAL
FUNCTIONALITY FOR THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE INTEGRATED
SOLUTION. IN ADDITIONAL TIME IS
FOR SCO NON PROJECTS STAFF TO
CONDUCT MORE TESTING- BEFORE
DEPLOYING THE TOOLS AND REPORTS
NECESSARY FOR SCO TO PRODUCE
THE BUDGETARYLEGAL BASIS
ANNUAL REPORT WHICH WE CALL THE
BILL MAHER. AND THE
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORT WHICH IS KNOWN AS THE
CAP FOR. THE FUNCTIONALITY FOR
SEOS CATHERINE BILL BARR WILL
BE DEPLOYED IN THREE RELIEF. WE
BEGAN IN DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
AND WILL CONTINUE THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
REDUCTION SUPPORT WILL BE
PROVIDED FOR TWELVE MONTHS
AFTER THE IMPLEMENTATION. AS
WELL AS THE COMPLETION OF
KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER FROM
ACCENTURE THAT IS OUR SYSTEM
INTEGRATOR. TO BOTH THIS GAL
AND YES YEAH RESTORE. WE EXPECT
FISCAL WILL BECOME THE STATE OF.
ANGEL OF TWO TWENTY TWO. AND
THE KAFIR WILL PRODUCED UTILIZE
ONLY THE FIFTH SAYS IN TWENTY
TWO THREE SO WE WILL BE
PRODUCING NEXT YEAR A PARALLEL
KAFFIR BUT WE WILL BE DOING IT
ON OUR OWN EXPECT IN. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. GEN THREE THAT I
WOULD LIKE ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
AS WERE THE SAVE- BETWEEN ASK
YOUR EIGHT AND ASK YOU ARE. OUR
CREATOR ASK YOU HAVE INCLUDED
PART FULL. WHICH INCLUDE THE M.
L. FOR THE NEW DEPLOYED
FUNCTION. AS WELL AS THE M.
COST SO. WITH ALL OF THE
FUNCTION THAT HAD BEEN
PRODUCTION FOR YEARS. SO AS MY
ASK YOUR NAY FORMALLY CLOSED
THE MAJORITY THE PROJECT AND
NOW SUCH PROJECT COSTS ASK YOUR
REPRESENT ONLY THOSE THIS. WITH
THE ROOM WERE COVERED BY YOUR
NINE. AND THE WAY YEAR AND
OPERATION I. WITH THAT
IMPLEMENTATION. WE DO NOT
NORDWIND. A BUDGET YEAR RICK
THIS YEAR. I THIS QUESTION.
ASKED HOW WE IN TO AND THAT THE
OPERATION BETWEEN THE LEGACY
SYSTEM AND FISCAL RUN. WE HAVE
AN- AND IT SENT COULD SUPPORT
TEAM IS DATA TO RECKON THE- D.
BETWEEN THE LETTER BALANCES
BOTH SYSTEM. THIS TEAM IS ALL
RISK FOR QUICKLY RESOLVE ANY
JUST. BETWEEN SYSTEM AND
ENHANCING THAT THE SISTER- THAT
PROCESS IS A THE BUSINESS. THE
BUSINESS SYSTEMS WHEN NEEDED
ACTIVE TO ASSIST THAT SYMMETRY.
I DID WE MAINTAIN- WE TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE OUR IN THE
OVERSIGHT UNTIL PROJECT IS. THE
THIRD QUEST IT WAS BY STATE IN
AGENDA. WAYS WHAT KIND
ASSISTANCE IS BEING PROVIDED TO
THE THAT ASTRUGGLING TO CLOSE
OUT THEIR FINAL WORK. WITH THE
ADDITIONAL THAT WE INTEREST
YEAR NINETY TO. BY THE LEAD. WE
HAVE A SIMPLE SERVICES IN TOOLS
IMPROVE IF. AND GREATLY OUR
TRAINING AND SO SIR. ARE
CHARTERHOUSE. OVER THE FEW.
THIS GUY HAS RELEASED THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
ENHANCEMENTS AND TOOLS TO
IMPROVE THE OVERALL CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE INCLUDING ACCURACY
AND EFFICIENCY OF THE MONTH AND
YEAR AND CLOSE REPORTING
PROCESSES. ADDITIONALLY
ENHANCEMENTS ARE CURRENTLY
BEING DESIGNED AND DEVELOPED
AND DEVELOPED TO FURTHER
ASSISTANCE AFRICA THIS IS AN
ONGOING EFFORT THAT WE ARE
WORKING WITH- OUR OUR LINE
DEPARTMENTS ON IMPROVING OUR
OUR SYSTEM. IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY FISCALE BEGAN TO
RELEASE THE SERIES WHAT WE CALL
WORK CENTERS BY MONTY AND SOME.
WITHIN A USERS AND THE SYSTEM
TO OUR- I SPECIFIC PRIORITIZE
CAL. IN ACTS IN THE CENTRAL OF.
SO AGAIN INSTEAD OF HAVING THEM
HAVE TO SEARCH THROUGHOUT THE
SYSTEM TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE
NEXT STEP FOR WHAT'S NEXT ON
THEIR TASK. WE HAVE MADE IT
MORE USER FRIENDLY. FOR THEM.
THIS BILL IS FULLY BRINGING.
AND COMPUTING TO THE STATE
FINANCE USING- MOST RECENT
WE'VE ON BOARDED MY CHRIS HOW
BI I. AND ASISTIR NOW ANALYTICS.
THESE NEW TOOLS ARE OF FISCAL
EFFORT KICKING EXT. IN THE
DOUBLE. OF TO EXPLORE ANALYZE
AND WE'RE- THEIR OWN IN AND-
YOU. THEIR OWN DATA SO AGAIN
GOING TO THAT ONE THE HARD OF
WHAT THE SCHOLARS ABOUT SAYS.
ENTRY JUST. AND PUT THAT DATE
INTO FORMAT BACK IN FRONT OF
THE. DISCOUNT ALL STARTED TO
RIVER PROCESS ON. IN AND NOT OF
THE TASK. AND WHAT. DE IS IT
TAKES MANY OF THOSE MONDAY
WE'RE KIND OF TASKS. THAT
WORKERS PERFORM AND IT DOESN'T
REMAIN STYLE. TO THE TO THIS.
ARE RESPONDING TO THE DATA CAN
YOU WITH OTHER SISTER AGAIN ON
THOSE MY NAME HOW TO GET. WITH
HIS YOU SEE A LOT OF ERROR IN
DATA. THERE IS TO DO THAT BY
THE COMPUTER SYSTEM IS ABLE TO
WITH HOW 2% AND IT CAN RUN FOUR
A DAY SEVEN A WEEK. SO THE BOTS
ARE DOING NINETEEN WORK OF THE
TRANS. IN IT OR- AND YOU THE
MORE CALM IN NEW WHERE YOU WANT
CAST. AND ALL THE LEADING
CREATE INTER AND- ABSOLUTELY TO
DO. THESE INNOVATIVE TOOLS AND
WE'RE DIRECTOR OF YOU KNOW
ENGAGING WITH OUR OFFICE OUT
AND USERS AND WE DO THIS
REVENGE LIKE ART HALL. ARE
FISCAL FORUMS AND IMAC SISTER
WITH WHICH WHICH IS A DESIGN TO
WORK. WE STARTED IN IN TWENTY
WE BRING THE WAS TO. THEY TELL
US THEIR PAIN POINT THEY GIVE A
SUGGEST ON WHAT THEY WOULD TO
SEE SYSTEM. AND WE TRIED.
INCORPORATE THAT AND IN SOME MY
TO MAKE THEIR JOB EASY. I WE
ALSO WANT THIS TV WHICH IS A
NOT IN GAME. SHE THAT ARE
INTERACTIVE. TO DEPART USERS
THE WEB. SESSIONS AND END USERS
CAN CONNECT WITH A SPOUSE
MATTER. TO HELP ANSWER. ABOUT
SBA'S TOPIC TO PROVIDE VALUABLE
IN AND- THIS CALL IS PROVIDED
TO DATE SEVEN. JUST OUTSIDE
WITH OVERSEE ONE HOW YEAR. AND
I THE SESSIONS MEET OUR HELP.
FOR TATE. AND AIRED THE FIRST
THEIR CODE ON OUR- AND USERS
COME BACK AND- HELLO AT THOSE.
AS OF MAR TWENTY TWENTY
INTEREST TO THE GLOBAL. JUST
GOT A QUICK SHIFT FROM ITS IN
HER OF MODEL TO VERGE SESSION.
IT IS TO HIS COUNTY. WE OFFER
OVERSEE HUNDRED. AND BURKE
ENTRY BURKE IN. WHERE OF AND
YOU STAY RISK SUPPORT AND TRAIN
RIGHT FROM THIS OUTSIDE THE
MATTER X. HAVING SAID THAT
THERE. AYE SEVEN. AND THEY HAVE
TO SEE THEIR YEAR AND FINING
WORK FOR THE PREVIOUS JUST YEAR
I TO ASK. AND I KNOW THAT IS-
THERE HAVE BEEN A COUPLE TO
HAVE CLOSE TO YOUR STAFF RIGHT
AT WE CAN INDICATE ALLOW. SO
CAL IS. ALONG WITH ASK. AND
ORDER FINING. AND PROVIDING
YEAR AND CLOSE SUPPORT IN
ACCESS OF THOSE THEIR NORMAL
BUSINESS HOURS AND AGAIN THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT THE PARTNERS
IN THE DEPARTMENT STAFF HAVE
BEEN DOING. FOR FOR MANY
ONTHS. FOR THE DEPARTMENTS
THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY HAD
DIFFICULTY WITH MONTH END
CLOSING YEAR AND CLOSE
PROCESSES AND ARE GENERALLY A
SMALLER DEPARTMENT FINANCE HAS
WORKED TO TRANSITION THEM TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES CENTRAL FINANCIAL
SERVICES- UNIT. WHICH PERFORMS
THEIR ACCOUNTING FUNCTIONS. DGS
RECENTLY LAUNCHED A STRIKE TEAM
THAT PROVIDE SPECIFIC-
SPECIFIED ACCOUNTING ASSISTANCE
TO SELECT DEPARTMENTS.
STRUGGLING OR DEALING WITH
TEMPORARY VACANCIES SO AGAIN
THESE ARE NOT SMALL ENOUGH
DEPARTMENT TODAY WOULD
PERMANENTLY GO OVER TO. THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
CONTRACTED JUST WILL SERVICES
SECTION BUT RATHER THIS IS A
ONE TIME NEED THAT THEY HAVE
THAT SOME INTENSIVE. HELP CAN
GET THEM ACROSS NOT. ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE SO ONE SUCH EXAMPLE
ARE ONE SUCH DEPARTMENT THIS
YEAR AND THAT THE DDS STRIKE
TEAM WAS CRITICAL IN HELPING.
WAYS CALYX ARE THEY CONTRACTED
WITH THE STRIKE TEAM AND THEY
HAD FALLEN BEHIND ON THEIR
MONTH AND YEAR AND CLOSE FOR
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY.
DISTRACTING PROVIDED THAT
SUPPORT HELP THEM CLOSE THEIR
MINDS THEY ALSO HELP IN
COMPILING COMPLETE ASSOCIATED
RECONCILIATIONS AND PREPARE THE
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS THAT WERE
ULTIMATELY. SUBMITTED TO SCO-
ADDITIONALLY WHILE THIS IS TO
INTO TRAINING JOB AND PREPARED
A SPECIFIC TO THAT DEPARTMENT
AND PREPARE CALLIE TARGET. TO
PERFORM THEIR OWN ACCOUNTING
BACK EXTENSIONS IN THE FUTURE
FOR FUTURE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS. THANK YOU CAN SEE
THERE ARE THERE'S A MYRIAD OF
SERVICES THAT FIFTY ON OUR
PARTNERS ARE OFFERING TO
DEPARTMENTS TO ADDRESS DELAYS
IN PERFORMING MONTH END AND
YEAR AND CLOSE TASKS AND
SUBMITTING THEIR YEAR END
FINANCIAL REPORTS TO THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. AND I I'M
HAPPY. TO REPORT THAT OUR
EFFORTS ARE PAYING OFF. IT
MEANS OVER ARE CLOSING. PERCENT
FAST THIS YEAR THAN THEY WERE
JUST TWO YEARS AGO. AND WE HAVE
ALWAYS MAINTAINED AND I
TESTIFIED TO THIS COMMUNITY BUT
THERE IS A THREE YEAR LEARNING
CURVE WITH THE SYSTEM. WITH A
CHANGE THAT WAS MADE IS LARGEST
S. AND WITH OUR LARGER MORE
COMPLEX DEPARTMENTS NOW
APPROACHING THEIR THIRD YEAR
USING THIS METHOD STYLE SYSTEM
WE EXPECT THIS PROGRESS TO
CONTINUE. SO IN AN EFFORT TO
BUILD ON THIS MOMENTUM AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR I JUST
LAST MONTH WE LAUNCHED THE
FIRST OUR LEARNING CENTER WHICH
IS A ONE STOP LEARNING
EXPERIENCE THAT CENTRALIZES.
ALL OF THE COURSES ALL OF THE
TRAINING THAT WE OFFER TO END
USERS SO THEY CAN MASTER THE
SKILLS NEEDED TO BECOME
CONFIDENT AND SUCCESSFUL SYSTEM
USERS. SO AGAIN ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT MEDIUMS THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO REACH. THE OUR
CLIENTS AYE BECAUSE EVERYBODY
LEARNS AT DIFFERENT RATES AND
WITH WITH DIFFERENT TOOLS FOR
PROVIDING THEM ALL SO THEY CAN
HAVE. EITHER ACCESS TO THAT
TRAINING COURSES THAT ARE IN
PERSON- RITUAL IN THIS CASE. OR
IF THEY JUST NEED I NEED ACCESS
I HAVE I'M STUCK ON A PO I NEED
TO ACCESS THIS RIGHT NOW THEY
CAN GO TO THE LEARNING CENTER
AND THEY CAN BE DIRECTED. TO
INFORMATION ON HOW TO PROCESS
THAT HERE WHERE THEY ARE- I'M
VERY PROUD OF ALL THAT WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED IN TWENTY TWENTY.
AND WHAT TWENTY TWENTY HAS
PRESENTED. A LOT OF CHALLENGES
DUE TO THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
THIS GAL HAS CONTINUED TO
THRIVE AND WE HAVE CONTINUED TO
MOVE THE SYSTEM FORWARD. AS WE
MATURE. AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
RUN THOROUGH EXPLANATION OF
WHAT'S GOING ON- ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THIRTY OFTEN. I THANK
YOU FOR OUR LONG TERM
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY. THE
HELP TO SWAY SOME OF MY
CONCERNS I WOULD LIKE TO REPEAT
HERE TO THE- COMMITTEE. AS WE
TALKED YESTERDAY I SHARED MY
CONCERNS WERE MORE GLOBAL THAN
SPECIFIC THAT. CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN ABSOLUTELY INCOMPETENT AND
APPLYING NEW TECHNOLOGY. AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER
MONEY WASTED. AND THESE
CONTRACTS NEVER COME IN ON TIME
NOW YOU'VE GIVEN ME SOME
COMFORT THAT MAY BE DISCOUNT IS
NOT ON THAT SAME SORRY TRACK.
NOW THIS IS THE IT WAS SAID I
THINK WE CAME UP JUST A TEN OR
ELEVEN DEPARTMENTS WERE NOT YET
TO COMPLETED I THINK YOU JUST
SAID SEVEN IS THAT CORRECT NOW.
YEP AND WE'RE STILL. THERE
HAVING TROUBLE GETTING THEIR
DATA TO YOU. SORRY IS MY CRIME
SORRY YES SENATOR WE HAVE SEVEN
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF CLOSING THEIR
MONTH AND- AND WE DO HAVE AT
FOR. DIFFERENT REASONS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL
AS THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE ARE ENGAGED WITH THESE
DEPARTMENTS WITH US TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN ET THEM
CLOSER THAT THEY HAVE A BETTER
EXPERIENCE NEXT YEAR IN THE
SYSTEM WOULD TRANSMIT THE NAME
OF THOSE SEVEN DEPARTMENTS TO
MY OFFICE I DON'T KNOW IF I
COLLEAGUES CARE BUT I'D LIKE TO
JUST KNOW THE NAMES OF THE
AGENCIES. YES I CAN DO THEN WE
CAN KIND OF FOLLOW UP ON THEM
IT'S ALSO IT SHOULD THE
DISTRUST BECAUSE AGENCIES
USUALLY WILL JUST STONEWALL YOU
INSTALL YOU AND NOT GET YOU
INFORMATION. AND FIGURE YOU'RE
GONNA FORGET IT. AND- I THINK
WE AFFORD DO THAT IN TEXTILE
ANYMORE IT'S COSTING FAR TOO
MUCH MONEY- THE THESE TAX
DOLLARS THAT WE WASTED- AND THE
EASY DOLLARS WE'VE WASTED.
REALLY COULD HAVE GONE A LONG
WAYS TO HELP THEM WITH SOME OF
OUR BUDGET CHALLENGES SO WE
WE'VE GOT TO BE VERY
FASTIDIOUS. AND CAREFUL ABOUT
IT- NOW. I SHOULDN'T. TEAMS
THAT GO OUT HELP AGENCIES ARE
HAVING PROBLEMS. A MULTIPLE
DISCIPLINE OTHERS SEVERAL
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS CAN IT
GET A DEDICATED PEOPLE TO DO
THAT OR DO YOU. DEPLOY THEM
FROM YOUR OWN DEPARTMENT. SO
BETWEEN- THE DEPARTMENT OF
SYSTOLIC WE PROVIDE SOME
ASSISTANCE WHEN IT COMES TO
MORE THE TECHNICAL AND OF THE
COMPUTER EARLY THE WORK AND
JUST OUT. OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS PROVIDING ON SITE NO
SUPPORTER- ASSISTANCE NOTHING
IS ON SITE AT THE MOMENT THAT
YOU KNOW SOMEONE ON WIND
ASSISTANCE WITH THE DEPARTMENTS
ON ACCOUNTING SIDE. AS IT IS
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES THEY WERE FUNDED FOR A
STRIKE TEAM SPECIFICALLY GOES
IN IT AND HELPS- DEPARTMENTS
THAT. ARE JUST ON THE CUSP OF
THOSE AT THE MEETING A LITTLE
BIT MORE. IT AS PART OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY I
REQUEST IN BC KEY THAT WE HAVE
ON THE LEGISLATURE THAT WAS
GRANTED WE DID HAVE SOME
DOLLARS TO SEND CONTRACTORS
OUT. TO SOME OF THESE MORE AT.
TICKETS TO SOME OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO HAVE HIS STRONG.
SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE MORE ONE
ON ONE AS WE MOVE INTO THE
FUTURE THAT IS A ROLE THAT YOU
SEE MORE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PLAYING. AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES-
BULLARD REMIND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WOULD LIKE TODAY
COMMUNICATING WITH US ABOUT
THEIR ROLE TO. YOU KNOW WHAT
COULD BE MORE COMFORTING THAN
NOT TO KNOW THE TWO AGENCIES
ARE TO DEPARTMENTS ARE. FAR
OVERSEEING SO I'D LIKE TO KNOW
TO WHAT DEGREE FINANCE
CONTINUES TO BE ENGAGE. ANOTHER
QUESTION I DON'T THINK WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY. A
LOT OF THE LICENSES ARE
PROVISIONAL NOW. AND THAT WAS A
MIGHT THAT IT TELLS ME THAT
THAT WAS AUTHORIZED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TWO YEARS AGO THESE
PROVISIONAL LICENSES. DESERVE
STAND THROUGH OR WITHOUT
TRANSITIONING TO ANNUAL
LICENSES OR EVERYTHING STILL
PROVISIONAL. WE HAVE LICENSES
FOR- R. EIGHTEEN R. FIFTEEN
THOUSAND END USERS AND- I DON'T
KNOW THAT I KNOW- WHAT WHAT THE
TERMS ARE OF THAT OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD I CAN SEE IF I CAN
GET SOMEBODY TECH TO SEND ME
THAT INFORMATION I'LL GET IT TO
YOU AS FAR AS HOW MANY YEARS WE
READ UP. ON THE CONTRACT FOR
THOSE LICENSES BUT WE YOU KNOW
WE HAVE THE PEOPLE SOFT
LICENSES THE HYPERION LICENSES
WE DO IT FOR ALL FIFTEEN
THOUSAND AND USERS WELL THERE
ARE A LOT OF LICENSES AT THE
STATE HAS AND THAT COULD BE AN
EXPENSIVE THING I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO KIND OF FLAG THAT TO
KEEP US ADVISED. HOW MANY HAVE
TRANSITIONED DOWN. FROM THE
PROVISIONAL STATUS. AND YOUR
CONCERN. THE REGULATORY.
FUNCTIONS INTO ONE DEPARTMENT
WHAT DEPARTMENT IS THAT THAT
WILL BE HANDLING ALL OF THE
REGULATORY MATTERS. SO THE FOUR
PARTNERS WILL RETAIN THEIR
REGULATORY AUTHORITY IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE AREAS THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES CONTINUES
TO REGULATE- CONTRACTS AND- YOU
KNOW THE SMALL BUSINESSES
CERTIFICATIONS THERE JUST
UTILIZING OUR SYSTEMS WE'RE
CONSOLIDATING WHERE THE FOUR
PARTNERS DO THEIR WORK. BUT THE
AT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE STILL
SETS THE ACCOUNTING POLICIES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE STILL
CONTROLS THE VENDOR MANAGEMENT
LAST- FOR ALL OF THE VENDORS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GATHER ALL
OF THAT THE TAX INFORMATION FOR
ALL OF THOSE SO THE FOUR
PARTNERS RETAIN THE POLICY. ON
THE REGULATORY ABILITIES AND WE
ARE THE TOOL THAT THEIR
LOCALIZING TO COMPLY WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OKAY WELL THAT IS
IMPORTANT A LOT OF AGENCIES
TAKE LIBERTY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
AND WE DON'T WANT. TO SEE THAT
HAPPENING HERE- LET ME JUST
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT THE HAS A
RECALL. HERE THE- THE
COMPLETION DATE ON THE SAYS
CALIFORNIA'S APPLICATION WITH
THAT. THE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
OR TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO WE
WILL BE DEPLOYING ALL OF THE
REQUIRED REQUIRED FUNCTIONALITY
WILL GO IN ON JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WHICH WOULD
AT THAT POINT JUST GOT WOULD
BECOME A BROKEN RECORD WE WILL
BE PRODUCING THE KAFFIR IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO A YEAR-
AFTER THAT. AND I GATHER YOU
HAVE A SCHEMATIC OR SOMETHING
OF THE PROGRESS THAT YOU'RE
MAKING THEN AND MAKING THIS
HAPPEN BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE
ANOTHER WOULD YOU HAVE
MILESTONES DATES INCORPORATED
TO GUIDE YOU. WE DO AND WE HAVE
THE FINAL FUNCTIONALITY FOR THE
SCO IS BEING RELEASED IN THREE
RELEASES WE'VE ALREADY
RELEASED- SOME OF THE
FUNCTIONALITY THE FIRST. PART
OF IT WENT IN DECEMBER OF.
TWENTY TWENTY THE NEXT.
FUNCTIONALITY WILL GO IN AND
THEN THE FINE PIECE GO AGAIN
THIRTIETH- TWENTY TWO ONE OKAY.
THERE'S ANOTHER OBJECT IN THE
STAFF COMMENTS SAYS. THE
UTILITIES OTHER PROVIDERS ARE
STARTING DOCTOR CHARGING
SERVICES THAT MIGHT BE MORE
COST EFFICIENT WATER THESE
CHARGING SERVICES THOSE WOULD
BE TO HAVE. THE UTILITY WOULD
DIRECTLY CHARGE YOUR USERS ARE
OR HOW WOULD THAT WORK. I AND I
ACTUALLY NOT FAMILIAR WITH OKAY
WELL WE CAN WE CAN GET BACK ON
THAT IT WAS A WHAT IN OUR
STAFF. COMMENTS AT THE END SO
WE CAN FOLLOW BACK UP WITH YOU
ON THAT POINT AGAIN IT WAS
ABOUT TO BE OFFERING THE
PROVIDERS WERE OFTEN CHARGING
SERVICES AND I THINK I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT I'M NOT
SURE. AND THEN I'D LIKE TO KNOW
HOW THAT IF THAT IS IN FACT THE
CASE THEY'RE OFFERING CHARGING
SERVICES HOW DOES THAT MAKE IT
MORE EFFICIENT OR EFFECTIVE OR
LESS COSTLY. AND THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO ME AS WELL- AND I
THINK THAT'S ALL I'VE GOT FOR
NOW MANAGER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MEMBERS I ENDED VIRTON
THEY FORGOT TO ASK FINANCE IN
THE ALLEY- SO I'M GONNA GO BACK
TO THAT IF YOU THINK OF NO
QUESTION YOU WANNA ASK PLEASE
LET ME KNOW- RETURNING IT OVER.
NOW RIGHT NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I INTERNET WENT FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WE
HAVE NOTHING FURTHER TO.
COMMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRIAN METZGER
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE APPRECIATE THE DETAILED
SUMMARY INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA
SO WE KEEP OUR COMMENTS BRIEF-
FIRST WE WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR APPROVING KEY CHANGES IN
THE PROJECT SCHEDULE AND SCOPE
IN SPR NINE- WE FIND THE
UPDATED PROJECT SCHEDULE AND
ASK YOUR NINE TO BE MORE
REASONABLE. AND SEOS ACCEPTANCE
OF KEY FINANCIAL REPORTS AND
THE FISCAL SYSTEM TO BE A MORE
LOGICAL DEFINITION OF PROJECT
COMPLETION- WE WOULD NOTE
HOWEVER THAT THE NUMBER OF
HOURS THAT IS REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE THE INTEGRATED
SOLUTION HAS INCREASED OVER
TIME. AND AS THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS IDENTIFIED ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS AND REFINE SOME OF
THE PLAN FUNCTIONALITIES THE
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT HAS
CHANGED A BIT- WE REMAINED A
BIT CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE
CHANGES AS WELL AS THE BACKLOG
OF ENHANCEMENTS AND
FUNCTIONALITIES THAT WILL
REMAIN AFTER THE
ADMINISTRATION. DEEMS THE
PROJECTS COMPLETE AND SO AS THE
PROJECT APPROACHES TO
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER WAYS TO OVERSEE THE
COMPLETION. OF THAT REMAINING
BACKLOG THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YES CENTER NIELSEN.
THE DALLAS WELL. I'M NOT
WILLING TO JUST LEAVE THAT
LOOSE ENDED HOW COULD WE TIE
THAT UP IN OTHER WORDS YOU
YOU'RE VOICING CONCERNS THAT I.
CERTAINLY DO SHARE. AND WHAT
KIND OF CONTROL MECHANISMS AND
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT REPORTING
REPORTING IS ABOUT IS IT
INEFFECTIVE IS ANYTHING GOING
GOOD JUST. SEND US A LETTER.
WHAT KIND OF CONTROL MECHANISMS
COULD WE PLACE IN THE BUDGET TO
TRACK AND KEEP THIS THING
ONLINE YOU KIND OF INTIMATED
THAT THERE SOMETHING WE COULD
DO WHAT WOULD THAT BE TO THE
ANALYST. I WOULD SAY THAT THE
FORMAL PROJECT OVERSIGHT
PROCESS- WOULD BE COMPLETED
ONCE THE ADMINISTRATION DETAILS
THE PROJECT COMPLETE SO THAT
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DEADLINE- WARD STOP FORMAL
PROJECT OVERSIGHT. BUT FOR THE
REMAINING BACKLOG IT IS
CERTAINLY POSSIBLE THAT EITHER
IN THIS BUDGET CYCLE OR THE
NEXT THE LEGISLATURE COULD
ADOPT SOME FORM OF BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE OR OTHER REPORTING
LANGUAGE TO. IDENTIFY THOSE
ITEMS THAT ARE CONSIDERED
ENHANCEMENTS OR FUNCTIONALITIES
THAT WERE MOVED OUT OF THE
PROJECT SCOPE AND TO HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION FORMALLY REPORT
ON THOSE OR TO HAVE OUR OFFICE
OR SOME OTHER- OVERSIGHT
ENTITIES SUCH AS THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY CONTINUE TO
REPORT ON THAT. THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROGRESS- IN
COMPLETING THOSE ITEMS WELL I
HAVE NOT THE HIGHEST DEGREE OF
CONFIDENCE IN THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY WHAT THEY'RE BEST AT
IS CHANGING THE NAME. I'M BEING
A LITTLE BIT FACETIOUS BUT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN CONTROL
OF THESE EXCESSIVE OVERRUNS.
AND TECHNOLOGY. MATTER THAT
WE'RE PUTTING THIS ALL AROUND
THE A CHAIR YES THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HERE IF WE MAY
I'D LIKE TO KIND OF. HAVE OUR-
TO GET. MAJEURE MINORITY STAFF
WORK WITH THE ALLEGE ANALYST IN
THE DEPARTMENT AND TO TRY TO
CLARIFY WHAT THAT LANGUAGES
AND- GET IT IN THIS YEAR RATHER
THAN TO WAIT TILL NEXT YEAR AND
IT'S NEBULOUS AND WHATEVER IT
DID. IT WOULD IT'S NO HARM I
DON'T THINK TO DO THAT AND IT
WOULD BE A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO HAVE US NOT LEAVE
THINGS SO OPEN ENDED AND- VAGUE
THAT WE CAN. MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET THE JOB DONE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I THINK THAT MIGHT BE GOOD
DIRECTION TO GIVE TO THAT. TO
STAFF. AT THIS CENTER ON. THE
MANAGER YOU KNOW- I'M NOT SURE
ABOUT TO OFFERING IN ASKING
TOUGH QUESTIONS AND CERTAINLY
HAVE FOR THINK I HAVE IN THE
PAST ON IT PROJECTS IN THE
YEARS THAT HAVE PASSED. BUT IT
CAN GOING THROUGH THIS AGENDA I
WAS THINKING BACK AND IT SEEMS
THAT NOW AS OLD AS I AM THAT
I'VE BEEN AROUND- CERTAINLY
NEAR THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PROJECT AT LEAST FROM THE
OPERATIONAL STANDPOINT. AND
IT'S BEEN A LONG ROAD. AND
SOMETIMES THAT ROAD HAS BEEN
AND- A LITTLE BUMPY AND IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT BEEN. AN
EXPENSIVE TO GET TO WHERE WE
ARE WITH THIS CRITICAL PROJECT.
BUT WE'RE ALMOST TO THE FINISH
LINE WITH WHAT APPEARS TO BE.
THE SUCCESSFUL A LARGE VERY
LARGE SUCCESSFUL IT PROJECT AND
I THINK THAT SOME NOTEWORTHY
AND I WANTED TO BE ONE TO SAY
THAT. YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
CONTINUED OVERSIGHT TO ON IT
PROJECTS AND OTHERPROJECTS AS
A AND R. IS OF COURSE OUR JOB
AND THE ISSUE OF- AND HIM
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
FIRST THE SCOPE OF CONTRACT AND
THAT'S ALWAYS AN ISSUE IT SEEMS
TO BE WITH THESE IT PROJECTS
AND I THINK WE'LL- WILL SOLVE
THAT ISSUE- WITH OUR OVERSIGHT
IN OUR HELP BUT- I AM PLEASED
TO THINK THAT IT LOOKS LIKE I
MAY ACTUALLY BE AROUND TO SEE
THE COMPLETION OF A LARGE.
SUCCESSFUL IT PROJECT IN THIS
STATE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THAT REPORT AND I JUST
WANTED TO- TO TELL THE FOLKS AT
FISCAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DILIGENCE AND FOR MOVING THIS
PROJECT FORWARD AND- I'LL BE
THERE WITH YOU WHEN WE CROSS
THE FINISH LINE THANK YOU
MANAGER. YOU SENATOR- LET ME
LET ME ECHO THE SAME
SENTIMENTS- EIGHT THIS IS A ONE
OF THE LARGEST PROJECTS I THINK
IT'S EVER BEEN ENVISIONED AT
THE STATE AND- ME YOU'VE HAD TO
BRING EVERY SINGLE DEPARTMENT
KIND OF KICKING AND SCREAMING
TO THE TABLE AND I KNOW THAT
THEY WERE KICKING AND SCREAMING
BECAUSE I WAS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ALL OF THAT WAS
HAPPENING. SO I SAW IT MYSELF
THE FIRST HAND- LET ME JUST-
SAY THAT I ECHO THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED UP BY- BY
SENATOR NELSON AND REALLY WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS THE I
BELIEVE IS A LIST OF THE-
BACKLOG OF FUNCTIONALITY THAT
WAS REMOVED FROM THE CONTRACT
AND WHERE- I EXPECT THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A AN
ANALYSIS OF WHAT WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE WITH THAT FUNCTIONALITY
REMOVED BECAUSE IT COULDN'T
HAPPEN BECAUSE IT BECAME
OBSOLETE OR OR WHY. BUT AN
EXPLANATION FOR- WHAT WHAT WHAT
DIDN'T GET DONE AND WHAT THE
PLAN IS FOR GETTING IT DONE IF
THERE IS WHEN I THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT I SEE AS AS A AS BEING
IMPORTANT BUT I WANT TOTHANK
YOU FOR THE THOROUGH
EXPLANATION FOR WHERE YOU'RE AT
RIGHT NOW I DO WANT TO SEE THE-
THE SEVEN DEPARTMENTS AND
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT BETTER
WHAT SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT THEY'RE FACING AND NOT
GETTING THEIR- THEIR WORK DONE-
AND- AND WHEN IT WILL BE DONE
BECAUSE IT BECOMES CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WITH THAT WE NEED TO
CLOSE OUT THE BOOKS THERE IS NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT AND- IT'S
LONG OVERDUE SO. ANY
EXPLANATION. FOR THAT IT WOULD
BE REALLY REALLY HELPFUL. THE
NOW FOR THE COURT. THIS IS A
NEW. ITEM I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION HERE
TODAY TODAY IT'S BEEN VERY
THOROUGH. AND WE WILL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY TWO.
WHICH IS UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES THANK YOU
OFFER FOR BEING HERE. ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE IS THE
PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BILL TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. ASK THE
DEPARTMENT TO PRESENT. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE A CAREER- AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JASON KENNEY I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR REAL ESTATE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES- IF YOU TWENTY ONE
BEFORE YOU IS R. T. BL FOR
PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BUILD
OPERATE DESIGN BUILD IS A
DELIVERY METHOD THAT
STREAMLINES THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS FOR PROJECT GREATLY
REDUCING BOTH PROJECT SCHEDULES
AND COSTS ASSOCIATED COSTS- AS
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF HAS KEENLY
WRITTEN UP IN THE AGENDA
PROGRESSIVE RETAINS THE
BENEFITS OF TRADITIONAL DESIGN
BUILD OVER OTHER DELIVERY
METHODS. BUT ELIMINATE SOME OF
THE NONESSENTIAL PROCESS SEES
THAT BOG DOWN TIME FRAMES-
DEBILITATION THE NEW NATURAL
RESOURCES HAVE A HEADQUARTERS
PROJECT WHICH IS JUST DOWN THE
STREET FROM THE CAPITOL IS
FINISHING CONSTRUCTION IN JULY
THE PROJECT WAS AUTHORIZED TO
GO TRADITIONAL DESIGN BUILD- WE
WERE GIVEN OUR INITIAL
AUTHORIZATION THE LEGISLATURE
TO START DEVELOPMENT IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN JULY TWENTY SIXTEEN. WE
AWARDED A CONTRACT TO BEGIN
BUILDING AND MARCH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND CONSTRUCTION WILL
END OF THIS JULY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OVERALL START TO FINISH
FROM THE WORD GO WAS ABOUT FIVE
YEARS- WE ARE FINISHING AHEAD
OF SCHEDULE- BUT WITH
PROGRESSIVE WE CAN DO BETTER-
THE CASE STUDY BY WAY OF
CONTRAST IS THE TEN BUT NO
BUILDING WHICH IS ALSO JUST
DOWN THE STREET FROM THE
CAPITOL- IT'S THE BUILDING THAT
WILL HOUSE THE GOVERNOR
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE DURING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE NEW CAPITOL
ANNEX. IT WAS AUTHORIZED TO BE
DELIVERED VIA PROGRESSIVE
DESIGN BUILD- AND IT WAS THE
STATE'S FIRST PROJECT USING
THAT METHOD- THE PROJECT WAS
AUTHORIZED TO BEGIN DEVELOPMENT
IN JULY TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO TWO
YEARS AFTER THE RESOURCES
BUILDING- WE BROKE GROUND IN
EIGHT MONTHS AND IT BE FINISHED
IN THIS OCTOBER NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY ONE JUST A FEW MONTHS
AFTER THE RESOURCES BUILDING-
SO NOT ONLY IS A SIGNIFICANTLY
FASTER BUT THE INCREASE SPEED
REDUCE THE PROJECT'S ESCALATION
COSTS BY ABOUT THIRTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS- WE ARE
PROPOSING TO USE THIS LIMITED
FOR THE THREE RENOVATION.
PROJECTS BEFORE YOU- AND- IN
DOING SO- WILL HAVE REDUCE THE-
PRICE BUDGET FOR THOSE PER.
THANK THIRTEEN MILLION- OUR
LANGUAGE BEFORE YOU AS THE
ENDORSED BY THE NATIONAL BOARD
OF THE DESIGN BUILD INSTITUTE
OF AMERICA. AS WLL AS THE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA AND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PROPOSED
PROCESS THAT YOU MIGHT HOUSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
APARTMENT OF FINANCE. HELLO
COMING FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PRETTY GOOD HOW BOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. SORT OF BORED WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE DID NOT RAISE CONCERNS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD COMMENTER
QUESTIONS FROM. COMMITTEE LET
ME JUST SAY THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- I THINK IT'S A- THE
MUCH BETTER- DESIGN BUILD-
PROCESS THAT IN MY MIND
PRODUCES A PRODUCT IN LESS TIME
AND COST LESS MONEY TO ALWAYS A
GOOD THING SO THIS IS AN ITEM
THAT- FOR WHICH WE WILL ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION SO WE'LL BE
TAKING THIS UP FOR A VOTE LATER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
TWO. WHICH IS THE SACRAMENTO
REGION GREGORY BATESON BUILDING
RENOVATION. WELL HOLD ON JUST A
SECOND. THIS. ACTUALLY I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO TAKE UP ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE WE HAVE. HI
THE STATE TREASURER ON THE LINE
AND THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT IS OF
INTEREST SO WILL WILL- HOLD ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY TWO AND
WILL GO GO ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE WHICH IS THE
SACRAMENTO REGION JESSE UNRUH
BUILDING RENOVATION. AND WE'LL
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT- ARE
WE IN HERE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
FIRST AND THEN HEAR FROM THE
STATE TREASURE. CHARLES MUTED
I'M HAPPY TO LEAVE OUT SENATOR
THAT'S OKAY YES- I MAYBE IF WE
COULD START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FIRST. THANK YOU. SIR YES-
JASON KENNEY AGAIN DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES- SO I'LL
TRY TO BE BRIEF THIS HISTORIC
BUILDING WAS CONSTRUCTED IN
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE IT SITS
ACROSS THE STREET IN THE
CAPITAL. BETWEEN NINETEEN TEN
STREETS. INFRASTRUCTURE STUDIES
GOING BACK TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT AND REPEATEDLY SINCE AND
HAVE RECOMMENDED A FULL
BUILDING RENOVATION. IN FACT IN
ITS NINETY TWO YEAR HISTORY
ASIDE FROM SOME SEISMIC WORK
DONE IN THE NINETIES THE
BUILDING HAS NEVER UNDERGONE
ANY- RENOVATION THE LITTLE A
SIGNIFICANT RENOVATION- THIS IS
A PROJECT LIKE THE OTHER TWO ON
THE AGENDA. THAT WAS AUTHORIZED
BY THE LEGISLATURE TO BEGIN ITS
INITIAL DEVELOPMENT IN JULY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- AND I
ACTUALLY- PRIOR TO BEING RICH
ON BY THE ADMINISTRATION LAST
YEAR WAS APPROVED TO MOVE
FORWARD TO THE SECOND PHASE- BY
THE SUBCOMMITTEE- THE- VACATING
OF THE FUNDERS AND BUILDING- AS
PART OF THE NEW NATURAL
RESOURCES PROJECT WILL ALLOW
US. TO RELOCATE TENANTS TO THAT
BUILDING- PRIMARILY THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE AND GIVE US
A ONCE IN A LIFETIME
OPPORTUNITY TO RENOVATE THE
BUILDING AS IT SO DESPERATELY
NEEDS- AS YOU CAN IMAGINE WITH
A NINETY TWO YEAR OLD BUILDING
THE WORKING NEEDED TO PRESERVE
IT IS EXTENSIVE. THE NECESSARY
SCOPE OF WORK INCLUDES THE
REPLACEMENT OF EVERY MAJOR
BUILDING SYSTEM CUTTING
ELEVATORS PLUMBING HEATING
VENTILATION AIR CONDITIONING
ELECTRICAL TELECOM AND SECURITY
AS WELL ADDRESSING SOME
CRITICAL FIRE LIFE SAFETY
ISSUES- ALL SYSTEMS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY BEYOND THEIR
USEFUL LIFE IN DANGER OF
FAILING. AND THE UNDER BUILDING
IN PARTICULAR HAS A SIGNIFICANT
WATER INTRUSION ISSUE THAT PUTS
THE BUILDING IN DANGER OF
FALLING INTO A PERMANENT STATE
OF DISREPAIR. OTHER PROPOSED
RENOVATION LIKE ALL OF OUR
OTHER NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
RENOVATION PROJECTS THAT WE ARE
WORKING ON- WILL BE FULLY
TELEWORK ENABLED- IN FACT WE
HAVE HAD SOME. PRETTY
REMARKABLE SUCCESSES IN OUR NEW
BUILDINGS- INCREASING. DENSITY
WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL BUILDING-
AND OUR DESIGN PRINCIPLE- WE
ARE PRO THE PRIME WITH OUR LINE
WITH. DESIGN GUY. ON POST COBIT
BILL- THIS FOR. AND ALL KIND OF
DO IS REACH THEM BUT THIS. WILL
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
THE STATE'S ECONOMY- ARE A
COMMUNIST PROJECTS RENOVATION
WHAT WILL DIRECTLY AND
INDIRECTLY CREATE OVER ELEVEN
HUNDRED JOBS OVER ITS- OVER ITS
LIFETIME. WHICH DOESN'T TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THE POSITIVE
EFFECTS OF KEEPING SUPPLIERS
COMPANIES IN BUSINESS RATHER
THAN LAYING THEM OFF- THE
PROJECT WILL ALSO HAVE SKILLED
LABOR AGREEMENTS- ALL
CONSTRUCTION JOBS WILL PROVIDE
A LIVING WAGE AS WELL AS THE
SKILLS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR A
LIFETIME OF WORK. AND THE
PROJECT WILL INCLUDE COMMUNITY
WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS WHICH WE
HIGHLIGHTED IN OUR OTHER
SACRAMENTO PROJECTS WHICH
BRINGS THE FOCUS ON EQUITY IN
FUTURE EMPLOYMENT THAT- IS
UNHEARD OF FOR STATE PROJECTS.
ARE FINALLY TWO QUICK NOTES ONE
IS THE- JESSIE I'M BUILDING
DOES HAVE A FOR A STARK
FOUNTAIN OUTSIDE THAT IS
MENTIONED IN THE AGENDA- OUR
OFFICIAL PROPOSAL TAKES A DO
NOTHING APPROACH WITH THE FOUND
WE'RE NOT. REQUESTING MONEY OR
AUTHORITY FOR IT THERE'S NO
FUNDING IN THE PROJECT REQUEST
TO RENOVATE IT. NO FUNDING
PROPOSED TO DEMOLISH IT EITHER-
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN SENT LETTERS
I KNOW YOU'LL LIKELY HEAR
PUBLIC COMMENT- WE HAVE NO-
PROJECTIONS OR OR CONCERNS- IF
YOU WERE ASKED TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH. THE RENOVATION OF THE
FOUNTAIN AS WELL AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY- AFTER I TREASURE
MAS- TESTIMONY AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR.
COMMENTS THAT MAY ARISE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DEPARTMENT IF I. DEPARTMENT
FINANCE DOESN'T HAVE ANY
COMMENT. HOW ABOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
SO MORE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE ALSO DID NOT RAISE
CONCERNS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE
ON TO THE STATE TREASURER FIONA.
WELCOME TO MEDICARE CABALLERO
MEMBER NIELSEN AS WELL AS
MEMBER ROSS I AM HERE TO
EXPRESS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
TIMING OF THE RENOVATIONS FOR
THE CHEST ON REBUILDING YOU
SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED A LETTER
PRETTY EXTENSIVE LETTER THAT.
WAS SENT TO DGS DATED FEBRUARY
FIRST- ELIMINATING A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT CONCERNS BUT DUE TO
THE TIME CONSTRAINTS HERE I'M
JUST GOING TO FOCUS ON THREE IN
PARTICULAR. ONE DGS ESTIMATES A
TOTAL RENOVATION PROJECT COST
FOR THIS BUILDING WILL BE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IS A 43% INCREASE OVER
THE ESTIMATED COST OF NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET I HEARD
MR KINNEY'S- PRIOR TESTIMONY
THAT THE DESIGN BUILD IS GOING
TO REDUCE COST YET. THE BUDGET
FOR THIS BUILDING HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED BY 43%
SINCE THE LAST BUDGET NUMBER
TWO WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH DGS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN ENDED TWENTY
TWENTY WITH DESIGN CONCEPTS FOR
THE REHABILITATION OF THIS DID
NOT TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION OF
THE PANDEMIC. AND THE NEW
CHANGES THAT A DESIGN CHANGES
THAT MAY BE NEEDED TO
ACCOMMODATE MY FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EMPLOYEES AND NUMBER
THREE THE GOVERNOR ISSUED HIS
STATE FACILITY LONG RANGE
PLANNING STUDY. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. IS THAT THE TOP TWO
NINE BILL THAT DEACON. LISTED
AS THE WORST OF BUILDINGS THAT
NEEDED TO BE RENOVATED. MISTER
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE NUMBER
ONE BUILDING THAT IS ALMOST
DONE. NUMBER TWO AND NUMBER
THREE ON THE LIST ARE NOT
PLANNED TO BE DONE ACCORDING TO
OUR MEETING WITH DGS A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO THAT THEY WERE GONNA
BE USED TO SWING SPACE. NUMBER
FOUR IS THE EDB BUILDING AND
THE NUMBER FIVE IS THE ON ROUTE
BUILDING AND THE PROPOSAL IS TO
MOVE OUR EMPLOYEES IN TO THE
BONNER ST BUILDING WHICH IS THE
NUMBER THREE WORSE BUILDING. SO
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
CHARGERS OFFICE BEING THE
NUMBER FIVE WAS BUILDING WILL
BE INTO THE NUMBER THREE WORST
BUILDING. IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO.
RENOVATE BUILDINGS NUMBER TWO
AND NUMBER THREE THEN. IS THIS
STUDY REALLY ACCURATE. AND THAT
WAS. MY CONCERN IS MOVING US
INTO A WORSE RATED BUILDING.
NUMBER FOUR EDT THEIR NUMBER
FOUR ON THE LIST PERHAPS. THE
GOVERNOR SHOULD RENOVATE THE
EDT BUILDING FIRST. GIVEN THE
SITUATION THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW WITH. FURLOUGHS WITH
LAYOFFS. WITH DEFERRALS TO THE
SCHOOLS I SMALL BUSINESSES
SUFFERING IN THE STATE NOW IS
NOT A GOOD TIMING. IN MY
OPINION TO BE RENOVATING MY
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE
BUILDING I'VE ALSO HAD MEMBERS
IN THE STATE BUILDING FOR
THIRTY. THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND
THEY HAVE NOT EXPRESSED ANY
CONCERNS WITH ANY OF THE LIFE
OR SAFETY OR OTHER MEASURES-
THAT- THAT WERE. DISCUSSED
EARLIER SO I JUST THINK THE
TIMING IS REALLY BAD- YOU KNOW
PERHAPS WE CAN DISCUSS THIS IN
A COUPLE OF YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD. AGAIN MOVING US FROM THE
NUMBER FIVE WORST BUILDING TO
THE NUMBER THREE WORST
BUILDING. IS NOT ACCEPTABLE I'M
TO ME OR MY TEAM SO. THOSE ARE
MY CONCERN HERE TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY I'M GONNA SEE IF ANY
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SENATE ROTH
OR NOT BUT PERHAPS NOT I'M SURE
SOMEBODY COULD ADDRESS THE
SEQUENCING OF THE- RENOVATION
PROJECTS FOR US BECAUSE I'M-
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
TREASURES- I REQUEST HERE IS
AND I GUESS AT THE END IT IS
NOT LEAVE US ALONE FOR RIGHT
NOW AND GET TO US LATER AND- I
GUESS THAT'S OKAY AS LONG AS
THE- HVAC SYSTEM AND THE WATER
SYSTEM IN THE ELEVATORS DON'T
FAIL AND I GUESS WE'LL HAVE TO.
ADDRESS A DIFFERENT TO.
SEQUENCING BUT ON THE BASE
QUESTION. RENOVATING BUILDING
NUMBER FIVE BEFORE WE RUN OF A
BUILDING NUMBER TWO AND NUMBER
THREE OR THREE OR FOUR. I'D
LIKE FOR SOMEBODY TO ADDRESS
THAT. I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
CENTER- SO JASON CAN AGAIN. D.
I THINK THE I AM BACK UP A
LITTLE BIT- TO GIVE SOME
CONTEXT SO YES. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN DGS DID COMMISSION OUR
CALL TO STILL BE CONDITION
ASSESSMENTS. ASSEMBLY CONDITION
ASSESSMENTS ARE- A TIME HONORED
INDUSTRY METHODOLOGY ARE DOING
RELATIVELY RAPID AND
INEXPENSIVE REVIEWS- COMPARED
TO THE EAST ABOUT FULL BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE STUDY I WISH YOU
TAKE A LOT LONGER IN BEIN
CONSIDERABLY EXPENSIVE. AND
PROBLEMATIC WITH THE IN
OCCUPIED BUILDINGS SO SCA'S OUR
WAY OF GOING THROUGH ITS OWN
CATALOGING. ISSUES IN THE
BUILDING THEY DON'T CATALOG
EVERYTHING BECAUSE WE CAN'T-
AND IT'S MOSTLY A FINANCIAL
ANALYSIS THEY'RE LOOKING AT
WHAT IMMEDIATE WORK NEEDS TO
HAPPEN TO KEEP THE BUILDING
OPERATIONAL- AND WHAT SORT OF
THINGS WOULD BE DONE IN OVER
TEN YEAR TIME FRAMES. AND AGAIN
TO KEEP THE BUILDING
OPERATIONAL OR AT LEAST IN THE
MEDIUM TERM NOT REALLY LOOKING
AT A LONG LONG LONG TERM
PROPOSITION AND A COMPARING
THAT TO THE COST TO REPLACE THE
BUILDING- AND SO IN THAT SENSE-
WE DID DO A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW OF OUR ENTIRE PORTFOLIO
AND BUILDINGS WERE RIGHT.
HOWEVER THAT STUDY WAS NEVER
INTENDED TO BE THE SOLE SOURCE
OF DATA FOR THE SOLE BASIS FOR
PRIORITIZATION OF RENOVATIONS.
WE HAVE BUILDINGS THAT ARE
PORTFOLIO- THAT WE HAVE HAD
INFRASTRUCTURE STUDIES DONE.
FOR YEARS ON A GROUP BEING ONE
OF THEM- THERE ARE ALSO OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS LIKE THE
SEVERITY OF THE ISSUES AND SO-
WHILE BOTH BUILDINGS NFCA MIGHT
HAVE. HOUSES CEREALS YOU KNOW
IT'S MUCH MORE SEVERE IN THE
UNDER BUILDING- FIRE LIFE
SAFETY ISSUES ARE MORE SEVERE
AND THE ON THE BUILDING THAT
THAT- YOU ALSO PASTIKAN
CONSIDERATION THE HISTORICITY
OF BUILDINGS FALL UNDERSTANDS
OF THE AGE WHERE WOULD QUALIFY
THE STORK CERTAINLY- THE
HUNDRED BUILDING ALREADY
GETTING IS- SQUARE. FOOTAGE IS
THE OTHER BIG EAT- SEQUENCING
PLAN WILL DESIGN TO. CENTER
AROUND CONSULT. THE TO LET OUR
EFFICIENCY ASKING THE THESE
PROJECTS THEY'RE ALSO DESIGN.
TO TRY TO MAKE MOVES- THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE. BECAUSE OF
THE- CAPITAL THE FALL. WE WOULD
LIKE TO A INTO. THE BUILDING-
BIKE IN THIS BY WE ONLY TEN
WILL BE MOVING AND THEN
RELOCATING BACK EVERYONE ELSE
IS MOVING ONCE- TO AVOID MOVE
COST TO AVOID DISRUPTION- SO IT
WOULD BE EASY BUILDING FOR
EXAMPLE- THAT IS IN THE
SEQUENCING PLAN IT IS SLATED
LATER. THAN THE UNDER BUILDING
BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY IS IT'S NOT
AS- IF THE CALLS- IN THAT SEAT
IS LEFT IN THE LOWER RANKING
THAN. NOTHING. IS- BY- THE
SCHOOL FOOTAGE HERE AS A REAL
WORK WE HAVE TO SWEAR OUT YOU
NEED THE RAGE. ARE AND ON THE
BACK IN WHICH AGAIN WERE TRY TO
AVOID A DOING. ED'S ACTION THE
TEN IN. RE RENOVATION WHICH IS
ALSO ON AGENDA I WOULD BE
COVERING NEXT- AND SO IT'S VERY
MUCH SOMETHING THAT RT HAD A TO
THE SEQUENCING PLAN. AND YOUR
QUESTIONS UNDER. WHAT WHAT I
THINK IT DOES CAN YOU BLOW THAT
DOWN TO ABOUT THREE SENTENCES.
THE BINDERS IN BUILDING RANKS
HIGHER IN THE SCA'S BUT IS NOT
IN BETTER SHAPE THAN UNDER
HONORING IS IN WORSE SHAPE. THE
SEQUENCING PLAN PRINCIPLES TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION. MORE THAN
JUST THE FCA'S AND B. BUT
COMPLICATED MASS THAT WE DID A
COUPLE OF THE SEQUENCING
PLANNED- REALLY. HAS A BETTER
CANDIDATE. FOR EARLY RENOVATION
THE- AND ULTIMATELY BY
UNDERSTAND AND ASKING BE SLOW
HIGHER RANKINGS IN THE ABSENT-
WILL BE- SERVICE SPACE BECAUSE
CAMERA AND THE LONG TERM
DISPOSITION UNDER BUILDINGS ARE
STILL UP IN THE AIR WE MAY
ACTUALLY BRING THEM. IT'S
POSSIBLE WE SELDOM- I'M
ACTUALLY WHAT THEY WILL TURN TO
ADAPTIVE REUSE THE BEANS KRAUSE.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE RESPONSE
THANK MANAGER. THINK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- IT WHAT IS THE TIME
FRAME THAT YOU'RE ANTICIPATING
THE END REBUILDING WILL TAKE.
TO DO THE RENOVATION. GOOD
QUESTION- SO MOST THE
RENOVATIONS I BELIEVE ARE IT'S
A ROUGHLY TWO AND A HALF YEAR
TIME FRAME FOR THE ACTUAL
PHYSICAL WORK- I BELIEVE I WANT
TO SAY THIS WILL BE DONE IN
TWENTY FIVE WHEN YOU FACTOR IN
THE DESIGN WORK AS WELL- RIGHT
AROUND THAT TIME FRAME I SHOULD
SAY TO THE LONGER THESE GET
PUSHED OFF OF THE MARKET COSTS
GO UP. LAST YEAR THE PROJECT
COST FOR ONE THING THEY
ACTUALLY INCREASED ABOUT 7%
PLUS OR MINUS- PROGRESIVE CUT
INTO THAT AND REFUSED IT- BUT
EVERY YEAR THE PROJECT. COSTS
WILL GO UP ROUGHLY 527% AND
THEN WHAT- WHAT LED TO THE 43%
INCREASES IN PRICE. YES SO
ORIGINALLY- THE PROJECT WAS.
THE TRIGGER MONETARY CHU IS THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN RUNS IN
BUDGET EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
WISE- THE LOWER COST ESTIMATE
THAT WE HAD AND THEN- LAST YEAR
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS BEFORE
THE PROPOSAL WAS WITHDRAWN- V.
PROJECTS COSTS THAT YOU SEE
BEFORE YOU ARE ARE WHAT WAS
SHARED AND- AND SO THEY KNOW
WHAT REALLY HAPPENED WAS AS WE
WERE DIGGING INTO THE PROJECTS-
A COUPLE THINGS OCCURRED ONE.
THE BUILDING CONDITION THE MORE
WE DUG AND THE MORE WE FOUND
THAT WAS PHYSICALLY WRONG THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS- BUT I THINK
IN FAIRNESS MORE FUNDAMENTALLY-
THE PROJECT COSTS THAT WE USE
TO BASE. THE INITIAL- IN
ADDITION GAS ON- WAS THE
LIBRARY RENDON WHICH DIRECTLY
THIS FROM THE BUILDING COUNTRY
BUILDINGS- WHEN WE DID OUR SITE
DESIGNATIONS HONORING. UPDATED
BUT THE COST ESTIMATES AND SAW
THAT THEY WERE MARKEDLY
DIFFERENT THAN BLACK RECORDS-
WE WANT ANY KIND OF DUG INTO
THAT PROJECT WHICH HAPPENED
ABOUT FOURTEEN YEARS AGO- AND
WHAT WE FOUND WAS THAT THERE
WAS ACTUALLY A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF WORK THAT WAS ELECTED
NOT TO BE DONE. IN THAT
BUILDING FOR EXAMPLE IN OTHERS
I WAS A FIVE RESTROOMS AND THEY
THEY ARE UPDATED THREE- THEY
WERE SELECTED AND- SOME OF THE
CATEGORIES WHICH ARE CHANGES
THEY MADE. THINGS THAT IN SOME
CASES ARE ACTUALLY OKAY BECAUSE
THAT BUILDING. HAS A NON OFFICE
USE AND- IT WAS IT WAS FAR FAR
LESS BAD SHAPE THAN THE REST OF
THE BUILDING OTHER CASES WHERE
YES I SUSPECT THAT IN FUTURE%
BUDGETS WILL BE COMING BACK
AND- IN ASKING FOR SUPPORT YOU.
TO COMPLETE WHICH HAD BEEN DONE
FOURTEEN YEARS AGO- SO THIS
PROJECTS AND WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
SORT OF- BUT IT'S MASSIVE
STROKE DIFFERENCE I THINK THIS
IS PROBABLY THE BEST WAY OF
PUTTING IT. ARE SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE. WELL IT IT IS FAIR
TO SAY THAT THAT THE- A NEW.
NOW AND BASED ON. THE WORK THAT
WAS IN TWENTY FIFTH AND THAT.
THERE WAS MORE. THERE WAS MORE
OF AN ANALYSIS OF WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO BRING IT UP TO THAT
CURRENT STANDARDS AT THIS POINT
MAVERICK I'M JUST NOT SURE WHAT.
WHY IT WOULD IF YOU IF YOU'RE
GOING TO DO IT M. A
METHODOLOGY. OF BEGINI IS
DESIGN BUILD- IT'S A IT'S A
METHODOLOGY DESIGNED TO GET YOU
UP QUICKER PROJECT. FOR LESS
COST AND YET IT WENT UP 43% AND
SO TO ME THAT DOESN'T MAKE A
LOT OF SENSE UNLESS SHE GOT
INTO THE PROJECT AND YOU
REALIZED IT'S GOING TO BE A LOT
MORE THAN THAT AND WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO. REPLACE OR REDUCE.
A LOT MORE THAN WE THOUGHT.
YEAH THAT'S THAT'S FAIR. THAT'S
CERTAINLY THAT'S CERTAINLY PART
OF WHAT HAPPENED- BUT I GUESS
MAYBE TO MAKE IT. A LITTLE
MORE. DIRECT WHEN WE ESTIMATED
THE PROJECT COSTS AT THE VERY
BEGINNING NOW THAT THERE WAS
NO- BASIS THAT WE HAD WE WERE
WE ARE COMING UP WITH THE
RENOVATION COSTS THAT WE
THOUGHT WAS APPROPRIATE. THERE
IS A BUILDING PROJECT ACROSS
THE STREETS LITERALLY ACROSS
THE STREET THAT WAS RENOVATED-
AND SO WE USE THOSE PROJECT
COSTS AS THE PROXY MEASURE OR
THE ORIGINAL RENOVATION. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT WAS AN ERROR
ON OUR PART TO DO SO BECAUSE
THE SCOPES FOR JUST SUCH A
MISALIGNED SO NOT ONLY. DID WE
FUNDAMENTALLY. PROVIDE THE
WRONG PROJECT BASIS IN THE
BEGINNING IN TWENTY EIGHT TO
NINETEEN. WHICH WE OWN UP TO IN
THE HEARING LAST YEAR- BUT ALSO
AS WE INVESTIGATE THE BUILDING
THERE WAS SIGNIFICANTLY MORE.
WRONG WITH IT AND WE HAD JUST.
GOT IT. THAT'S I'M VERY DIRECT
AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT. I
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM I
THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE
DISCUSSION THAT NEEDS TO BE HAD
AND I WOULD. RECOMMEND THAT THE
STATE TREASURER HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE- WITH
DTS- BUT THIS IS A HOLD. OPEN
ITEM SO WHAT WE WILL DO THAT.
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM BUT I
UNDERSTAND THAT STATE TREASURER
HAS ONE FINAL COMMENT TO MAKE.
YEAH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YOU
KNOW- I WAS ON THE STATE BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN TO TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO KNOW A
LITTLE BIT BOUT THE STATE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION BUILDING
AT FOUR FIFTY AND- THEY HAD
SCAFFOLDING UP THERE FOR MANY
YEARS IT'S STILL THERE BECAUSE
THE WINDOWS WERE POPPING OUT-
WE HAD FLOODING ISSUES WHEN IT
RAINED IT WENT UP THE RAIN
WOULD COME DOWN THE STAIRWELLS
WE HAD. PLANTS GROWING OUT OF
THE WATER FOUNTAIN AND SO WE
REALLY WERE ASKING THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BACKBENCH TO
PLEASE PRIORITIZE THAT BUILDING
TO RENOVATE IT AND THEY WENT
OUT WITH THE STUDY AND THE
STUDY CAME OUT WITH THEIR TOP
TWENTY NINE BUILDINGS THAT
NEEDED TO BE RENOVATED AND THE
BE- EACH BUILDING WAS NOT ON
THAT LIST AND EVEN THOUGH I
THINK THAT BUILDINGS REALLY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN. IN THE TOP
TEN BUT IT WASN'T AND SO WE ARE
ALL GOING BY THAT STUDY THAT
THE GOVERNOR PUT OUT AND SO MY
ISSUE IS IF YOU'RE GOING TO
ISSUE A STUDY PUT IT OUT THERE
USE IT AS A MEANS FOR
ALLOCATIONS WAR PRIORITIES AND
THEN NOT GO BUY IT OR NOT
RENOVATED THEN THAT'S STUDY
REALLY PROBABLY NEEDS TO BE
REDONE BECAUSE IT IS VERY
DISINGENUOUS TO PUT IT INTO A
BUILDING THAT IS RANKED WORSE
WHEN EVERYBODY AROUND THE
CAPITAL IS USING THAT STUDY AS
THE STUDY THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE PRIORITIZED SO- THAT'S
ANOTHER THING THAT- IS VERY
DISCONCERTING. TO ME AND IS
VERY VERY HARD. FOR ME TO SELL
TO MY STAFF. UNDERSTOOD AND IT
MAKES A OF WHOLE HECK OF A LOT
OF SAN AND- I'M- I'M SENSITIVE
TO THAT- SO. I GUESS MY E. WE
WILL THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM
AS I SAID THERE'S A LOT MORE
DISCUSSION TO BE HAD AND- HI I
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT. YOUR OFFICE GETS
HEARD AND THAT WE WEIGH IN ON
ON. ON WHETHER THE RENOVATION
OF THIS BUILDING IS THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY- GIVEN EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY AND YOUR
INPUT AND YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT TO BE- REBUILDING IS A
DISASTER AND- THE FACT THAT IT
DIDN'T END UP ON ANY LIST IS.
IS A IS OF CONCERN BECAUSE THEN
YOU START QUESTIONING THE LIST
IN THE FIRST PLACE SO. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THIS. AND THIS
IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM SO WILL-
WE'LL MOVE ON WE'LL GO BACK TO
ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
YES ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO
WHICH IS THE SACRAMENTO REGION
GREGORY BATESON BUILDING
RENOVATION. SURE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AGAIN. MADAM CHAIR
JUST- ONE TINY RECOGNITION
WOULD BE REBUILDING FOR THE
ENTRY WAS UNDERSTUDIED WHICH IS
RANKED SIXTEENTH IN THE FCS-
SIXTEEN OR SEVENTEEN RIGHT
AROUND THERE. ARE SO THE
GREGORY BATESON BUILDING IS ON
THE OTHER THREE BUILDING
PROJECTS IN FRONT OF YOU-
ANOTHER HISTORIC BUILDINGS
ACTUALLY WON THE STATE'S FIRST
IN TERMS OF THE SUSTAINABLE
BUILDING- ISN'T SLATED FOR
RENOVATIONS SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN WHEN ARTS AND. USUALLY
COMES IN PLAN WAS PUBLISHED.
LIKE I'M- IT WAS A- BY THE
SENATE. DEBATE IN TWENTY EIGHT-
AND THEN YEAR. IT WAS APPROVED
FOR THIS FINAL PHASE BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE OR WE WITHDREW
THE-BUT YOU THE PROJECT FOR
CONSIDERATION. THE CURRENT
TENANTS WILL BE OUT RELOCATED
TO THE CORPORATE ALAMEDA
BUILDING WHICH IS FINISHING
CONSTRUCTION NOW- AND- WILL
RESULT IN THE BASIN BUILDING
BEGINNING TO BE VACATED THIS
SUMMER. LAKE UNRUH AND LIKE
RESOURCES WHICH ALL TESTIFIED
TO THE MINUTE- WEDNESDAY
CREATED BE- WELL THE ONCE IN A
LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY READ THE BIG BUILDING-
IT HAS SIMILAR SORTS OF ISSUES-
IT'S YOU THE HONOR BUILDING IT
NEEDS OF THE NAY MAJOR BUILDING
SYSTEMS REPLACED AGAIN
ELEVATORS PLUMBING HEATING
VENTILATION AND- AIR
CONDITIONING ELECTRICAL TELECOM
SECURITY. IT ALSO HAS SOME
CRITICAL FIRE LIFE SAFETY
ISSUES BUT NOT AS SEVERE AS THE
ON REBUILDING- AND- THE BASIN
BUILDING LIKE ON YOUR HAS A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF WATER
INTRUSION BUT THIS IS ACTUALLY
MORE SIGNIFICANT- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE FOUND AS WE WERE
DIGGING INTO THIS PROJECT IS
NOT ONLY WAS THE ORIGINAL
CONSTRUCTION DESIGN. ADEQUATE
BUT AS WE STARTED CALLING CARDS
THE EXTERIOR TESTED BUT THE-
THE CONSTRUCTION WAS NOT EVEN
DOWN TO DESIGN- AND THERE'S
VERY LITTLE ACTION IN REAL
WATERPROOFING ON THE EXTERIOR
BUILDING. WHICH IS A VERY BAD-
BLOOD ALL OVER END OF THE
CONSTRUCTION AGAIN HELLO LABEL
IT WILL. IN IT KEEP WITH THE
DOES GUIDANCE ON COAST WILL BE
BILLED. OBJECTS SLIGHTLY- LARGE
THAN A GROUP I WILL CRAVE ABOUT
EIGHT HOW J. AGAIN NOT
INCLUDING DOWN BENEFITS. IT
WILL ALSO PROJECT LABOR AND THE
CAN YOU WORKFORCE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BERMAN FINANCE.
SACRAMENTO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. ABOUT THE L. A. L.
SORT OF BORED LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE ALSO HAVE
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE
THIS IS AN ITEM. OKAY HERE TO
THIS IS THIS IS A RECOMMENDED
FOR APPROVAL SO WE'LL BE TAKING
UP OUR VOTES LATER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT PRESENTATION.
WE WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR SACRAMENTO REGION
RESOURCES BUILDING RENOVATION
SINCE THE BUILDING RENOVATION
DAY. IT IS THE LAST TIME YOU
HEAR ME I PROBLEMS- BUT AGAIN
JASON NEEDS YES- SO A LOT OF
MATERIAL HAS BEEN COVERED I'LL
JUST BE BREEDS- ANOTHER
HISTORIC BUILDING- BASED ON OUR
RESEARCH STUDIES OPERATIVE
INSTIGATION. AND THAT'S THE AS
THEY ALL KIND OF CONSPIRED
TOGETHER THIS IS. THE MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY DIVISION BUILDING
AND OUR PORTFOLIO IT WAS. FIRST
CONSTRUCTED BY THE STATE AFTER
WORLD WAR TWO LIKE THE OTHER
ONES- THE LEGISLATURE WAS BEGAN
IN JULY TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT WAS
WITHDRAWN LAST YEAR AFTER BEING
APPROVED BY THIS COMMITTEE- THE
TENANTS IN THIS BUILDING WILL
BE- THE PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THE
CURRENTS. I'M SORRY WHO WHO BE
GOT CERTIFICATE BUT- THE P. TEN
THE BUILDING OCCUPANTS WILL
MOVE TO A NEW NATURAL RESOURCES
BUILDING BECAUSE WE ARE GREAT
WITH NAMES. ARE IN THAT
BUILDING WILL BE CONSTRUCTED IN
JULY- LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE
AGAIN MAJOR BUILDING SYSTEM-
REPLACEMENT REQUIREMENTS- I
SHOULD ALSO SERVICE BUILDING
HAS A SEVERE SEISMIC
EFFICIENCY. WHICH WILL ADDRESS
WAS ACTION REQUIRE US REPLACING
THE ENTIRE EXTERIOR SKIN OF THE
BUILDING- THIS BUILDING
PROJECT. WILL HAVE A- HE MEANT
AS WELL THE COMMITTEE WORK
FORCING- AND IT IS AT TO GROW
OVER FOUR. FIVE JOB AND CAL AS
A RESULT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE- O. F. I'M SUCH A MAN AS
PART OF FINANCE NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. VERY MUCH ABOUT THE
OHIO. SO TO WORK WITH THE L. A.
WE ALSO HAVE NOTHING FURTHER TO
ADD AT THIS POINT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SAYING NO. COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ITEM IS RECOMMENDED FOR
APPROVAL AS WELL AND SO WE'LL
TAKE THAT UP AT A LATER TIME
WILL MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE INFORMATION ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE IS THE- SCTV
S. C. INFRASTRUCTURE ASSESSMENT
AND FACILITY DEVELOPMENT. WHICH
IS THE OFFICE OF
SUSTAINABILITY- EVSC. WE WILL
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS IS NANCY
UNDER. ARCMINUTES GENERAL
SERVICES THIS REQUEST IS FOR A
ONE TIME BUDGET AUGMENTATION OF
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL BONDS AND ONE POINT
THREE MILLION IN SERVICE FOR
GOLFING KIND OF FLOORING. I
REQUEST IS DEFINED YEAR FIVE OF
OUR DGS ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
FIVE YEAR INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT PLAN AND TO CONTINUE
PERFORMING INSTALLATIONS OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE SERVICE
EQUIPMENT AT STATE OWNED AND
LEASED FACILITIES WHICH IS
CRITICAL TO MEETING
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION AND
GREENHOUSE GAS GOALS. THE
PURPOSE OF THESE BONDS IS
ESSENTIALLY TEN STAR ALEXIAD
VEHICLE CHARGING STATIONS FOR
BOTH POLICE. AN EMPLOYEE YES. I
WILL BE RIGHT OUT A POOR CALL.
FOR VERY GOOD THANK I MET YEAH
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU GUYS HAVE
HEARD FINANCING YEAH. ABOUT THE
L. A. O.'S OFFICE. SORT OF
BORED LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE DID NOT RAISE
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
VERY GOOD- HI I HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS IF I COULD- THIS
IS AN ITEM THAT IS BEING
REQUESTED TO BE HOLD HELD OPEN
BUT I'M JUST WERE WONDERING IF
YOU COULD ADDRESS TWO ISSUES
THAT- THAT HAVE ME A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED ONE IS. THAT THE
IMPACT OF TELEWORKING- DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. I THINK WE'VE
LEARNED SOME LESSONS ABOUT THE
ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
WORK FROM HOME AND GET- TESTS
DONE THAT ARE REQUIRED- AND I'M
WONDERING IF. IT MAKES SENSE
FOR US TO LOOK AT. CONTRACTING
THE AB STATIONS THE AB CHARGING
STATIONS RATHER THAN MAKING A
STATE INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MAY BE
OBSOLETE IN JUST A FEW YEARS.
SO I THINK ARE YOU RAISE A
VALID QUESTION THERE'S A COUPLE
OF THINGS I WANT TO MENTION IN
RESPONSE TO THAT ONE IS THAT WE
ARE IN IN. ANTICIPATING AN
INCREASE IN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING NEEDS IN SPITE OF THE
FACT THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
LIKELY CONTINUING TO WORK AND
SOME REMOTE WORKING CAPACITY
AND THE REASON FOR THAT BEING
THAT MOST RECENT EXECUTIVE
ORDER WHEREBY WE ANTICIPATE
TRANSITIONING TO. ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE INTHE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT AGGRESSIVE TARGET WE
ANTICIPATE A NEED FOR INCREASED
CHARGING STATION SERVING BOTH
OUR FLEET AND- WORKPLACE. IN
ADDITION TO YOUR YOUR OTHER
QUESTION IN TERMS OF
ALTERNATIVES WE ARE LOOKING
VERY VERY CLOSELY AT OTHER
ALTERNATIVES AT THIS POINT
THOSE ARE TURNER GETS AND
BUSINESS MODELS ARE STILL
EMERGING IN THE INDUSTRY AND
NONE ARE RISING UP TO THE
SURFACE AS BEING COST EFFICIENT.
FOR US AT THIS TIME HOWEVER.
ANKLES TO IT AND- WILL BE
CONTINUING TO RESEARCH AND
OPTIONS WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR THE MOST COST EFFICIENT
OPTION TESTER THAT NEEDS OF
BOTH THE FLEET WILL WORK PLACE
IN THIS AREA AND IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT AT SOME FUTURE TIME. SOME
OF THOSE CHARGING AS A SERVICE
MODEL MAY BECOME MORE
APPROPRIATE THAN STATE OWNED
INFRASTRUCTURE. AT THIS POINT
WE BELIEVE THAT OUR PLANS FOR
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE IS STILL
REQUIRED AS A BASELINE MINIMUM
DISTURB THE FLEET AND EMPLOYEE
NEEDS IN THIS AREA. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT I
APPRECIATE I GUESS I'M GONNA
MAKE MY- MY STANDARD COMMENT
WHICH FROM. I MAKE IN YOU KNOW
NOBODY LISTENS TO HIM BUT I
MAKE IT ANYWAY WHICH- USE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED WE
NEEDED WE NEEDED PEOPLE THEIR
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AND I GET
THE CONVERSION TO AN ELECTRIC
ALL ELECTRIC VEHICLE IS GREENER
BUT IN THE END YOU STILL HAVE
TO PRODUCE CITY. AND- I KEEP
HOPING THAT WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
THE MAJOR INVESTMENTS. INTO
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION INTO THE
SUBURBS AND RURAL CALIFORNIA SO
THAT WE CAN GET PEOPLE OUT OF
THEIR CARS AND TAKING. A MODE
OF TRANSPORTATION THAT THAT
ACTUALLY WILL WORK FOR THEM
RIGHT NOW IT DOESN'T DOESN'T
WORK AT ALL- SO I DO APPRECIATE
THE- THE NEED FOR INCREASED
CHARGING STATIONS BUT I ALSO
FEEL LIKE WE OUGHT TO BE
INVESTING IN. IN PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION IF THERE'S EVER
A PLACE WHERE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION WORKS
SACRAMENTO- THERE ARE LOTS OF
WAYS TO GET AROUND AND IF WE
CAN GET PEOPLE INTO THE
DOWNTOWN AREA WITHOUT BRINGING
A CAR THAT WOULD BE THE BEST
AND WE OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
STATE EMPLOYEES AROUND AS WELL
AND GIVE THEM. FREE ACCESS TO
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION IS PART
OF THE EMPLOYMENT. BENEFITS AND
HOPEFULLY HAVE TO BUILD LESS
PARKING LOTS OF AND BILL LESS
PARKING LOTS AND MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO I'VE MADE
MY POINT AND I APPRECIATE THIS
IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR. FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND WILL BE
LOOKING AT IT AT ANOTHER TIME.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
ITEM ISSUE NUMBER. TWENTY SIX
WHICH IS THE WORKLOAD BCP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY NAME'S
JUSTIN HOWARD AND I AM THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR FISCAL
POLICY AND ADMINISTRATION OF
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY- FOR YOU TO DATE WE HAVE.
HER WORKLOAD PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY IS REQUESTING
FOR POSITIONSIN A MILLION AND
ONE MILLION DOLLARS SIX HUNDRED
FORTY NINE THOUSAND OF WHICH IS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OR TWENTY TWO AND EIGHT
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
ONGOING TO FIND AND MANAGE
EXISTING AND NEW WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH OVERSIGHT
MANAGEMENT STATE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS. THIS REQUEST ALSO
INCLUDES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO ALLOW THE BOX TO ADDRESS
SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND RACIAL
DISPARITIES WITHIN STATE
OPERATIONS APPROVING THIS
REQUEST WILL ALLOW. THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY TO
APPROPRIATELY PROVIDE STATEWIDE
POLICY DEVELOPMENT AND CRITICAL
INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT OF THE
VERY SKEWED ENTITIES THAT
RECORDS TO OUR AGENCY AS WELL
AS ESTABLISHED THE STATEWIDE
EQUITY AND INCLUSION FRAMEWORK
FOR HIRING IN GERMAN STATE
DEPARTMENTS MUST FOLLOW WITH ME
TODAY IS A LOT OF TROUT SHE IS
A SPECIAL CONSULTANT. TO THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
WAS BROUGHT ON TO ASSIST OUR
EFFORTS AT SURROUNDING RACIAL
EQUITY AND INCLUSION EITHER OF
US ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE WE
HAVE. REGARDING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BERMAN OF. BRIAN WHITE TO
FIND BUT NOTHING ADAMS PHOTO.
THANK YOU HOW ABOUT THE ALLEGED
ANALYST'S. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAD
OVER THE L. A. O. US SIMILAR WE
HAVE NO ASPEN COMMENTS ABOUT
THIS PROPOSED THANK YOU RIGHT.
THERE ARE NO NO QUESTIONS ON
THE SIDE SIR THIS IS A HOLD
OPEN ITEM AND SO- WE WILL SEE
THIS BACK AT A LATER DATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
WHICH IS A STATE WIDE DATA
STRATEGY. THANK YOU MADAM.
CHAIR ONCE AGAIN JUSTIN HOW'RE
AT THE SECRETARY FOR FISCAL
POLICY ADMINISTRATION
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
THE NEXT ITEM IN FRONT OF YOU.
IS RELATED TO THE STATEWIDE
DATA STRATEGY THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCIES REQUESTING
THREE POSITIONS FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND I'M GOING. TO
FACILITATE AND SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATEWIDE
DATA STRATEGY AND CONDUCT
EVALUATIONS FOR COME OUT
CENTER. EXCELLENCE ON
IMPLEMENTING A STATEWIDE DATA
STRUCTURES YOU WILL LAY THE
GROUNDWORK FOR STATE
DEPARTMENTS TO DELIVER BETTER
OUTCOMES TO THE RESIDENTS THEY
SERVE BY BREAKING DOWN DATA
BARRIERS. THE STATEWIDE DATA
STRATEGY WILL HELP IMPROVE
STATE DEPARTMENTS ACCESS TO
DATA AND STANDARDIZED DATA
MANAGEMENT GOVERNANCE
PRACTICES. AN INCREASE
DEPARTMENTS ABILITIES. TO USE
DATA ANALYTICS ALL OF WHICH
WILL LEAD TO BETTER DECISION
MAKING. AND RESOURCE
ALLOCATIONS BY SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND POLICY MAKERS IN
THE FUTURE WITH ME TODAY AND
JOIN ONE OF OUR OLDEST STATES.
AT THE STATEWIDE SHE DATA
HOLLISTER AND SHE SHE WILL
BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT THE UPCOMING
AND SHE CAN HELP ME ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND TALK ABOUT THE
STATEWIDE DATA STRATEGY. FOR
DETAIL. IF SO DESIRED. HELLO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AS A
SOCIETY WE YEAH. YOU'RE ON. AS
THIS WE- TESTER GOVERNMENTS
WITH SOME OF OUR MOST COMPLEX
CHALLENGES JUST A FEW OF THESE
INCLUDE EDUCATING OUR CHILDREN
BALANCING PUBLIC SAFETY IN WITH
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND PROVIDING
SERVICES TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
THIS MEANS WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
GUESS HOW WELL OUR SERVICES ARE
WORKING THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS DEPEND ON US
KNOWING WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
DOESN'T WHICH IS WHY WE NEED
ROBUST DATA AND EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACHES TO ENSURE THAT OUR
PROGRAMS ARE IN SERVICES ARE
WORKING IN THE WAY THAT WE
EXPECT THEM TO WORK. BETTER USE
OF DAYTON EVIDENCE BY STATE
EMPLOYEES AND LEADERSHIP CAN
IMPROVE OUR DECISIONS ARE
SERVICES AND ULTIMATELY THE
OUTCOMES AND LYFT OF OUR
RESIDENTS. GIVEN THE NEED FOR
BETTER USE OF DAYTON EVIDENCE
WE STRUCTURE THE DATA STRATEGY
AROUND THE ANALOGY THAT IN
ORDER TO SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATE
THE LANDSCAPE. DID A LANDSCAPE
YOU NEED TO INTENTIONALLY BUILT
THE ROADS CROSSED THE RULES OF
THE RATES AND BUILD. THOSE THAT
DRIVER'S. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
BUT IN SHORT OUR VIRTUAL DATA
ROLLED WORK WORLD REQUIRES THE
KAREN PLANNING THAT WE PUT INTO
THE ROADS AND BRIDGES OF THE
REAL WORLD. OTHERWISE WE'LL
CONTINUE TO ASK OUR LEADERS AND
OUR STATE PLACE TO NAVIGATE THE
DANCE DATA LANDSCAPE WITHOUT A
ROADMAP. OR EVEN A COMPASS.
PERFECT DEPART OF FINANCE. BUT
I WAS ABLE TO HOLD THE FINANCE
YEAH WE HAVE- WASHINGTON'S OLD
RECALL BOOKS ON. THANK YOU HOW
ABOUT LEGISLATIVE AND OFFICE.
YES- THE L. A. L. SIMILAR WE
HAVE NO SPECIFICALLY OR ISSUES
WITH THIS PROPOSAL THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BOB I GOT
TO BE REAL HONEST WITH YOU I
DON'T HAVE A CLUE WHAT YOU JUST
SAID IN REGARDS TO. ADD DATA
MANAGEMENT WHAT WHAT YOU WOULD
USE IT FOR ME JUST SAY THAT
THAT DATA FOR DATA SAKE.
DOESN'T DO MUCH FOR US- THE
DATA HAS TO BE RELATIVE TO
WHATEVER IT IS THAT- YOU'RE
TRYING TO ANALYZE AND SO I'M
JUST NOT SURE CAN YOU TELL ME.
WHAT THE STATEWIDE DATA
STRATEGY ISN'T AND HOW GIVE ME
A PRACTICAL APPLICATION FOR HOW
IT WOULD BE USED BECAUSE IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME LIKE. MAN I'M
VERY CONSCIOUS OF THE FACT THAT.
WE ARE GROWING GOVERNMENT EVERY
DAY. AND EVERY TIME WE DO THAT
IT COST THE TAX PAYERS AND AT
SOME POINT WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT ARE THE MOST NECESSARY
THINGS THAT PEOPLE REALLY WANT
DONE. THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO
GET THE DRIVER'S LICENSES THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO GET
UNEMPLOYMENT WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY'RE UNEMPLOYED THEY WANT TO
GET DISABILITY IF THEY'RE HURT
SO THERE'S SOME REAL PRACTICAL
INTERCHANGES WITH THE PUBLIC
UPDATE YOUR ABSOLUTE RIGHT THEY
NEED THEY NEED A GOOD ROAD. BUT
BEYOND THAT ON ME YOU KNOW
THERE'S A THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE PUT OBLIGATIONS
AND REQUIREMENTS WE PUT ON
BUSINESSES AND PEOPLE AND I
JUST I'M I'M CAUTIOUS ABOUT
JUST GROWING THINGS BECAUSE WE
HAVE DATA. SAID YOU COULD TELL
ME EGGS. TELL ME A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT WHAT WHAT YOU
ENVISION. OUT OF THIS GROUP OF
PEOPLE AND HOW IT'S GOING TO
HELP TO RUN. TO DIRECT- EITHER
THE AIRPORT OR THE WATER
BOARD'S DECISIONS OR OR THE
KINDS OF YOU KNOW DELTA SMELT
IT THINGS THAT ARE THAT ARE
KIND OF OVER FOUR DOUBLE
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS HOW HOW
HOW IS WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
DOING GOING TO AID IN THAT.
SURE THOSE ARE WONDERFUL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU- AND
SECRETARY- SO FOR EXAMPLE- BUT
YOU. I LOVE THE QUESTION ABOUT
DATA MANAGEMENT DATA GOVERNANCE
I'LL GIVE A VERY SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES SO HOW HOW SHOULD THE
STATE COLLECT RACE AND
ETHNICITY DATA FOR EXAMPLE OR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND- GENDER
IDENTITY. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE COLLECTING THAT
CONSISTENTLY ACROSS DEPARTMENTS
AND ACROSS PROGRAM AREAS SO
THAT WHEN WE COMPARE. RATES OF
EQUITY OR PARTICIPATION ACROSS
APPLES TO APPLES RIGHT NOW WE
DON'T WE DON'T. NECESSARILY DO
THAT CONSISTENTLY AND THERE
HASN'T TO DATE BEEN A GROUP
THAT HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON SURE
INSURANCE. STEP BY- ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IS ENSURE. WE HAVE THE
RIGHT JOB. FOR AGE RIGHT AS AS
MORE DATA BECOMES AVAILABLE WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN USE
IT CONSISTENTLY AND WELL AND SO
DO WE HAVE THE RIGHT JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS IN PLACE SO
WE'RE REVISITING THE JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS TO ENSURE THAT
OUR OUR VARIOUS PROGRAMS. HI
YOUR DATA SKILLS THAT THEY NEED
TO ACTUALLY USE THAT DATA WELL
TO MAKE BETTER PROGRAM
DECISIONS WHETHER IT'S HOW
THERE ARE YOU PROVIDING
SERVICES IN DMV WILL BY THE WAY
DON'T HAVE IS A GREAT EXAMPLE
WHERE THEY'RE TRYING TO BUILD
OUT THEIR DATA. PROGRAM I NEED
HELP. RETAINING AND HIGHER.
STAFF ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS YOUR
YOU HAVE IF THEY DON'T THE
RIGHT DATA I'M HERE SO THAT CAN
WORK WITH IT THEY DON'T LESS
AFFECT SO WE STARTED A PROGRAM
CALLED THE DAY TOOLS FOR THEN
SURE ARE DATA STAFF AROUND HAD
TO TOOLS AND UNDERSTAND WHY AND
HOW THEY CAN USE THEM ACTIVELY
SO THOSE ARE JUST A FEW OF-
SPACE PROGRAMS WERE ON AND
PROGRAM IS CALLED THE ACT WAS
PROGRAM SO. LET'S SAY ONE TO
GOES OUT TO PURCHASE DATA FOR
EXAMPLE SATELLITE IMAGERY HOW
WE LEVERAGE THAT THAT DATA HER
JUST ACROSS THE STATE SO IT'S
NOT HAPPENING INDIVIDUALLY
THAT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF IT IS
DAMAGING DATA GOVERNANCE TO
ENSURE THAT IT ONE DEPARTMENT
GOES OUT TO BUY DATA THAT THERE
MAY BE TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION OTHER DEPARTMENT
YET SO WE'RE ONLY BUYING IT
ONCE I AM HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE
BALK OR ANSWER MORE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT ONE LAST FINAL
EXAMPLE AND SOMETHING I'VE BEEN
PERSONALLY INVOLVED IT IS
ENSURING THAT AS WE DO BUILD
OUT YOUR DATA SYSTEMS ONE OF
THEM BEING THE HOMELESS DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM. ONE THAT'S
UNDER PLANNING IS CRADLE. TO
CAREER TO MAKE SURE THAT. THERE
USING APPROACHES ARE. THE THOSE
EFFORTS SO. I GUESS THE AND- IS
INDIA. AND TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE
WE HAVE STATURE COULD NOT BUT
AROUND EIGHT AT. IMPRINT
IMPRESSIONS GET A MAN'S MAN.
HAVEN'T HAD THAT. AND SO
BUILDING ON THAT KNOWLEDGE THE
ROLE OF THE CIO. AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE UNDER THE CLINGER
COHEN ACT AND WE'VE SEEN A LOT
OF WORK DEVELOP AROUND THAT.
THE FEDERAL LEVEL THE ARE
FOUNDATIONS OF EVIDENCE BASED
POLICY CREATED THE ROLE OF THIS
CBO AT THE AGENCY LEVEL AND THE
FEDERAL SPACE JUST IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. SO THE NEWER ROLE. IN
AND FIGURE OUT- WHERE IT CAN
HAVE THE MOST LEVERAGE AND HELP
IS ACTUALLY IS PART OF WHAT WE
WILL BE WORKING. THE LEAD TO
VERY HELPFUL AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- THAT THE
DETAILED EXPLANATION AS WELL AS
THE- THE COMMITMENT TO WORKINGACROSS DEPARTMENTS SO THAT
THERE'S SOME CONSISTENCY AND
HOW DATA IS COLLECTED AND I'M
AND HOW IT'S USED AT THE MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE TO ME- SO I. YES
SENATE ROTH BUT THE MANAGER
THIS IS VERY INTERESTING YOU
KNOW. PART OF OUR PROBLEM IN
THE STATE IS THE STATE IS SO
LARGE WITH. THE NUMBER OF
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS AND-
SOME OF THEM OF COURSE ARE
DEALING WITH DATA THAT. TO THE
EXTENT IT'S PERSONALIZED IS
PROTECTED BUT- REALLY BAD CAN
BE CLEANED SO THAT THE DATA IS
UTILIZED SO HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO GET YOUR ARMS AROUND THIS IN
TERMS OF OTHER AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS WHERE. THE EDT FOR
EXAMPLE MAY HAVE DIFFICULTY
GETTING INFORMATION FROM CDCR
IN ORDER TO MAKE TO RECONCILE
PAYMENTS UNDER FRAUDULENT OR
NON FRAUDULENT THE- THE OF
OTHER AGENCIES MAY NEED
INFORMATION THAT ARE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. AGENCY HAS SOME
OF WHICH IS PROTECTED BUT
PROBABLY CAN MAY BE MADE ON
PROTECTED IN ORDER FOR THE USES
THAT ARE IMPORTANT. HOW DO YOU
GET YOUR ARMS AROUND THAT
BECAUSE OF COURSE. SOMETIMES
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS DON'T
KNOW AS- SECRETARY RUMSFELD
ONCE SAID YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU DON'T KNOW. CHIU LATELY I
TALK ABOUT A DATA FALLS INTO A
FEW BUCKETS ONE THE DATA WE
KNOW WE HAVE YET WE HAVEN'T
FIGURED OUT HOW TO INSTRUMENT
IT SO IT'S AT THE READY THAT'S
ONE SET OF PROBLEMS- DATA THAT
WE KNOW WE NEED BUT WE DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO FOR EXAMPLE THE
STATE'S RECENT ACQUISITION OF
SATELLITE IMAGERY THAT'S
ANOTHER AND THEN THE DATA THAT.
WE- THE QUESTIONS WE HAVE BUT
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW IF THEY DID
EXIST OR WE HAVE TO CREATE IT
IN EACH OF THOSE CREATES. A
DIFFERENT SORT OF PROBLEM TO
YOUR BROADER QUESTION OF HOW TO
COORDINATE AND PUT OUR HANDS
AROUND THIS. THAT'S WHERE WERE
REVAMPING IN LAUNCHING
SOMETHING HEALTHY AND GET COLD
CAL DATA COMMUNITIES THAT'S
GOING TO WORK TO CREATE
SYSTEMATIC GOVERNANCE AROUND IT
BUT IT ALSO MEANS I'M
PARTNERING WITH THE CONTROL
AGENCIES LIKE C. AND DIGESTER
ENSURE THAT. WHEN WE HAVE DATA
ISSUES THAT TOUCH THEIR SYSTEMS
WE HAVE A POINT OF CONTROL. I'M
ON THE ON THE NOTION OF- DID
EXCHANGE WE ARE WORKING ON
SOMETHING CALLED INTERAGENCY
DATA EXCHANGE AGREEMENT WHICH I
BELIEVE I SPOKE WITH THIS
GROUP- ABOUT A YEAR AGO. AND
WHAT THAT IS DOINGIS IT'S
CREATING A SINGLE- UMBRELLA
AGREEMENT FOR DATA EXCHANGE TO
NEGOTIATE THE EXCHANGE OF.
PERSONAL INFORMATION TO ENSURE
THAT THAT IS. LAWFUL AND
APPROPRIATE. BUT IT'S ALSO DONE
SECURELY AND CONSISTENTLY AND-
THAT IS ACTUALLY AN
ADMINISTRATIVE- TOOL THAT WE
ONE YEAR SO FOR EXAMPLE
NORMALLY NEGOTIATING THESE
KINDS OF DATA EXCHANGE
AGREEMENTS. I'VE SEEN THEM TAKE
UP TO TEN YEARS. BUT OFTEN
YOU'LL SEE ANYWHERE FROM A YEAR
TO TWO YEARS. EIGHTEEN MONTHS
FOR. BETWEEN DEPARTMENTS TO.
AGREEMENTS AND WHY WE'RE SCHEME
THE WAR AND THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY WHERE WITH AN AGENCY
THEY ADOPTED A SINGLE CREAM AND
FOR DOING THAT DATA EXCHANGE
WHEN THEY ADOPTED THAT
GREENMAN. THEIR TYPICAL
NEGOTIATIONS OF DATA EXCHANGE
WENT FROM I BELIEVE IT WAS- ON
A YEAR AND A HALF TO SEVENTY
NINE DAYS. SO WE NEED THOSE
ADMINISTRATIVE TOOLS THE FACT
THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD COMMONDATA
EXCHANGE AGREEMENTS AND
LANGUAGE IS A TOOL THAT WE NEED
TO BUILD OUT AND SUPPORT. ON
THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS SOLVE THE
CULTURAL PIECES AND THAT'S
WHERE WE WERE LYING COMMUNITIES
AND CREATING- NETWORKS OF- DATA
AND DATA ADVOCATES ACROSS THE
STATE AND THIS IS SOMETHING
CERTAINLY THAT I WORKED ON IN
SAN FRANCISCO WHEN I WAS THE
CHIEF DATA OFFICER THERE. ON
YOUR FIRST POINT ABOUT DATA
QUALITY THAT'S A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF WE'RE INTRODUCING EMPLOYEES
ACROSS THE STATE TO DATA
QUALITY TOOLS. AND HOW TO USE
THEM WHILE AND EFFECTIVELY AND
INCORPORATE THEM INTO
PROGRAMMING INCLUDE PLAYBOOKS
AROUND THAT SO IN SHORT WE HAVE
TO HAVE SHARED RESOURCES AND
SHARED APPROACHES. BUT THE
NETWORK OF. PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITIES SPREAD AND DRIVE
ADOPTION OF THOSE TWO ALL OF
THE THINGS WE HAVE NO HAD. IN
THE DATA SPACE. BROUGH CRISTINA
LOOK FORWARD TO LEARNING OF
YOUR PROGRESS AS WE MOVE ALONG
THANK YOU VENTURE. I AGREE I
THINK IT IT COULD BE REALLY
FASCINATING AND THAT YOUR YOUR-
YOUR EXPLANATION MAKES A MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING MORE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS AS WELL.
HI THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM SO
WE WILL DO SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE- DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
WHICH IS ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT STABILIZE CRITICAL
SERVICES AND IT INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THIS
IS AMY TOM GRAHAM THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND JOINING ME IT'S-
JUST CLINCHER POWELL WHO IS THE
CHIEF STRATEGIST- FOR
TECHNOLOGY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO JUST AND IF YOU
COULD. TURN ON YOUR CAMERA AND
SAY HELLO- WE CAN MAKE SURE
BOTH THE MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
SEE BOTH OF US. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR TOM MY- JUSTIN TO. AND
THAT- DIRECTOR COMMENTED ON THE
SHE TRIED AT THE TECH. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US TODAY. IN THE
BANK YOU JUST- IN FOR OF YOUR
ARE- BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSED ON
TO PARTICULAR- ITEM ONE IS TO
CALIFORNIA ON THE TECHNOLOGY IS
REQUESTING A SEVENTEEN POSITION
AND- LITTLE BIT OVER ELEVEN.
BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND FOR
THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- AND THE SUBSEQUENT-
YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WITH ABOUT NINE MILLION DOLLAR
AND THEN THERE FOR AFTER SIX
MILLION DOLLAR ON GOING TO
INVEST IN THE PROACTIVE
MEASURES IN STABILIZING THE
CRITICAL SERVICES. AND
ENHANCING THE PERFORMANCE OF IT
SYSTEMS STATEWIDE. AND THIS IS
A PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN
LIGHT OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACED- I IN RESPONSE TO COVER
NINETEEN. THERE ARE CRITICAL
SYSTEMS THAT YOU'VE- I'M SURE.
YOU ALL HAVE MENTIONED EARLIER
DIED- IT WAS SINCE NOT SCALED
OR NOT READY TO DEAL WITH THE
SCALE AND THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
ISSUE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WAS ON. AIR FORCE THERE FOR
INSTEAD OF IN A ACTION MODE AS
DEPARTMENT OF TAKING. OFTEN IN
TO BE SIGNED IN IN A- I RESCUE
MO INTO THE DEPARTMENT'S WHO
HAVE THEIR OWN TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEM TO BE. A PART OF THE
PORTFOLIO THAT WE ARE COMING IN
AND HELP FIX ISSUES- ANYTIME
WE'RE GOING AND ADDS A-
REACTIVE WAY- OFF AND THE
RESULT IS NOT IDEAL- SO WE
WANTED TO GET OUT OF THAT.
REACTIVE MODE AND BECOMING MORE
OF A PROACTIVE IN IDENTIFYING
PRIORITY SERVICES THAT NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED AND GET IN FRONT
OF IT BEFORE THESE CRITICAL
SERVICES ARE- YOU KNOW IT RAN
INTO CHALLENGES- SECOND BCP
RELATED TO THAT- I JUST. TALKED
TO THE B. C. PIANO WERE OPEN UP
FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE- IT I SHOULD MENTION IN
THIS PARTICULAR B. C. P. WITH
ALSO HAVE- ASKS FOR A SUPPORT
RESOURCES- TO HELP IMPLEMENT
THE RECENTLY IMPLEMENTED STATE-
BROADBAND FOR ALL STRATEGIC
PLAN. AND THAT IS THE WORK OF
FOR MAY COLLABORATION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PROPPING COUNCIL
WHERE I'M THE CHAIR OF AND I
WORK WITH- MULTIPLE MEMBERS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS
THE MEMBER. REPRESENTING THE
LEGISLATIVE- BRANCH- TO BE PART
OF A PARKING COUNCIL- SO WE ARE
VERY MUCH MUCH LOOKING FORWARD
TO HAVE A BRAND NEW BROADBAND
FOR ALL STRATEGY AND CAN BE
ABLE. TO EXECUTE ACCORDINGLY-
ALL OF THE IS IN WE CALL THE I-
WORKLOAD COMPACTS. B. SECOND B.
C. P. PERMITTING IS PERSON.
IT'S A SECURITY BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR- I'D BETTER CHANGE
PROPOSAL THERE'S ACTUALLY NO
NET NEW ASK- IT'S A MATTER OF
CHANGING THE FUNDING SOURCE
FROM. A COST RECOVERY MODEL OF
THE DEPARTMENT TO MORE OF A
GENERAL FUND MODEL SO THAT THEY
ARE FOR. INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM
DEPARTMENTS WHICH IS ABOUT A
HUNDRED THIRTY PLUS OF THEM
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA DO NOT
HAVE TO- YEAH I'D PAY FOR
SERVICES OF SPEAK- TO RECEIVE
THESE TYPE OF A SECURITY
MEASURE. AND THIS IS ANOTHER
WAY THE ADMINISTRATION IS
REALLY PRIORITIZING SECURITY AS
A WAY OF DOING BUSINESS AS
OPPOSED TO- I HAD A WAY OF A
COST RECOVERY MEDFORD TO
IMPROVE AND ENHANCE. THE
SECURITY MEASURE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. SO THOSE ARE THE
TWO BCPS ARE PRAYING FOR AND IF
YOU'RE FOR CONSIDERATION-
JUSTIN AND I ARE- HERE. TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BERMAN FINE. BRIAN ONE OF THE
FINALS WE HAVE NOTHING THAT ALL
THIS WILL. WE NEED TO HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. BRIAN
ONE OF THE FINANCE WE HAVE
NOTHING TO ADD ON THIS PROPOSAL.
RIGHT HOW ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. PRIME
MINISTER L. A. O. WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
STABILIZE CRITICAL SERVICES AND
IT INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL BUT
WITH BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
IMPROVE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OF THIS PROPOSAL CREATES NEW
PROGRAMS FOR WHICH STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE POLICY WOULD BE
MADE AFTER THE PROPOSAL IS
APPROVED AND THIS LACK OF
POLICY IS PROBLEMATIC IN THAT
IT MEANS THE LEGISLATURE LACKS
KEY DETAILS ON HOW THE NEW
PROGRAMS WILL BE IMPLEMENTED.
INCLUDING WHO WILL BE SELECTED
FOR CERTAIN ASSESSMENTS THE
LENGTH AND SCOPE OF THOSE
ASSESSMENTS HOW SHORT TERM
REMEDIATION EFFORTS WILL LEAD
TO LONG TERM PLANNING AND
FUTURE I. T. PROJECTS AND WHAT
REPORTING MECHANISMS WILL
INFORM THE LEGISLATURE AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT THOSE
ASSESSMENTS AND THEIR OUTCOMES.
THEREFORE WE RECOMMEND SOME
AMOUNT OF APPROVED FUNDING FOR
THIS PROPOSAL BE CONDITIONED ON
THE COMPLETION OF CHANGES IN
ADMINISTRATIVE POLICY AND
NOTIFICATION OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE EXACT AMOUNT OF THAT
APPROVED FUNDING THAT WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE PROVISION WOULD
BE NEGOTIATED BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS CENTER A- THANK YOU
MANAGER OF MR I'M JUST CURIOUS
ON THIS BROADBAND INITIATIVE I
COME FROM A COUNTY THAT'S
FAIRLY LARGE AND WE HAVE ONE
JUST NORTH OF US IT'S PROBABLY
EVEN LARGER. AND THE BROADBAND
DIFFICULTIES IN THE RIVER AND
REMOTE RURAL REGIONS OF THE
COUNTY ARE SIGNIFICANT TO THE
POINT THAT OF COURSE SUBSIDIES
ARE NOT REALLY THE ISSUE.
THERE'S JUST NO SERVICE
WHATSOEVER OR AT ALL. AND DO WE
HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT SORT OF-
EXPENDITURE WOULD BE REQUIRED
IN ORDER TO ACTUALLY BRENT
BRING BROADBAND SERVICES TO.
FOR EXAMPLE SCHOOL CHILDREN WHO
ARE IN EASTERN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
OR- IN THESE VERY RURAL AREAS
ARE SCHOOL CHILDREN THAT ARE
IN- SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY- MOST
OF THE RURAL AREAS THERE. YES
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION THE
SENATOR ROTH AND I WOULD ALSO-
SAID JUSTIN ANYTIME IF YOU'RE
FREE TO JUMP IN AS WELL BECAUSE
HE ALSO- PLAYED AN INSTRUMENTAL
ROLE IN HELPING THE CALIFORNIA
PROPPING COUNCIL IN PUTTING
TOGETHER TO PLAN. BUT
SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR OFFSIDE I THINK IT IT
IS- NOT. ONLY A MATTER OF-
COSTS TO BRING BROADBAND TO
DOES YOUR ROLE COMMUNITY THE
PRIMARY THINGS THAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PROPERTY COUNCIL IS ACTUALLY
HAVING MORE COMPETITIVE AND
ADDITIONAL NUMBER OF PROVIDERS
WHO CAN ACTUALLY BRAIN
CONNECTIONS TO THESE WORLD
COUNTY AND THEREFORE. DRIVES
THAT COMPETITION AND
COMPETITIVENESS ON WHAT'S THE
BROADBAND THAT KNOWN NOT ONLY
BEING BROUGHT FORWARD BUT IT'S
AFFORDABLE BY TO RESIDENTS IN
THOSE AREAS TO RECEIVE
DISRUPTING SERVICES. SO ON THAT
END- NAY CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY IT'S ACTUALLY
WORKING ON A SOLICITATION CALL
THE STATE WHY RURAL
CONNECTIVITY IT'S A MULTI TO
WORK CONTRACT AND IT'S BEING-
CHAMPIONED BY- CALIFORNIA PARKS
AND RACKS. ALONG WITH THIRTEEN
OTHER CO HOSTING DEPARTMENT TO
JUST POINT A- YOU KNOW
LEVERAGING THE STATE PURCHASING
POWER- TO SAY THE LEAST BUT THE
TO PUT THAT REQUEST OUT TO THE
VENDOR COMMUNITY. AND THE WORLD
CONNECTIVITY COSTS THE C. WHAT
IS THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY
TO MEETING THAT REQUIREMENT. SO
I'M JUST I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO ADD
TO THAT- TO SENATORS QUESTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR- THIS
OBVIOUSLY A PRESS QUESTION FOR
ALL. WORLD HEALTH. AND ALL CAL.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BROADBAND
AND THIS ISSUES MORE PER IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC
IN THE WORK FROM HOME
ENVIRONMENT THAT. OPERATING
AND- AS PART OF THE ACTION PLAN
WORK- THERE'S A PIECE OF
ANALYSIS THAT WAS COMMISSIONED
BY THE CPUC- TO HELP IDENTIFY
WHAT THE TOTAL COST OF. PUTTING
OUT A BUILD TO ENSURE GIGABIT
SERVICE ACROSS THE STATE AND
ITS RELATIVELY CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATE- BUT GIVES A BIT OF A
SENSE OF THIS THE SORT OF THE
TOTAL STICKER SHOCK- ENTAILED
IN BEING ABLE TO SORT OF MEET
THAT GOAL. OF A 100% COVERAGE
OF OUR POPULATION ACROSS THE
STATE AS BIG AS DIVERSE AS
CALIFORNIA NO SIX POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS AND OF COURSE
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE TOTAL
EXPENDITURE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES IN TERMS OF
BUILDING OUT OUR BROADBAND
SERVICES. AS WELL AS EVEN THE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL MONEY THAT'S
ALLOCATED TO READ. CLEARLY ONLY
ALLOCATING A FRACTION OF THE
TOTAL ESTIMATED COST AND SO.
THAT'S REALLY JUST PUTTING A-
YOU KNOW DOTTING THE I'S AND
CROSSING THE. T. ON THE POINT
THAT YOU'RE MAKING. BOB THERE
ARE THEIR CPA. RULE AND-
PROCEDURES. APPEAR TO BE A PET
TO MOVING FORWARD ON THIS
BROADBAND INITIATIVE THAT NEED
TO BE VISITED OR REVISITED
EITHER BY THIS LEGISLATURE OR-
IN SOME OTHER FASHION. IF THE
GOAL IS TO IMPROVE COMPETITOR A
COMPETITIVE SITUATION DRIVE
COMPETITION AND DRIVE MORE
PROVIDERS DOES OUR PROCESS
PERMIT THAT. IF THAT'S A FAIR
QUESTION. RIGHT FROM FROM THE
CURRENT I MEAN IT'S IF YOU SEE
ACTUALLY HAS A SEAT ON THE
CALIFORNIA ROBYN COUNCIL AS
WELL AND WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
WORK VERY COLLABORATIVELY AND
THEN AND THEN THE KIND OF AN
IMPROVING COUNCIL IT'S A
PUBLIC- A MEETING PROCESS UNDER
BAGLEY KEENE SO THERE'S A LOT
OF A GOOD FEEDBACK FROM THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS T. R. BOB
FRANKEN BROADBAND PROVIDERS ON.
WHAT IMPROVEMENTS CAN BE MADE
TO HELP US STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS SO THAT THERE'S MORE
COMPETITIVENESS CAN BE
INTRODUCED- SO AT THIS MOMENT-
THIRST YOU KNOW I THINK THERE'S
SOME PROCESS BEING WORKED
THROUGH IN THE CBCP UC'S
PROCESS TO IMPROVE THAT BUT NOT
NECESSARILY AT THE MOMENT
WITHOUT WERE SAYING ANY
LEGISLATION. ON A NEED TO
ENHANCE DOT COM HOWEVER I WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY IS
ALWAYS THERE SO THAT WHEN
THEY'RE NEED TO RISE- YOU KNOW
WE WOULD DEFINITELY WANT TO
CONSIDER THAT. WELL THANK YOU I
KNOW I JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES
IN INLAND CALIFORNIA NORTH
CENTRAL AND SOUTH AND BEING
SERIOUSLY INTERESTED IN THIS
ISSUE THERE ARE OTHERS OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE TAKING THE
LEAD. ON THAT ISSUE IN BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE AND I
CERTAINLY DEFERRED OF THEM BUT
I LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS SUBJECT
CAN. FOLLOWING PROGRESS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH CENTER A CENTER
NIELSEN. ON THE LATTER I WANT
TO PAY IN A WELL THIS IS KIND
OF BEEN A DECADE LONG ON MY
PART REPRESENTING SO MANY. BUT
CERTAIN DO CONCUR WITH THE-
CHECK. THAT THE- SAID OF THE
RIVER COUNTY FACE AND THEY'RE
VERY SIMILAR. ALL THE WAVES UP
TO OREGON BORDER. AND THIS IS
AREA THAT DOESN'T SOME
ATTENTION WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PROVIDERS- WITHIN IN ONE CASE
IN WESTERN TAME A COUNTY WE HAD
A SCHOOL SHOOTING- PROVOKING
AND SHOT UP IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND THEN WESTERN COUNTY
AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANY
ACCESS. TO ANYTHING. AND THAT
WAS QUITE A PROBLEM TO SAY THE
LEAST IN TERMS OF THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY. OF THOSE CHILDREN.
SHOW THE EXPANSION OF BROADBAND
ACCESS IS A VERY IMPORTANT AND
I'M- VERY HAPPY TO SEE THAT
THAT SOME ATTENTION IS BEING
PAID- SHARE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THAT WE WOULD END UP HAVING A
LOT. OF ATTENTION. PAID A- IF I
WERE DIRECTOR TONGA IF YOU ON
TO A MOMENT. THE RECTOR SONG
YOU AND I ARE VERY VERY GOOD
FRIENDS AND I HAVE HIGHEST
REGARD FOR YOU. BUT YOU MUST
KNOW THAT I ONE OF BEEN THE
MOST SERIOUS CRITICS OF THE
AGENCY. AND ONE OF MY COMPRISES
OF. THING YOU DO IS YOU JUST
KEEP CHANGING THE NAME OF THE
AGENCY BUT HERE'S THE POINT I
WANT TO GET TO. L. ONE ASK THE
ANALYST AS WELL AS YOU. WHAT IS
THE DEPARTMENT LET'S SAY YOU'RE
NOT DO IT ANYMORE YOU'RE NOT
ALONE YOU'RE OFFICE OF DIDN'T
ALL I T. NOW SHOULD. THE DALLAS
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY OKAY. WELL THE LAST
IS NOT A GOOD ONE. R. I. T.
PROJECTS WITH MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE DATING TO THE
NINETEEN NINETIES THE
CALIFORNIA PROMOTIONAL
SERVICES. THE PROGRAM THAT WAS-
AT CDC ARE. NOT ON TIME
BILLIONS OVER. AND CRUSHED AND
BURNED THE PHONE AWAY. COMING
CURRENT WE STILL HAVE BIG
PROBLEMS. WHAT ARE YOU PUTTING
IN PLACE TO ENSURE. THESE
PROJECTS COME IN ON TIME. AND
ON BUDGET AND THE PROVIDERS ARE
NOT TAKING ADVANTAGEAND
LIBERTIES WITH THE STATE WHICH
I ARGUE I THINK THEY ARE. AND
CORRECT OF TONGA WATER WE DO
WANT TO MAKE THIS TECHNOLOGY
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD. MORE THAN
AN EMBARRASSMENT. WITH THE
APPLICATION OF I. T. YES I
APPRECIATE THE FRUSTRATION AND
THE SENATE AND HOUSE AND- HEY
DID YOU KNOW THAT I BY NO
MEANS- WERE SAYING BAGHDAD YOU
KNOW PERSONALLY YOU KNOW I KNOW
WE CAN DO MUCH MUCH BETTER THAN
THE TRACK RECORD THAT WE'RE ARE
INHERITING. AND THE AND THE IN
THE YOU KNOW THE PAST FEW
YEARS- GOSH I CAN'T EVEN COUNT
HOW MANY YEARS I'M IN THIS ROLE
RIGHT NOW I HOPE THAT YOU HAVE
SEEN THEIR HUSBAND INCREMENTAL
CHANGES AND IMPROVEMENT THAT
IT'S YOU KNOW BEING MADE JUST
TO NAME A FEW IN FACT I WOULD
ALSO CALL ATTENTION AS THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS NOW HAVE
BEEN VERY TRANSPARENT WITH ALL
OF THE- PERFORMANCE
MEASUREMENT. BOTH ON THE
PROCUREMENT SIDE THE SUCCESS OR
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
PROJECT AS WELL AND IN THOSE
PROJECTS ARE BOTH BIG AND SMALL
ARE BEING ISSUED ON ANNUAL
PERFORMANCE REPORT SO JUST
HIGHLIGHTED A FEW OF THOSE IN
THE ANNUAL PERFORMANCE REPORT
OF TWENTY TWENTY SPECIFICALLY
ITEMS RELATED TO COAL BUT
NINETEEN- THERE HAS BEEN OVER
TWENTY ONE PUBLIC REPORTS THAT
WAS DEVELOPED IN RESPONSE TO
PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY ON ANYTHING
THAT ARE RELATED TO COVERT
RESPONSE. THERE HAS BEEN
MULTIPLE PROJECTS RELATED TO
COVERT RESPONSE ANY FIRMWARE
FROM CONTACT TRACING TO
EXPOSURE NOTIFICATION TO THE
ABILITY- TO. CLOSE SO THE-
ASSISTANCE OF GETTING THE OUT.
AS WELL AS- COMMITTEE TO.
THROUGH THE COLD AND I WEBER TO
PUT MOST RELEVANT OUT THERE OUR
REST. I BELIEVE MAY OF THOSE
YOU HAVE NOT NECESSARILY CAN
ONLY THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE
FAILURE TO WHAT BUT ANY TIME
WHEN THE SYSTEM IS WORKING TO
US KNOWING HE WAS IT'S A GOOD
NEWS AND I WOULD SAY AS FAR WE
HAVE GOT YOU KNOW GREAT
FEEDBACK FROM THE COMMUNITY
FROM THE RESIDENCE THAT MANY OF
THOSE INFORMATION ABLE TO
PROVIDE TO THEM IN A TIMELY
MANNER. NOW COLEMAN NINETEEN
ALSO GENERATED A NEW CHALLENGE
THAT THINGS ARE MOVING ON THE
WARP SPEED RIGHT IN THAT CASE
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE'S MANY
MANY CONTRACTS NEEDS TO BE
CONDUCTED SERVICES OF PROVIDERS
NEED TO BE BROUGHT IN AND EVEN
WITH THAT- SENATOR NELSON WE
HAVE NOT RELAXED THE
REQUIREMENTS AND HOLDING THE
VENDOR ACCOUNTABILITY EVEN
THROW THOSE VERY RAPIDLY RAND
PROCUREMENT- THE PROCUREMENT
ITSELF ALL OF THE TECHNOLOGY
PROCUREMENT DIED UNDER THE
PURVIEW OF MY DEPARTMENT.
WORKING WITH THE VARIOUS
PROGRAM DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS
PUBLIC HEALTH OR OTHERS ALL
CONDUCTED UNDER THE COMPETITIVE
MANNER SO THAT NOT ONLY SAVINGS
WORK WAS BEING BROUGHT INTO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO
THERE WERE STRONG- PERFORMANCE
YOU KNOW- WITH HOLD IF THE
DELIVERABLES ARE NOT RECEIVED
THE VENDORS NOT GETTING PAID.
AND I THINK THOSE ARE THE
MEASURES THAT WE HAVE PUT IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT WATER WE
MOVING FAST WE ARE CONTINUE TO
HOLD THE VENDORS YOU KNOW
PERFORMED WITH THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT IS SET. FOR
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
THE SENATE I. A WITH YOU
THERE'S MENTION. THAT WE NEED
TO DO AND WHICH IS THE WHY.
ALSO IN THIS YEAR IN
UNPRECEDENTED MANNER DIED. THE
MINISTRATION WITH THE SUPPORT
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION I WOULD
SAY DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY HAVE
ISSUE WITH A VISION TWENTY
TWENTY THREE CLASS. AND IF YOU
WOULD INDULGE ME I WOULD BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO HAVE JUSTIN
TO GIVE A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF ONE OF THE GOALS THAT WERE
WE SET OUT TO SET. OUT TO
ACHIEVE BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND THIS IS NOT
ONLY TO JUST MAINTAIN THE
STATUS QUO. OF EIGHT OUR
TECHNOLOGY TRACK RECORD WE HAVE
TO IMPROVE IT AND WE HAVE TO
CELEBRATE THE PACE OF
IMPROVEMENT- THE BCP ALONG
TODAY AS A WAY. OF CHANGING THE
CONVERSATION FROM BEING
REACTIVE TO PROACTIVE AND THE
VISION TWENTY TWENTY THREE
FURTHER YOU KNOW ENGAGES THE
COMMUNITY AT THE END USER. END
OF AND THE VENDOR OR FOR THAT
MATTER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
NOT AND SHE NEEDED TO HAVE THE
TRACK RECORD THAT WE HAVE TODAY
IN THE TECHNOLOGY. SO WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO GIVE A VERY BRIEF
UPDATE ON THE VISION TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. YEAH PLEASE IF
YOU WERE DESERVES. MYSTERON.
YEAH YES THANK YOU. BRENT THANK
YOU DIRECTOR KONG THANK YOU
SENATOR. SO WE PUT TOGETHER
THIS BILL ISN'T TWENTY IN THE-
OF NINE. AND SO WORK. REMINDED
US THE FRIDGE. OF COMMUNITIES
BUSINESSES AND LIVES THAT ARE
DEPENDENT ON GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS
AND SHOWN THAT IT MUST THAT WE
MUST PREPARE BETTER- AND BE
MORE RESILIENT TO MEET THE
MOMENTS WHEN THEY WHEN THEY
TELL THAT'S WHAT WE DID IS WE
WENT OUT AND I'M- PARTICIPATION
IN THE CONTEXT OF GLOBAL
PANDEMICS ERECTED MORE THAN
SIXTY INTERVIEWS ACROSS AGENCY
AND DEPARTMENTAL LEADERS. NOT
JUST IN TECHNOLOGY BUT ALSO ON
THE PROGRAM SIDE. WE ENGAGE
WITH MANY MEMBERS OF YOUR STAFF
AND STAFF- WITHIN THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE JUDICIAL BRANCH WITH
THE WITH BRIAN AND THE L. A. O.
TEAM. AS WELL AS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WE ENGAGED OVER
FOUR HUNDRED PROVIDERS
INCLUDING 30% WHO'D NEVER DONE
BUSINESS WITH THE STATE BEFORE.
SURVEYED STAFF ACROSS THE STATE
REALLY IT SHOULD JUST
CONTEXTUALIZE THE PICTURE OF
HOW TECHNOLOGY WAS BEING USED
IN COULD BE USED ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE
LEARNED OUT OF THAT EXPERIENCE
WAS THAT WE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS AND CRITICALLY IN THE
CONTEXT OF COVE IT CAN MAKE IT
REALLY QUICKLY BUT THAT WASN'T
ENOUGH WE NEED TO BOTH SOLVE
PROBLEMS TOGETHER AND SO THAT
MEANS BRINGING THE TECHNOLOGY
AND THE OPERATIONS OF THE
POLICY TOGETHER TO HELP DESIGN
AND DO THIS WORK IT MEANS
ENGAGING OUR USERS ENGAGING OUR
STAKEHOLDERS FOR CRITICAL
PARTICIPANTS IN THE ACTUAL USE
OF THE TECHNOLOGY. WE NEED TO
EASIER AND FASTER WAYS TO GET
STARTED- WE CAN'T ADMIRE THE
PROBLEMS FOR TOO LONG- AND
ACTUALLY PUSH OUT THE
EXPERIENCE OF THE USER. SEEING
NEW FUNCTIONALITY. AND THERE IS
A NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT NO
ONE HAD THE RIGHT ANSWER WASN'T
THAT THE YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY
SENATOR NELSON THESE ARE THESE
ARE CHALLENGING PROBLEMS- AND
THEY REQUIRE A LOT OF. A LOT OF
ELBOW GREASE TO BE ABLE TO
RESOLVE THEM. AND SO WE PUT OUT
THREE GUIDING PRINCIPLES TO
HELP DIRECT THE WAY THAT WE
ENGAGE IN THIS WORK AS A STATE
AND PUT OUT FIVE GOALS. THE
THREE THE THREE PRINCIPLES ARE
FIRST PUT PEOPLE FIRST SO AT
THE END OF THE DAY WE ARE
BUILDING TECHNOLOGY FOR TO
DELIVER SERVICES TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA- AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION AND LEARNING
AND UNDERSTANDING AND BUILDING
FOR THOSE PEOPLE. AS WELL AS
THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY
DELIVER THE SERVICES SO. YOU
KNOW IF YOU'VE GOT A PUBLIC
SERVANT WHO'S LOOKING AT A
GREEN SCREEN AND TRYING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING BY- BY A
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH WE ACTUALLY NEED TO MAKE
THE EXPERIENCE BETTER FOR THE
PUBLIC SERVANT AS WELL. TO WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
MAKING CONTINUOUS AND TIMELY
IMPROVEMENTS- CONTINUOUS IN THE
SENSE THAT WE NEED TO INCREASE
THE VELOCITY OF CHANGE IN OUR
SYSTEMS. BUT ALSO WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT SYSTEMS WORK AS
DESIGNED WHEN THEY'RE NEEDED.
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH FOR THAT
TO HAPPEN YOU KNOW TWO MONTHS
DOWN THE ROAD IF YOU ACTUALLY
NEED SOMETHING THAT'S URGENT
FROM YOUR. GOVERNMENT YOU NEED
AT THAT POINT IN TIME. THE
THIRD IS WORKING TO. IT'S
WORKING ALONE AND THAT REALLY
SPEAKS TO THE COLLABORATION
THAT'S REQUIRED ACROSS.
TECHNOLOGY POLICY AND
OPERATIONS OF THE STATE BUT
ALSO IN TERMS OF ENGAGEMENT
WITH OUR USERS- AND SO IN THE
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR OBVIOUSLY
YOU SEE A LOT MORE INTEGRATED
TEAMS WHEN IT COMES TO PRODUCT
TEAMS AND- INTEGRATION ACROSS
DISCIPLINES AS WELL BETWEEN
ENGINEERING AND PRODUCT AND
USER RESEARCH. AND THAT IS AS
IMPORTANT TO DO YOU IN IN
GOVERNMENT AS IT IS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. WE PUT UP FIVE
GOALS- AND I'LL SKIP THROUGH
THIS QUICKLY- AND HAPPY TO GO
INTO MORE DETAIL AS NEEDED-
DELIVER EASY TO USE FAST
DEPENDABLE AND SECURE PUBLIC
SERVICES AND SO YOU KNOW IF YOU
TALK TO ME- AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE ADMINISTRATION. WE WOULD
HAVE SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON
EASY TO USE AND FAST- GIVEN THE
COURSE OF THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS WE'VE HAD A LOT OF FOCUS
ON DEPENDABLE AND SECURE- AND
THAT YOU KNOW TO DIRECTOR TALKS
POINT EARLIER THIS IS PART OF
WHAT HELPS FRAME. THE P. C. P.
PROPOSAL AROUND STABILIZING
CRITICAL SERVICES BECAUSE THE
LAST THING THAT WE WANT TO DO
IS RESPOND AFTER SOMETHING
FAILS WE WANT TO GET AHEAD OF
IT AND STABILIZE IT IN ADVANCE.
TO IS ENSURING THAT OUR PUBLIC%
SERVICES ARE EQUITABLE AND
INCLUSIVE AND SO- REFER FROM
SEVERAL SENATORS ARE BROWN
DEPARTMENTS OF THIS IN THE
CONTEXT OF BROADBAND. BUT IT'S
BIGGER THAN JUST BROADBAND IT'S
ALSO ABOUT THE CONTENT IN THE
DESIGN AND THE OPERATION OF OUR
SERVICES SO TO USE A SIMPLIFIED
EXAMPLE- THE READABILITY OF OUR
WEBSITE SOME OF THE CONTENT
THAT WE PUT OUT INTO THE WORLD
OFTEN EXCESSIVE POSTGRADUATE
READING LEVEL- WORDS IF WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. OUR SERVICES
ARE ACCESSIBLE AND INCLUSIVE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
SHOULD BE TARGETING A SEVENTH
OR NINTH GRADE READING LEVEL.
IT TURNS OUT IT'S REALLY HARD
TO WRITE AT THAT LEVEL THAT
REQUIRES SIMPLIFICATION COURSE
WORK AND THAT'S AS TRUE ON THE
PROCESS. SIDE AS WELL. THE
THIRD IS MAKING COMMENT. EASY
TO. USE AND RE USE ACROSS STATE-
AND SO A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THIS
IS A- IDENTIFICATION SO IN THE
CONTEXT OF A PANDEMIC WHERE THE
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH RISKS TO BE
IN PERSON. ACTUALLY IDENTIFYING
MYSELF AS A THE PERSON THAT I
SAY I AM. IS AN IMPORTANT
UNLOCKED FOR THE WAY THAT WE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AND RIGHT
NOW THAT PROBLEM IS GETTING
SOLVE MULTIPLE TIMES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND WE WANT TO HELP MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE FEDERATING THAT
UP AND- CREATING THE RIGHT
INTEROPERABLE LADY ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA INSTEAD OF
SOLVING MATTER PROGRAM. OR
DEPARTMENTAL LEVEL. THE FOURTH
IS BUILDING DIGITAL GOVERNMENT
MORE QUICKLY AND MORE
EFFECTIVELY. AND SO- CENTER
PARK PART OF THE QUESTION-
AROUND YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT PROJECTS MORE
SUCCESSFUL GOING FORWARD. IS
THAT ONE OF THE- ONE OF THE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT GOES BEHIND A
LOT OF BIG TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS
IS THAT THE ONLY WAY TO DO THAT
MISTER RIP AND REPLACE EXISTING
LEGACY SYSTEMS. WELL ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO DEVELOP MORE CASE
HISTORY AROUND IS HOW DO WE
MODERNIZE LEGACY INFRASTRUCTURE
ANYMORE GET RID OF MATTER- YOU
KNOW USING THINGS LIKE THE
STRANGLER PATTERN TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE FF BITS OF FUNCTIONALITY
FROM LEGACY SYSTEMS AND MAKE IT
BETTER OVER TIME. AND ACTUALLY
CHALLENGES THE BASED ASSUMPTION
THAT YOU NEED A BILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT TO RIP AND REPLACE
SOMETHING ALL AT ONCE. THE
LAST- THE LAST GOAL THAT WE PUT
OUT IS BUILDING CONFIDENT
EMPOWERED MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAMS. IT'S A PART OF THIS IS
ABOUT CREATING THE RIGHT SPACES
ON THE RIGHT CASE HISTORY. FOR
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO
BRING OUT THE BEST ACROSS. THE
VARIOUS PEOPLE THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO MAKE TECHNOLOGY
PROJECTS SUCCESSFUL. TO PUT ALL
THIS OUT ON- VISION TWENTY
TWENTY THREE DOT C. T. DOT CA
DOT GOV. IT'S PUBLISHED IN THE
OPEN WE'VE ASKED FOR FEEDBACK-
AND IDEAS FROM THE BROADER
COMMUNITY AND FROM THE STATE.
WE PUT OUT SPECIFIC CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO- GET TEAMS
AROUND TO BE ABLE TO BEGIN
MAKING PROGRESS AGAINST THESE
GOALS OVER THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT THREE YEARS. HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND
APOLOGIES IF THAT WENT A LITTLE
BIT LONGER. THAN ANY I PROMISED
WELL I THANK YOU AND I THANK%
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND
IT'S COSTING US BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS I'M PARTICULARLY AT THE
SWEET NEWS OF DIRECTOR TONG
THAT THE COMPANIES TO DO NOT
MEET THEIR CONTRACTUAL
MILESTONES ARE NOT GETTING
PAID. I HOPE THAT THAT WAS OF
AN ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM THAT
WAS INTENDED. TO GET THEIR
ATTENTION MAYBE IT HAS. IF I
MADE AND ONE MORE. IF WE COULD
IT TO THE LEGEND. IF CONCUR
THAT PROGRESS IS BEING MADE.
THE JOURNALIST. THANK YOU
SENATOR- WE AGREED WITH- OF
LARGE NUMBER OF THE ITEMS THAT
ARE INCLUDED IN THE VISION
TWENTY TWENTY THREE STRATEGIC
PLAN- WE AGREE PARTICULARLY
WITH THE IDEA OF C. T. TAKING A
MORE PROACTIVE ROLE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT LOOKING AT LEGACY
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE STATE
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES HELPING TO
IDENTIFY WHICH ONES ARE MOST IN
NEED OF REPLACEMENT OR- YOU
KNOW ITERATIVE UPGRADES- WE
AGREE WITH THE OBSERVATION THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE- PROCESSES IN
PLACE THAT ALLOW- MORE YOU KNOW
REASONABLE SMALLER SIZE
PROJECTS TO BE DONE IN A
QUICKER BASIS THOSE SORTS OF
OBSERVATIONS WE LARGELY AGREE
WITH- WE SIMPLY REYES YOU KNOW
ISSUES WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION-
THE- ABILITY. OF NEED TO
UNDERGO THIS WORK WHAT IT
ACTUALLY MEANS WHEN IT'S PUT
INTO ADMINISTRATIVE POLICY-
WE'VE HAD ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT THE
NEED FOR NEW REPORTING
MECHANISMS FOR PROJECTS THAT
USE FOR EXAMPLE AN AGILE
APPROACH. TO DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH- ARE
SUPPOSED TO ALLOW FOR MORE YOU
KNOW BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES AND
BUSINESS NEEDS TO BE MET
QUICKLY- BUT CAN ALSO CHALLENGE
THE LEGISLATURE IN ITS
OVERSIGHT OF THESE- PARTICULAR
PROJECTS AND SO. WE'VE HAD
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WE APPRECIATE THEIR
STRATEGIC PLAN- WE CONTINUE TO
MEET WITH THEM ON A REGULAR
BASIS TO DISCUSS HOW BEST TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE POLICY ITEMS-
BUT WE ALSO WOULD JUST MENTION
THAT YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
HAS AN IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY
HERE- FOR PARTICULAR PROJECTS
THAT ARE COMPLEX AND COSTLY. WE
HAVE RECOMMENDED IN THE YOU
KNOW RECENT PAST. THINGS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN DO TO
IMPROVE ITS OVERSIGHT OF LARGER
PROJECTS INCLUDING LOOKING AT
THE SCOPE OF THE PROJECT BEFORE
IT IS FORMALLY APPROVED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT AGREES WITH
THAT SCOPE- IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
SOME OF THESE LARGER PROJECTS
THAT CAN APPROACH. YOU KNOW AS
YOU SAID SENATOR BILLION
DOLLARS CAN BE SCHOOL
DIFFERENTLY SUCH THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE SUCH A HIGH YOU KNOW
COST- BETTER OPPORTUNITIES TO-
CONDITION THE APPROVAL OF
CERTAIN AMOUNTS OF FUNDING ON
THE RECEIPT OF YOU KNOW ALL OF
THE PLANNING DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED UNDER THE PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE. NOT
SOMETHING WE RECOMMEND AS A
BEST PRACTICE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THEN IF A
PROJECT IS APPROVED HAVING THE
LEGISLATURE MAKE ITS INTENT
CLEAR IN STATUTE OR SETTING
PROJECT GOALS SUCH THAT THERE
IS AND A SET OF METRICS OR- YOU
KNOW PERFORMANCE STANDARDS THAT
ARE. APPLIED TO THESE PROJECTS
COME BEFORE THEY'RE COMPLETED
AND THAT WILL GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE MORE CONFIDENCE IN
THE FINAL PRODUCT THAT IS- YOU
KNOW PROVIDED BY DEPARTMENT SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
OBSERVATIONS THAT I HAVE TO
SHARE WITH YOU TODAY BUT HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP WITH. YOU FOR THIS
INDIVIDUAL CON TRACKS A LATIN
AND- BY. THE GM OR- THE- SAID
FOR. I T. WHO DOES THE ACT
NEGOTIATION OF THE CONTRACT H.
SO IN THE LARGE SCALE
PROCUREMENT IF IT'S TECHNOLOGY
PROJECT RELATED DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY IT'S AT THE HEAD OF
THE TABLE AND IN GOLD IN THE
NEGOTIATION ALONG WITH THE
PROGRAM DEPARTMENT- IN THE
SMALLER SCALE PROJECTS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS THE DELEGATED
AUTHORITY THAT THEY DO THEY ARE
AT THE TABLE TO NEGOTIATING NOT
THEMSELVES AND I THINK THIS WAY
COMES TO THE ACCOUNTABILITY OF
THE OVERSIGHT ROLE OF
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND WE
DO AGREE WITH MANY OF THE
OBSERVATION THE L. A. O. HAS IN
HOW TO. MAKE SURE THAT WHILE WE
ARE ADVOCATING FOR SMALL THE
CONTRACTS AND SMALL THE
PROJECTS TO BE DONE AT THE PUMP
TECHNOLOGY CONTINUE TO HAVE A
STRONG OVERSIGHT ROLE IN MAKING
SURE THAT THOSE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS AND IS IN THE FAVOR
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WELL
YOU MADE ME MORE COMFORTABLE
AND THAT'S TWICE IN ONE WEEK-
DAY BEFORE YESTERDAY I TALKED
WITH THE HAVE THE HEAD OF THE
FENCE CAL. AND THAT WAS ANOTHER
ONE THAT IS HEADED TOWARDS
DISASTROUS CONSEQUENCES IT MAY
BE THAT THAT'S ON BETTER
GROUNDS DO SO IT IS HELPFUL BUT
WE MUST TO PAY HEED AND KEEP
TRACK OF IT AND I SURELY WILL
AS THINGS GO ON DAY AFTER DAY
BECAUSE THESE ARE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND WE NEED TO BE VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT AND COULD
EMBARRASSING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT WE CAN'T GET
TECH RIGHT.THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THANK YOU VERY SENATOR
I THAT'S A FOLLOW UP TO THOSE-
ONCE CONTRACT IS- IS.
EFFECTUATED AND THE PROJECT
STARTS WHO'S THE ONE THAT THAT
DOES THE MANAGEMENT OF THE
CONTRACT. RIGHT MADAM CHAIR SO
THE MANAGEMENT OF THE CONTRACT
IT'S AT THE PROGRAM- DEPARTMENT
LEVEL HOWEVER THE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CALL THE PROJECT
OVERSIGHT CONTINUE TO REMAINS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. AND THAT'S WHERE WE
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO STRENGTHEN THE OVERSIGHT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A TWO
TIER SYSTEM FOR RISK AND ISSUE
TO BE ADDRESSED QUICKLY. VERY
GOOD WELL I APPRECIATE THAT
THAT INFORMATION AND IT'S
PARTICULARLY CRITICAL BECAUSE I
THINK PART OF THE CHALLENGES
YOU HAVE. THE CONTRACT
NEGOTIATED BY ONE SET OF
INDIVIDUALS AND THEN YOU HAVE
THE CONTRACT MANAGEMENT IN THE
HANDS OF DIFFERENT INDIVIDUALS
AND THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE-
THE OUT THE OUTCOMES ARE THE
DELIVERABLES THAT THE CONTRACT.
INVASIONS AND SO WHEN THOSE
DELIVERABLS. ARE NOT MET BUT
THEY'RE NOT IDENTIFIED AS A
PROBLEM IN THE CONTRACT YOU
START LOSING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HOLD THE- THE CONTRACTOR TO
THAT CONTRACT AND IT BECOMES
VERY DIFFICULT LEGALLY AFTER
THE FACT TO BE ABLE TO GET
SATISFACTION YOU'RE YOU'RE
NEGOTIATING A CONTRACT ALL OVER
AGAIN. SENATE ROTH THANK YOU
MAN I'M SURE YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
OUT OF THIS THE END OF OUR
BUSINESS FOR A COUPLE YEARS
BUT- MISS TALKING ABOUT HOW
SUCCESSFUL ARE YOU IN TERMS OF
PROPERLY SCOPING THESE. IT
PROJECTS SO WE TRY TO START
WITH THE SMALLEST. COMMON
DENOMINATOR AND THEN BUILD ON
THAT TRYING TO IF TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOSS
TO MINIMIZE LOSSES WE MOVE
FORWARD. I SEEM TO REMEMBER
THOSE DISCUSSIONS OF YEARS AGO
FOLLOWING SOME RATHER LARGE IT
FAILURES. AND THE VARIOUS
COMMENTATORS ON IT PROJECTS AT
THE TIME WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRYING TO SCALE DOWN THE SCOPE
OF THE IT PROJECTS AND YOU KNOW
BY THE END SHOULD SISENSE BY
THE YARD IT'S HARD SO. I GUESS
THE SIMPLE QUESTION IS HOW
SUCCESSFUL WE'VE BEEN
IMPROPERLY SCOPING IT PROJECTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET DONE
WHAT WE CAN GET DONE AND THEN
BUILD ON THAT. TRYING TO AVOID
FAILURE AS WE MOVE FORWARD. I
SENATOR ROBERT DEFINITELY
REMEMBER THAT FROM THE FROM THE
DAY THAT I STEP IN THIS ROLE
AND YOU HAVE BEEN A- VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE UNEMPLOYED AND IN
TERM OF GOSH THERE'S GOING TO
BE. A BETTER WAY TO DO THIS AND
YES IT WAS ABOUT THREE OR FOUR
YEARS AGO- THAT THE
CONVERSATION HAVE STARTED ON
HOW THE STATE ARE SHIFTING FROM
THESE GIGANTIC MONOLITHIC
PROJECTS WHICH WE SEE THEM.
BACK DOWN AS THE NORM TO NOW
FOUR YEARS LATER THAT MAJORITY
OF THESE PROJECTS ARE NO LONGER
THESE MODERNIZE THE ELECTRIC
MULTI YEARS- I'M LITERALLY JUST
PULLING UP THE- A PERFORMANCE
METRICS. ARE PRESENTED IN THE-
PERFORMANCE REPORT TO TWENTY.
AND IF YOU CAN INDULGE ME FOR A
MINUTE HERE I CAN PUT THE
ACTUAL NUMBER SAY HOW MANY
PROJECTS ARE HAVE BEEN REDUCED-
BUT THERE YOU GO. SO THREE
YEARS AGO- I WOULD SAY 8290% OF
THE PROJECT THERE ARE COMING IN
IN THE HUNDREDS OF. MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND THEY'RE AVERAGING
YEARS OR FIVE YEARS OR MORE TO
RUN AND OBVIOUSLY THAT NUMBER
OF. YEARS AND THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
EQUATES TO HIGHER RISK. TODAY
WE HAVE MAJORITY OF THOSE RE OF
PROJECTS ARE DOWN TO. IN THAT
SIDE IS AN EX. ALL TO RIGHT NOW
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHILE- OTHER LARGE PROJECT
TWENTY ONE OF THEM ARE IN WHAT
WE CALL THE SMALLER SCALE- AND
THEN THE SMALLER SCALE DOES NOT
NECESSARILY MEAN THEY'RE
PIECEMEAL I THINK THAT'S THE
IMPORTANT POINT THAT WERE ALSO
TRYING TO MAKE. IT STOP YOU
MIGHT HAVE A MASTER PLAN TO
ACHIEVE A GOAL HOWEVER THAT
EACH OF THOSE. MODULES CAN BE
MANAGED AND DEMONSTRATE THE SSS
BEFORE ADDITIONAL MODULES CAN
BE APPROVED SO THAT SO THAT I
THINK THE STATE OF ALSO GONE
THROUGH ITS LEARNING PROCESS.
FROM YOU KNOW COMPLETING MOVING
COMPLETELY MOVING AWAY FROM THE
LARGE PROJECTS TO THE AGILE
PROCESS AND FOUR MINUTE MAKING
SURE THE I. JOE IS STILL
FOLLOWING A MASTER PLAN SO THAT
THE TOTALITY OF THE INVESTMENT
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
STILL HAVE THE APPROVAL AND
OVERSIGHT FROM THE LEGISLATURE
UNTIL BAD IS STEEP PROCESS THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO IMPROVE ON THE
PICKETING THAT TOOK PLACE ABOUT
FOUR YEARS AGO FOR EVERYTHING
THAT IS IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS DOLLARS. TO SMALLER
MODULE A SMALL THE MODULE WITH
THE MASTER PLAN. THANK YOU FOR
THAT THE RESPONSE AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT FOR YOUR. WORK IN THAT
REGARD THANK YOU MA'AM SURE.
YEAH SENATOR JUST COMPOSING
POINT THAT THAT BRINGS IT
FORWARD TO. ALMOST TODAY.
SEVERAL AGO IT WAS ANNOUNCED
THAT THERE WAS GOING TO BE A
NEW WEBSITE AVAILABLE. TO THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA TO
ACCESS THE CROW CORONAVIRUS AND
WHEN THEY COULD GET THE SHOTS
AT CENTER AND THAT WAS GOING TO
BE THE BIG PANACEA WELL THAT
WAS OF SOMETHING THAT BROUGHT
FORTH A LOT A WHOLE CERTAINLY I
WAS EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT IT.
UNTIL I FOUND OUT THAT FOR THE
IMMEDIATE FUTURE IT'S ONLY
GONNA BE ACCESSIBLE TO TWO
LARGE COUNTIES AND ALL THE REST
OF THE COUNTY SINCE SIXTY OR
FIFTY FOUR FIFTY SIX COUNTIES
WILL GET RATHER THAN LATER
SOMETIMES SIX WEEKS OR MORE
AHEAD. NOW I KNOW THAT'S AS
COMPLICATED AS SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
WITHIN THESE VARIOUS AGENCIES
YOU'RE CONTRACTING WITH. BUT
THAT WAS KIND OF ANOTHER ONE
LIKE HERE WE GO AGAIN. THIS IS
A PROMISE IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO DELIVER IT BECAUSE
MODOC COUNTY MIGHT NOT GET THIS
FOR YEARS. UP TO SO WE BETTER
BE CAREFUL ABOUT OVER PROMISING
TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY I THINK IT'S BEEN
VERY HELPFUL- OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT. IMPORTANT WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING- THIS IS A
HOLDOVER OPEN ITEM SO I'M SURE
WE'LL BE BACK AND WE'LL SEE
THIS AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO. THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY NINE WHICH
IS THE REGULATIONS UNIT FUNDING
EXTENSION. HI MY NAME IS ABOUT
RYAN MARK CROFT- I AM BE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS- AT- LEGAL
AFFAIRS DIVISION- THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING A TWO
YEAR FUNDING EXTENSION. TO
CONTINUE SUPPORTING EIGHT
EXISTING POSITIONS AND PEOPLE
IN THE DEPARTMENTS REGULATIONS
UNIT. THE UNIT WAS ESTABLISHED
TO ADDRESS AN INCREASING
REGULATIONS WORKLOAD. IMPROVING
THE TIMELINESS OF REGULATIONS
IMPROVING THEIR QUALITY AND
RESPONDING TO NEW LEGISLATION.
AND SINCE IT WAS ESTABLISHED
THE UNIT HAS MADE GOOD PROGRESS
IN IMPROVING QUALITY IMPROVING
TIMELINESS AND PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL TRAINING. MORE THAN
TRIPLE THE. THAN IN THE PRIOR
YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN MORE
REGULATIONS WERE APPROVED IN
BECAME LAW LAST YEAR THAN IN
PRIOR YEARS AND ZERO WERE
REJECTED. GIVEN THIS POSITIVE
PROGRESS THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING TWO YEAR FUNDING
EXTENSION TO ALLOW IT TO
CONTINUE IMPLEMENTING AND
EVALUATING THE NEW UNIT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
OUR REQUEST I'M HAPPY TO FIELD
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
BERMAN FINANCE ANY COMMENTS H.
R. DEPARTMENT FINANCE WE WOULD
LIKE TO ADD THAT AS THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO STAND
REGULATION PACKAGES TO FINANCE
FOR REVIEW WE HAVE NOTICED
THAT- THE QUALITY OF THE
ECONOMIC AND FISCAL IMPACT
STATEMENTS ARE MUCH BETTER AND
A MORE THOROUGH- IN THE NEWER
PACKAGES THAN BEFORE AND WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO FULLY IMPLEMENT
AND EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS
EFFECTIVENESS OF A DEDICATED
REGULATIONS JANET. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LMAO. TO SORT OF
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DID NOT
RAISE CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. VERY GOOD. COMMENT TO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR NIELSEN. WELL I MUST
SAY I WAS NOT COVERED BY YOUR
OBSERVATION THAT YOU'RE
PROCESSING MORE REGULATIONS. I
THINK THE PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A LOT FEWER. REGULATIONS
THAT ISN'T THE POINT THOUGH
THAT I WANT TO MAKE HERE IN
TERMS OF YOUR REGULATION UNIT
AND THE DCA PARTICULARLY USES
REGULATIONS FOR MANY MANY
THANKS MANY MANY. AGENCIES AND
THESE REGULATIONS ARE OF THE
MOST COMPLAINED ABOUT THINGS
THAT WE LEGISLATORS DEAL WITH.
THE REGULATIONS THAT BUSINESSES
AND PROFESSIONS HAVE GOT TO
DEAL WITH ALL OVER CALIFORNIA.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE STAYING AS A
LIMITED TERM. WITH THIS UNIT
AND WE'LL SEE IF IT DOES ITS
JOB OR NOT. BUT I CERTAINLY
WOULD NOT TO WONDER SHE HAD
FULLY IMPLEMENTED AT THIS POINT
AT ALL. AT THE END WITHIN THE A
FUNDING EXTENSION YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO PROVE A LOT TO ME
ABOUT THE MERIT OF IT. AND I
WOULD SUGGEST AND THIS REALLY
IS NOT ON YOU WOULD BE ON THE-
THE AT THE- OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE. JUSTICE SEVEN
EDGE. WHAT IS IT OFFICE OF THE
MINISTER. LAW MINISTER TO
BLOCK. THE DINNER AT MINISTRY
OF ALL I SHOULD KNOW BECAUSE I
HELPED CREATE THE DARN THING
LONG TIME AGO. BUT BUT MY HOPES
WERE DASHED IN THAT LAW WHICH
WAS PASSED WITH THE FRESHMAN
SENATOR WORKING WITH A VERY
POWERFUL SPEAKER THEN LIAM
MCCARTHY. THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT DID REQUIRE THAT
DEPARTMENT TO REVIEW THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE
REGULATION IT IS MY OPINION
OVER THE DECADES THAT THE LEAST
IS GOTTEN SHORT SHRIFT IF NOT
TOTALLY IGNORED. AND I WOULD
JUST SUBMIT TO THE DEPARTMENT
DCA TO KEEP THAT IN MIND THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF YOUR
REGULATIONS THANK YOU MESSAGES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I WONDER
IF THE DEPARTMENT COULD-
ARTICULATE WHAT WHAT HAPPENS.
PRACTICALLY SPEAKING WHEN IT
WELL FIRST OF ALL IS THAT I
THINK THE REASON THAT THIS B.
C. P. CAME FORWARD IN THE FIRST
PLACE IS BECAUSE OF LEGISLATION
THAT REQUIRE REQUIRED- CHANGES
IN THE REGULATION SO I
APPRECIATE THE- WHY IT'S BEING
IMPLEMENTED IT'S TEMPORARY. BUT
I WAS WONDERING IF YOU COULD
THAT GIVE US A BRIEF
DESCRIPTION OF WHERE. THE
REGULATION GOES HOW IT STARTS
ON AND WHERE IT GOES TO AN INCH
AS PART OF THE- THE DESCRIPTION
OF WHY TAKES A LONG. MY
PLEASURE THANK YOU FOR THAT
OPPORTUNITY AND JUST TO
CLARIFY- BRIEFLY THE
REGULATIONS UNIT- IT IS. ONE OF
THE ARE IMPORTANT GOALS THAT
THE UNIT- TRIES TO ACHIEVE IS
TO IMPLEMENT NEW STATUTES NEW
LEGISLATION ENACTED BY THIS
BODY. AND SO THAT IS DEFINITELY
A NEW NEW LAW IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED- AND IT ENACTED-
ONE OF OUR PRIMARY GOALS IS TO.
ENSURE THAT THE ALLIES CARRIED
OUT AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE ARE GAPS THAT NEED TO BE
FILLED IN ON A REGULATORY LEVEL
THAT WE'RE DOING THAT SO THAT
IS ONE OF THE GOALS AND ONE OF
THE PURPOSES OF THE UNIT. BUT
THE UNIT WAS REALLY A BROADER
EFFORT FOR THE DEPARTMENT- A
BROADER EFFORT BECAUSE OVERALL
REGULATIONS WORKLOAD HAD
INCREASED- YEAR OVER YEAR AND
IT WILL BE DEMAND FOR
REGULATIONS HAVE INCREASED YEAR
OVER YEAR. AND YOU ALL ARE
AWARE THIS DEPARTMENT IS
COMPRISED OF APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY SEVEN SEPARATE
REGULATORY BODIES AND EACH OF
THEM HAVE. A REGULATIONS THAT
THEY WERE ARE GENERATING FOR
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES
IN CALIFORNIA. AND SO- THE
BECAUSE OF JUST INCREASING AND
STATUTORY LAW THAT DRIVES A
LITTLE BIT OF AN INCREASE IN
REGULATORY LAW AS WELL- IT IN
ADDITION TO THAT- THE
DEPARTMENT- WHICH WAS GETTING A
HIGH PERCENTAGE OF REGULATIONS
REJECTED BY THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW FOR NOT
MEETING STANDARDS- AND BECAUSE
OF THAT. WE REALLY I TOOK THE
OPPORTUNITY ABOUT A YEAR AND A
HALF AGO WITH WHEN THAT BCP WAS
FIRST APPROVED. WE TOOK THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REGROUP AND- AND
IMPROVE THE PROCESS AND THAT
WAS HOW THIS REGULATIONS UNIT
WAS BORN WHAT OUT OF TRYING TO
BOTH IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF THE
REGULATIONS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WAS PUTTING FORWARD SO THEY
WOULD STOP GETTING REJECTED BY
THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW. MEETING THAT DEMAND THAT
WAS INCREASING OVER. THE YEARS-
AND ALSO INTO RETICULAR NEXT. A
SPECIAL ONES TERM THAT DRIVEN
INTO NINETEEN. THAT'S ONE OF
THAT BEEN ON THE FOREFRONT OF
OUR OUR MIND OF THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF BUT IT'S ONLY- ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WERE REALLY-
SETTING SETTING OURSELVES TO
TRY AND TACKLE LONG TERM. WE'RE
HOPING THAT THIS IS- A LONG
TERM EFFORT BUT UNDERSTANDING
THEM THIS IS- WE'RE STILL WE'RE
STILL IMPLEMENTING A NEW
PROCESS AND SO WANTING TO TEST
THAT OUT. A TEAR TO YOUR SECOND
QUESTION ABOUT JUST PROCESS
WHAT IS THE PROCESS. TO EAT
LIKE I MENTIONED EACH OF THE
PORTS- THEY ARE VESTED WITH
STATE LAW MAKING ABILITY OF
MAKING REGULATIONS. J. DRAFT I
TAXED VERY MUCH LIKE STATUTORY
TEXT AT REGULATORY LEVEL. AND
THEY APPROVE THAT TEXT USUALLY
A PUBLIC BOARD MEETINGS WHERE
THERE'S COMMENTS ON IT- AND
THEN THEY DO THAT WITH THE
INPUT OF THE ATTORNEYS THAT ARE
IN THE REGULATIONS UNIT WITH
SOME OF THEIR OWN STAFF AND
EXPERTS ON STAFF THAT BUT NO
THE POLICY ISSUES VERY WELL.
AND THEN WITH OUR BUDGET STAFF
IN THE REGULATIONS UNIT HAS
ACTUALLY A DEDICATED- FISCAL A
STAFF MEMBER WHOSE JOB IT IS.
TO HELP EVALUATE ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT- FISCAL AND ECONOMIC
AFFECTS IMPACTS OF THE
REGULATIONS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS PUTTING OUT. TO THAT TEXT IS
DRAFTED IT IS SUBMITTED TO THE
STATE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW FOR A FORTY FIVE DAY PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD FOR THE PUBLIC
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO WRITE
INTO THAT THAT BORDER OR THAT
BUREAU. AND COMMENT ON THE
REGULATIONS ASK FOR CHANGES-
AND HIS VOICE THEIR VOICE THEIR.
SUPPORT THEIR OPPOSITION THAT
KIND OF THING. I THE END OF
THAT FIVE DAY PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD- THE- DOC. ARE THAT
DOCUMENT SIMILAR THE DOCUMENTS
THAT SUPPORT STATUTES.
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL DIGEST
COMMITTEE- COMMITTEE ANALYSES A
LOT OF THAT SAME. CONCEPT
EXISTS IN THE REGULATORY WORLD
AS WELL- AND SO THOSE DOCUMENTS
ARE ARE IN LARGE PART DRAFTED
BY THE ATTORNEYS IN THE
REGULATIONS UNIT- THE- STATE
ASSIST- THE STAFF OF THE PORTS
THE EXTENT THE COURTS HAVE THE
STAFF TO HELP DO THAT- THE DATE
THEY- COMPILE ALL THOSE
DOCUMENTS. THEY GIVE THEM OVER
TO ONLY OFFER PUBLIC NOTICE
THEY MAKE CHANGES BASED ON THE
PUBLIC INPUT THEY RECEIVE. AND
THEN- DOES THE THOSE FILES ARE.
GIVEN TO YOU. DO YOU SEE A MORE
GENERALLY TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THE FISCAL LEGAL ISSUES HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED. THEY ARE LOOKED
AT BY THE AGENCY THAT IS ABOVE
THIS DEPARTMENT- WHICH IS A
FAIRLY COMMON THING IN THE
STATE WHERE- THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR THE FISCAL ANALYSES AS WELL
AND THE REGULATIONS AND JUST
AND ENSURING FROM. A LARGER
PERSPECTIVE THAT THERE'S
OVERSIGHT OVER WHAT THE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS UNDER THE
AGENTS YOU'RE DOING- THEY ARE-
LOOKED AT FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FROM A FISCAL AND
ECONOMIC PERSPECTIVE. AND THEN
THERE SUBMITTED TO THE OFFICE
OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. AND ONCE
THERE THE OFFICE OFADMINISTRATIVE LAW TYPICALLY
HAS ABOUT THIRTY DAYS TO REVIEW
IT. AND HOPEFULLY APPROVING IT
AND FORTUNATELY FOR US ONE OF
THE CHANGES THAT WE MADE. TO
IMPROVE QUALITY HAS HAS TAKEN
ROOT AND OVER THE LAST- TWO
YEARS I'M PLEASED TO SAY WE HAD
NO REGULATIONS PROJECT. OFFICE
OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE ONLY HAVE ONE SO WE
MADE A BIG IMPROVEMENT GOING
FROM 16% REJECTION RATES DOWN
TO ZERO. SO THAT THAT'S IN A
NUTSHELL WHAT THE PROCESSES I
HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION. YES HE DID AND THEN-
IS IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT I AM
AS A GENERAL RULE IT TAKES
SOMEWHERE. BETWEEN A YEAR TO
EIGHTEEN MONTHS TECH GET THE-
TO REACH THE FINAL APPROVAL.
THAT IS CERTAINLY TO SAY I
THINK WE WANTED ONE OF OUR- ONE
OF THE CRITICISMS OF OUR
PROCESS BEFORE WE IMPLEMENTED
THE REGULATIONS UNIT IF THE
DEPARTMENT DID NOT HAVE A GOOD
TRACKING TOOL SO THAT'S
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE REGULATIONS UNIT
IMPLEMENTED WELL AS A TRACKING
TOOL AND FOR TWENTY TWENTY ON
AVERAGE- IT TOOK ABOUT TWENTY
MONTHS SO A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN AND THEN YOUR AVERAGE OF
EIGHTEEN. IT TOOK APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY MONTHS FOR- BY THE
PACKAGES TO CLEAR THE PROCESS
FROM THE FIRST POINT IN TIME
WHERE THE BORDERS APPROVING
THAT TAX THAT I MENTIONED ALL
THE WAY TO THE POINT THAT IS
BEING SUBMITTED TO THE OFFICE
OF THE MINISTER OF ALL. IN IN
IS THAT WAS AT TWENTY MONTHS.
BECAUSE OF THE OFFICE OF A-
THAT AOL- IS IT WHAT IS IT
INTERNAL. IF THAT TWENTY MONTHS
IS THE IT ALL OF THOSE STEPS
THAT I DESCRIBED IT'S- THE STEP
OF. THEY WORK HOLDING A
MEETING- DRAFTING TAXED- HAVING
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT TEXT
WORKING OUT THE DOCUMENT- THANK
THINK ALONG THE LINES OF LIKE
THE LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL DIGEST
IN THE COMMITTEE MEMOS- WORKING
UP THOSE DOCUMENTS TO SUPPORT
THE REGULATION- THE FORTY FIVE
DAY COMMENT PERIOD. THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS AN OPPORTUNITY IN
ALL CASES TO COMMENT ON
REGULATIONS. THE THE WORK THAT
HAPPENS ONCE THE PUBLIC IS
COMMENTEDSOMETIMES THERE NEEDS
TO BE CHANGES TO THE TAX
BECAUSE THE PUBLIC HAS POINTED
SOMETHING OUT OF THE NEEDS TO
BE CHANGED. OR OTHER OR OTHER
TIMES THE LAW DOES REQUIRE THAT
WE RESPOND TO ALL COMMENTS ON
REGULATIONS SO THAT TAKES SOME
TIME OFTEN IS WRITING OUT
RESPONSES TO COMMENTS- AND THEN
SUBMITTING IT THROUGH TO THE
AGENCY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND AWEIL. SO THAT'S THAT'S A
TWENTY MONTH PROCESS. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. WELL I'M SOMEWHAT
CONCERNED WITH THE LENGTH OF
TIME THAT IT TAKES TO MOVE A
REGULATIONS THROUGH THE
PIPELINE. YOU KNOW IF
REGULATIONS ARE DESIGNED TO
FILL IN THE GAPS IN STATUTES
THAN. THEN YOU HAVE FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY MONTHS OF PERIOD OF TIME
WE KNOW SOME OF THE STATUTES
ARE IN EFFECT WERE. THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO THEM AND
THE BUSINESSES OR ENTITIES THAT
ARE SUBJECT TO THE MAY MAY HAVE
DIFFICULTY COMPLYING BECAUSE-
OF COURSE THE GAPS ARE NOT
FILLED IN. IN LOOKING AT OUR
ANALYSIS I. MY EYES FROM THE
SENSE THAT SAID THE ENHANCED
REVIEW PROCESS IS ALSO LENGTH
AND THE TIME NEEDED TO DEVELOP
AND REVIEW FILES AND I ASSUME
THAT MEANS REGULATORY FILES. WE
HAVE- WE RECEIVE COMPLAINTS IN
THE LEGISLATURE FROM. THE
BOARDS THAT ARE SUBJECT TO- TO
THESE REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
FROM TIME TO TIME OF COURSE I
HAVE. ANOTHER JOB THIS YEAR
THAT WILL CALL ON ME TO OR
REQUIRE ME TO DEAL WITH BOARDS-
AND REGULATIONS AND COMPLAINTS
THAT ARISE FROM THE PROCESS SO.
LET ME- THERE'S A COUPLE
QUESTIONS IF I MAY. THE LEGAL
AFFAIRS DIVISION IS THAT THE IS
THAT THE DIVISION OF LAWYERS
AND IS THAT THE SAME AS THIS.
REGULATIONS UNIT THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT HERE. IT IS
YES OKAY. MY UNDERSTANDING WHEN
I ASKED. OTHERS ABOUT THE
LENGTH OF TIME IT TAKES TO DO
REGULATIONS INSIDE THE AGENCY
IN THE DCA. WAS THAT THERE IS A
PRE REVIEW PROCESS THAT OCCURS-
BEFORE THE REGULATIONS ARE
SUBMITTED TO. THE PUBLIC FOR
COMMENT AND BEFORE REVIEW BY O.
ALE IS THAT WHAT YOU'VE BEEN
DESCRIBING THIS PRE REVIEW
PROCESS. EFFECTIVELY YES
SENATOR PROF. AND SO WHEN I
ASKED FOR A MORE DETAILED
DESCRIPTION I WAS TOLD THAT-
BOARD REGULATIONS- OF COURSE
SIR DRAFTED UNDER THE
SUPERVISION AND WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE LEGAL AFFAIRS
DIVISION BY THE VARIOUS BOARDS.
AND THEN THEY NEED TO BE SENT
TO DC AGE REGULATIONS
COORDINATOR. THEN TO THE LEGAL
AFFAIRS DIVISION AGAIN THEN TO
DC AS BUDGET OFFICE BACK TO THE
LEGAL AFFAIRS DIVISION THEN TO
DCH LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
REVIEW. I ASSUME THAT'S AN
OFFICE. THE DCA EXECUTIVE
OFFICE THEN TO THE AGENCY FOR
WHATEVER THE AGENCY DOES AT
THAT POINT. THEN BACK TO THE
DCH REGULATION COORDINATOR AND
BACK TO THE BOARD FOR THEN
SUBMISSION I GUESS POSTING. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEN ON TO-
ALE FOR REVIEW. FOR INITIAL
REVIEW AND THEN OF COURSE
PUBLIC COMMENT HAS TO BE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT I ASSUME AT SOME
POINT AND THEN ANY COMMENTS OF
A WHALE NEED TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION BEFORE
REGULATIONS ULTIMATELY ARE
FINALIZED PERHAPS GOING BACK
THROUGH THIS PROCESS DOES THAT
SORT OF ACCURATELY DESCRIBE
SCRIBE AT LEAST WHAT'S BEEN
PRESENTED TO ME ACTUALLY
DESCRIBE. THE PRE REVIEW
PROCESS WE'RE DEALING WITH HERE-
IT IS. NOT ENTIRELY BUT-
THEY'RE PART OF THE CHANGE IN
THE REGULATIONS UNIT- WHY IS
IT- ESSENTIALLY. THE CONCEPT IS
EACH ATTORNEY IS ASSIGNED THE
PORTFOLIO OF CLIENTS SO- ONE OF
MY CLIENTS IS A BOARD AND I'M
WORKING WITH THAT BOARD WHO
ARE. OFTEN TIMES ALREADY HAS
REGULATORY STAFF NOT ALWAYS BUT
OFTEN TIMES. AND FOR THOSE
LAWYERS BY THE WAY. I APOLOGIZE
WHAT WAS THAT YOU SAY THEY HAVE
THE BOARD HAS REGULATORY
STAFFER YOU TALKING ABOUT
REGULATORY ATTORNEYS. NOT
ATTORNEYS USUALLY APPROACH YOU
KNOW- PROGRAM ANALYST STAFF
THAT ARE THAT ARE SOMEWHAT-
THANKS MORE ON POLICY- THEY MAY
BE FOCUSED ON PROCEDURAL ISSUES
BUT- WE'RE GONNA GET A LOT OF
OUR POLICY SUPPORT FROM THE
BOARD STAFF ITSELF- AND SO
THOSE. THOSE THAT TEAM IS
WORKING TO DEVELOP REGULATORY
TAXED- THE TEXT IS PRESENTED TO
THE BOARD SOMETIMES BOARD HAVE
NO COMMENTS ON TEXT- OF THE
REGULATION MUCH LIKE STATUTES
OTHER TIMESTHE BOARDS VERY
MUCH ARE VERY INTERESTED IN THE
IN THIS THE PRECISE WORDING OF
A PARTICULAR REGULATION AND HOW
IT AFFECTS THE INDUSTRY. AND SO
USUALLY OUR ATTORNEYS WILL BE
AT THOSE BOARD MEETINGS HELPING
FACILITATE THAT CONVERSATION-
OFTENTIMES WITH THE BOARD STAFF
TO- AND THEN ONCE THAT TEXT IS
SETTLED- IT DEPENDING ON THE
CLIENT- SOME OF OUR CLIENTS
HAVE MORE DEVELOPED REGULATIONS
STAFF THAN OTHERS OF OUR
CLIENTS AS I MENTIONED WE HAVE
ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN DIFFERENT
REGULATORY BODIES AT THIS
DEPARTMENT- AND CHAU DEPENDING
ON OUR CLIENT- WILL BE MORE OR
LESS INVOLVED IN DRAFTING UP
THE MAJOR REGULATORY DOCUMENTS
AGAIN THE- THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL TYPE DIGEST. THAT
COMMITTEE ANALYSES TYPE
DOCUMENTS- WILL BE ENGAGED WITH
THE CLIENTS AND DRAFTING KNOWS-
THEY GO THROUGH A DEPARTMENTAL
LEVEL REVIEW. THEY GO THROUGH
WHICH INCLUDE THE LEGAL SIDE IN
THE BUDGET SIDE. THEN THEY. GO
THROUGH AN AGENCY LEVEL REVIEW.
AND THEN THERE PUBLISHED SHE-
THE- PUBLIC FOR NOW IT'S
CHILDREN- THAT THE PROJECT STEP-
IT GOING TO VARY FROM TIME TO
TIME WE DON'T FOR INSTANCE HAVE
THAT WAS ONE OF THE PROCESS
CHANGES OF THE REGULATIONS
UNIT. WAS WE CUT OUT THE
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS STEP THAT
YOU DESCRIBED IN YOUR IN YOUR
SUMMARY- WE'VE ALSO CUT OUT
STEPS BOTH AT THE LEGAL
DIVISION AND AT THE BUDGET
OFFICE SO THAT THE PROCESS HAS
CHANGED SOMEWHAT- FROM FROM
THAT DESCRIPTION BUT ROUGHLY IT
IS. THAT THE CONCEPT IS THE
SAME WHICH IS. A SORT OF A
SYMBIOTIC DEVELOPMENT OF
REGULATIONS BETWEEN BOARDING
DEPARTMENT. SHOULD MEANING FOR
DEPARTMENTAL REVIEW SUBMITTING
FOR AGENCY REVIEW. PUBLIC
NOTICE. AND THEN. BACK TO. THAT
SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP OF
DEVELOPING THOSE FINAL
DOCUMENTS. OR MENTAL REVIEW
AGENCY REVIEW DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE REVIEW. AND OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW ALSO YOUR
PROCESS CHANGES THE PROCESS
CHANGES THAT YOU SPEAK ABOUT
DID THEY RESULT IN ANY
REDUCTION IN YOUR PROCESSING
TIME. SO AS I MENTIONED THAT
WAS ONE OF THE CRITICISMS OF
OUR OUR PROCESS BEFORE WAS WE
DIDN'T REALLY HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE TRACKING SYSTEM
ANECDOTALLY WE HAD HEARD THAT
THERE WERE ABOUT TWO YEAR LONG.
SAYS HE'S OF REGULATIONS SO IF
WE WERE TO ASSUME THAT'S TRUE
THEN WE'VE NOW REDUCED THAT BY
ABOUT 20% DOWN TO- TWENTY
TWENTY MONTHS THAT'S NOT OUR
GOAL OUR GOAL IS TO KEEP
IMPROVING ON THIS PROCESS- AND
SO WE'RE HOPING TO KEEP
CONTINUING TO NOT WALK AWAY AT
THAT- BUT LIKE I SAID THIS IS
BEEN. BASICALLY IMPLEMENTED NOW
FOR ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF A
BIG A BIG PART OF THAT WAS WAS
KIND OF IT WHERE WE
TRANSITIONED. FROM WHAT WAS A
PAPER HEAVY PROCESS AT TO YOU
MUCH MORE FLUID ELECTRONIC
PROCESS THESE PEOPLE WORKING
FROM HOME- SO WE'VE WE'VE HAD
TO MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS THAT
WERE NOT ANTICIPATED BUT WE
HAVE MADE THEM. AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE MAKING IMPROVEMENTS AS
I SAID OUR NUMBERS ARE SHOWING
THAT WE'VE MADE IMPROVEMENTS SO
I'M WE'RE WE'RE WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR IS AN ADDITIONAL TWO
YEARS TO CONTINUE BUILDING ON
WHAT WE STARTED. WELL MAKES OF
JUST TO MY FLOWSHEET FLOW CHART
BUT YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE DO YOU
KNOW OF ANY OTHER. STATE TO
STATE GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY AT
THE AGENCY AND DEPARTMENT LEVEL
THAT UTILIZES THIS TYPE OF
PROCESS TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS. THE DETAIL PROCESS
THAT I OUTLINED SUBJECT TO THE
CHANGES THAT YOU INDICATED.
WHAT I CAN'T SAY IT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THE DEPARTMENT I DID A
PRETTY DEEP DIVE REGULATIONS
REPORT AND PUBLISH THAT
REPORTED ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
WEBSITE IN THE COURSE OF DOING
THAT THE APARTMENT LOOKED AT
FIVE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AND
BOARDS AND SURVEY THEIR
DIFFERENT PROCESS EASIER. IT IS
TRUE THE DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES DO IT DIFFERENT WAYS
DEPENDING ON THEIR MAKE UP THIS
DEPARTMENT IS SOMEWHAT UNIQUE
IN THAT IT'S COMPRISED OF
LITTLE MANY DEPARTMENTS WITHIN
A BIGGER DEPARTMENT- WHERE IT'S
ONE OF THE POINT OF THE
ENTITIES WE SURVEYED BUDGET
RESOURCES SUPPORT. RESOURCES
FOR DOESN'T HAVE THAT OVERSIGHT
AT THAT WE DO WITH THIS
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS-
BUT OTHER DEPARTMENTS WE LOOK
AT BERMAN A PUBLIC HEALTH THEY
HAVE CENTERS WHICH ARE SORT OF
LIKE SMALL BOARDS AND SO THEY
DO HAVE THE PROCESSES ARE NOT
IDENTICAL TO WHAT I ESCRIBE
BUT THEY DO HAVE KIND OF A-
CENTER DEPARTMENT AGENCY LEVEL
REVIEW ON REGULATIONS. SO THERE.
ARE SOME COMPARABLE- TAMPA OUT
THERE BUT PROBABLY NOTHING BIG.
LIKE PCA IDEAS SOMEWHAT WAS
SOMEWHAT UNIQUE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT OF THE TIMELINE FOR
THE AGENCY JUST REFERENCE HOW
LONG ON AVERAGE DOES THAT
AGENCY TAKE TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS. SHOW THE DATE I
DON'T RECALL THAT ONE OFF THE
TOP BUT THE AVERAGE IS- FOR THE
WHOLE GROUP THAT WE LOOKED AT
THEY RANGE FROM BETWEEN. NINE
MONTHS TO THREE TO FOUR YEARS
OKAY WHERE IS THE BEERS THE
ISSUE I'M NOT GONNA BELABORED
HERE THIS YEAR AS YOU KNOW- I
HAVE A DIFFERENT ASSIGNMENT
THIS YEAR SO WE'LL HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION IN A DIFFERENT
FORM ON A DIFFERENT DATE. BUT
MY QUESTION IS OBVIOUSLY WE ALL
WANT PERFECTION IN STATE
GOVERNMENT AND IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO FIND. SO KUDOS TO
YOU FOR FINDING IT IN THE
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT BUT I'M
JUST WONDERING WHAT THE BALANCE
I BALANCING. TOTAL PERFECTION
WITH. A SPEEDY RESOLUTION AND
DEVELOPING INFORMATION AND
GETTING OUT TO THE CUSTOMER.
WHO NEEDS TO HAVE IT IN ORDER
TO KNOW HOW TO COMPLY WITH THE
RULES THAT WE PUT IN PLACE HERE
SO. I'M GOING TO BE LOOKING TO
SEE WHAT SORT OF A- VALUE ADDED
ANALYSIS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE AGENCY HAS PERFORMED
WITH RESPECT TO THIS REGULATORY
PROCESS. TO ANALYZE FOR EXAMPLE
WOULD VALUE ADDED TO IT IS IT
TO HAVE THE AGENCY INVOLVED IN
THE PROCESS AND AT WHAT POINT
IN TIME. JUST AS ONE EXAMPLE
SO. I LOOK FORWARD TO- HAVING A
FURTHER CONVERSATION ON THIS
ISSUE OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT- THIS
IS A BUDGET ISSUE AND I'M NOT
OPPOSED TO. GETTING ATTORNEYS
PEKKA LOVE ATTORNEYS- SO I'LL
MOVE ON BUT I'M SURE AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY HAVE
A CONVERSATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR SHERIFF AYE MATE
KID TRYING TO. FINANCED I JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT
NINETEEN TWENTY WAS THE FIRST
YEAR THAT. THE- DEPARTMENT
RECEIVED. INTO THE STAFF TO
ESTABLISH THE NEW REGULATIONS
UNIT. IT DID TAKE SOME TIME TO
HIRE THE STAFF I'M TO START
WORKING ON THIS. THE TWENTY
MONTH TIMELINE THAT- YOU KNOW
RYAN MENTIONED YOU KNOW BEFORE
NINETEEN TWENTY WE WANT TO
STRESS THAT- YOU KNOW THE
SECOND HALF OF THE YEAR. CUBBON
NINETEEN HIT THAT- REALLY HAD A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT NOT JUST ON
THE PARK BENCH BUT LIKE.
FINANCED- I NOTICED IN A WELL
AS OTHER DEPARTMENTS- JUST.
IMPACT ON THEIR- WORKLOAD IN
THE PROCESS USED TO. THAT IS
PART OF THE REASON WHY WE'RE
ASKING FOR THIS EXTENSION-
BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT. THAT SORT
OF ISSUES. BUT YOU KNOW ABSENT
KEVIN NINETEEN- YOU KNOW ASK
THE DEPARTMENT RAN SEVEN FULLY
IMPLEMENT THIS- REGULATIONS
UNIT- THAT THAT COULD HAVE YOU
KNOW THAT THAT LIKELY WOULD
HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE BEEN NINETEEN SO
WE- ARE REQUESTING TO EXTEND
THIS FOR ANOTHER COUPLE YEARS-
TO ALLOW YOU KNOW. STATE
PROCESS USED TO BETTER JUST TO
COVER NINETEEN AND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT COLLECTS- MORE DATA-
AND YOU KNOW FULLY HER THEIR
STAFF FULLY IMPLEMENT THEIR
REGULATIONS UNIT AND- WE'RE
ANTICIPATING THAT TIMELINE-
WILL PROBABLY. IMPROVE THANK
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT I
APPRECIATE THAT THE THEIR
REFLECTION ON A IMPACT TO
PROVIDE. CENTER NIELSEN MANAGER
I JUST HAVE TO REFLECT AT. THE
CENTRE FROM RIVERSIDE IT
ENQUIRIES OF BROUGHT A BIG
SMILE TO MY FACE YOU CAN'T TELL
BECAUSE OF. THE MASK THAT I WAS
SMILING FROM EAR TO EAR. WHAT
THIS HAS BECOME AS A EXAMPLE OF
WHY HAPPENS WHEN SOMETHING GETS
IN THE GOVERNMENT. IT'S MCCARTY
THEN AND I HAD A GREAT IDEA.
AND I JUST WATCHED HOWARD'S THE
LITTLE TRACING OF THE PROCESS.
IT IS GOTTEN SO CONVOLUTED.
CUMBERSOME IT ALMOST
IRRELEVANT- GOOD IDEAS GET
TWISTED UP AROUND HERE AND IT'S
JUST IT'S REALLY AMUSING I
SUPPOSE BUT IT ISN'T AMUSING
QUITE FRANKLY ON THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEING REGULATED AND HASSLE.
BY ALL OF THESE AGENCIES STAFF
BUREAUCRATS IN ALL THIS DEMAND
FOR MORE MORE INFORMATION.
RELATED TO THE REGULATIONS WE
OWE OUR CITIZENS A LOT BETTER
THAN THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT COMMENT-
WANT TO REMIND US THAT- THIS
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS HAS. ONE THIRTY SEVEN I
GUESS THE STREET THIRTY EIGHT
BUT NOW THIRTY SEVEN BURDEN
BUREAUS AND- THAT WE THEY
IMPLEMENT THE RULES IT. WE
CREATE AND SO THE CHALLENGE IS
GETTING THAT INTO THEM INTO A
FORM THAT MAKES SENSE TO THE
PUBLIC AND- I THINK WHAT WHAT'S
BEEN TALKED ABOUT TODAY'S
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S
A WAY TO BE ABLE TO DO A LITTLE
BIT MORE EFFICIENTLY. AND- AND
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENT ABOUT.
IT THIS BEING. IMPLEMENTED
DURING THE ERA OF CODE-
BLIGHTED CHANGES HAPPENED AND
SO THIS IS A BUDGET ISSUE AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE REVIEWING
THIS. COMING BACK AT A LATER
DATE THIS IS A HOLD UP OPEN
ITEM AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU.
PROVIDED TO US TODAY- I THINK
WAS VERY HELPFUL TO ME TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY WHICH
IS THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
REQUEST FOR THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD. HE THERE
THE DEPARTMENT OR SOMEONE FROM
THE BOARD. OF ESTIMATES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MIKE CHEN
NASTY LEGISLATION SHE FOR THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD.
SO IF YOUR MATERIALS PROVIDE
THIS YEAR SO WE DOES HAVE A
SEPARATE ACCOUNT IN THE BUDGET
BILL YOU'RE A SEPARATE FROM ITS
SPECIAL FUND. CALLED THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
EDUCATION ACCOUNT. IT IS FUNDED
ENTIRELY BY VOLUNTARY DONATIONS
ON CONTRACTOR LICENSE AND
REGISTRATION RENEWALS. BY
STATUTE IT DOES FUND
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
EDUCATION PROGRAMS I QUALIFY
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES AND
CANNOT BE USED FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSE. HI THE ACCOUNT IS
CURRENTLY APPROPRIATE AT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND BUT THERE IS
PROJECTED TO BE OVER HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS THERE BY THE
END OF THE YEAR. SO THE BUDGET
CHANGE A PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
TODAY DOES INCLUDE LANGUAGE
THAT ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO AUGMENT THE
APPROPRIATION IN A GIVEN YEAR
BASED ON THE FUNDS ARE ACTUALLY
AND THE ACCOUNT. SO THAT'S OUR
LITTLE BACKGROUND TODAY I'M
HERE WITH OUR LICENSING CHIEF
IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS WE
ARE CERTAINLY. AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ANY
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. CATEGORY
FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER AT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ABOUT THE
L. A. O. COMENT. SO IN ORDER
ALMOST OFFICE WE DID NOT RAISE
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE ARE NO- QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS A HOLD OPEN
ITEM SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO. THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS%
CONTROL AND- ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY ONE ESTABLISHING THEIR
APARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
KIMBERLY HARBISON FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND I'M
JOINED BY MEMBERS OF THE
FINANCE TEAM AS WELL AS
COLLEAGUES. FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE- SO THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US HERE TODAY TO TALK
WITH YOU ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. TO
CONSOLIDATE THE LICENSING
COMPLIANCE AND REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS OF
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS ACTIVITY IN
CALIFORNIA. INTO A SINGLE
DEPARTMENT. ALSO INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WILL
CREATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL WITHIN THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY. EFFECTIVE JULY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR. CREATING
ONE POINT OF CONTACT WILL
BETTER SERVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
LICENSEES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS BY MAKING SURE
THEY RECEIVE CONCISE CONSISTENT
GUIDANCE FROM THE STATE. THIS
PROPOSAL AIMS TO SIMPLIFY
PARTICIPATION IN THE LEGAL
MARKET AND SUPPORT THE
SUCCESSFUL AND SAFE OPERATION
OF CANNABIS BUSINESSES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW. THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A SINGLE
DEPARTMENT WILL REMOVE
REDUNDANCIES PARTICULARLY
AROUND LICENSING AND COMPLIANCE
PROCESSES. THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE LICENSING HAS PROVEN TO
BE A CHALLENGING BARRIER TO
ENTRY FOR SMALL OPERATORS AS
WELL AS VERTICALLY INTEGRATED
COMPANIES. PLACING ENFORCEMENT
UNDER ONE DEPARTMENT WILL LEAD
TO IMPROVED ENFORCEMENT
COORDINATION AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE STATE TO
MORE EFFECTIVELY APPLIANCE
RESOURCES TO BETTER PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH SAFETY AND LANDS.
CIBLE FIVE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AND ULTIMATELY MAKE IT MORE
COSTLY AND INEFFICIENT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE ILLICIT
CANNABIS INDUSTRY. WE KNOW THAT
A STRONG LEGAL MARKET AND LOCAL
PARTICIPATION REDUCES THE
ILLEGAL MARKET. HAVING ONE
DEPARTMENT WILL SIMPLIFY THE
STATE ADMINISTRATION OF
REGULATING CANNABIS. I'M SORRY
FOR EVERYTHING CANNABIS AND
THIS WILL A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN UNDERSTANDING THE STATE
FRAMEWORK AND BEING MORE
WILLING TO ADOPT THAT FRAMEWORK
IN THE RESPECTIVE LOCALITIES.
ONE OF THE FIRST TEST OF THE
NEW DEPARTMENT WILL BE A WILL
BE TO HARMONIZE. THE THREE SETS
OF EXISTING REGULATIONS INTO
ONE. READING OFF OF ONE SET
WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
INDUSTRY TO NAVIGATE AND THE
STATE WILL HAVEA BETTER
UNDERSTANDING. OF THE IMPACTS
AND OUTCOMES OF THE STATE
REGULATORY EFFORTS THROUGH MORE
UNIFORM DATA COLLECTION AND
ANALYSIS. THIS WILL INVOLVE
CONSOLIDATION RECONCILIATION
AND STREAMLINING MORE
APPROPRIATE. THIS PROPOSAL
CREATES THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THE NEW DEPARTMENT LARGELY BY
MOVING POSITIONS AND FUNDING
THAT ARE CURRENTLY SUPPORTING
THE THREE EXISTING STATE
CANNABIS LICENSING ENTITIES. TO
THE NEW DEPARTMENT ON JULY
FIRST. THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL REQUESTS SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE POSITIONS AND A
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION. CANNABIS CONTROL FUND
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
THAT AMOUNT DECREASES BY
SEVENTEEN POINT TWO MILLION TO
A TOTAL OF ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX POINT SIX MILLION IN TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND I'M GOING.
SO OF THE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
POINT EIGHT NINE REQUESTED ONLY
THREE POINT TWO MILLION IS NEW
FUNDING. TO ESTABLISH THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE REMAINING
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY POINT SEVEN.
THIS WILL CURRENT
APPROPRIATIONS IN THE EXISTING
DEPARTMENTS. WE WILL FOCUS ON
CONTINUITY AND STABILITY FOR
STAKEHOLDERS DURING THE
TRANSITION TO THE CONTINUED USE
OF THE CURRENT LICENSING
SYSTEMS. AND THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS TRACK AND TRACE
SYSTEM. AS WELL AS THROUGH
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS WITH
EXISTING DEPARTMENTS FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES. WHILE
WE WORK TO STAND UP NEW
DEPARTMENT OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. THE FUNDING DECREASED IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
THAT I NOTED ABOVE LARGELY
REFLECTS THE PHASE OUT. OF
THESE TRANSITIONAL INTERAGENCY
AGREEMENTS. SO LIKEWISE OF THE
SIX HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
POSITIONS THAT WE REQUESTED.
ONLY TWENTY THREE ARE NEW AND
THE REST ARE CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED WITHIN THE THREE
LICENSING ENTITIES. THE
TRANSFER OF FIVE HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT EXISTING POSITIONS WILL
HELP THE NEW DEPARTMENTS RETAIN
THE KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERTISE
THAT RESIDE WITHIN THESE
PROGRAMS TODAY. THE TWENTY
THREE NEW POSITIONS ARE NEEDED
TO FORM THE EXECUTIVE
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE OF THE NEW
DEPARTMENT. CONSISTENT WITH
THAT OF OTHER DEPARTMENTS OF
SIMILAR SIZE. THESE POSITIONS
WILL PROVIDE SOME EXECUTIVE AND
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS
CURRENTLY PERFORMED. WITHIN THE
THREE EXISTING DEPARTMENTS THAT
ARE NOT SPECIFIC TO CANNABIS
AND WILL BE STAYING AT THE-
HOME DEPARTMENTS THE LEGACY
APARTMENTS. SO I'D ALSO LIKE
TO. POINT OUT SPECIFICALLY THAT
THE THREE DEPARTMENTS- ALL
RECEIVE ONGOING FUNDING IN
THEIR TWENTY TWENTY ONE MAYOR
VISUAL BASIC PEACE BECAUSE WE
HAD INITIALLY. PRESENTED THIS
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET LAST
YEAR BUT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC HOLD IT BACK SO WE'RE
INTRODUCING OF THIS YEAR. SO
THIS YEAR'S GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALSO INCLUDES COMPANION
PROPOSALS. AND CONSUMER AFFAIRS
PUBLIC HEALTH AND FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. TO REDUCE ENTRANCE
FOR THEIR RESPECTIVE CANNABIS
RESOURCES TO THE DEPARTMENT.
ASSEMBLY A PROPOSED STATUTORY
CHANGES TO EFFECTUATE THE
CONSOLIDATION AND MAKE RELATED
IMPROVEMENTS WHERE POSSIBLE ONE
ITEM OF NOTE FOR THE COMMITTEE
IS OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE. WILL
RETAIN THE CANNABIS-APPELLATIONS PROGRAM. THE- CAL
PROGRAMS WHICH WILL ESTABLISH
STANDARDS FOR CANNABIS
COMPARABLE TO THE NATIONAL
ORGANIC PROGRAM WILL ALSO BE
RETAINED WITHIN FOR AN
AGRICULTURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BENEFIT FROM THEIR
EXISTING EXPERTISE. IN CLOSING
WE WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS THE FIRST
STEP IN MOVING TOWARD A UNIFIED
APPROACH TO CANNABIS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA. THIS EFFORT IS
ABOUT TRYING TO REMOVE BARRIERS
AND PAIN POINTS FOR SMALL
OPERATORS FACE CHALLENGES
ENTERING THE CANNABIS SPACED
AND PROVIDING EFFICIENCY IS
REPORTEDLY INTEGRATED COMPANIES
AND OTHER OPERATORS. THIS IS
NOT AN UP FRONT COST SAVINGS
EXERCISE BUT MAINLY TO SAVINGS
OVER TIME AS KNOWLEDGES
CENTRALIZED ACTIVITIES ARE
INTEGRATED IN PROCESSES BECOME
MORE EFFICIENT. WE RECOGNIZE
THIS EFFORT WILL REQUIRE
ADJUSTMENTS AFTER THE INITIAL
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT
AND IT IS OUR INTENT TO PROVIDE
CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS. AND
SERVICES DURING THE TRANSITION
PERIOD. THREE OF EXPERT TO THE
TRANSFER EXISTING. FROM THE
THREE CANNABIS ENTITIES SHE
THEN. DEPARTMENT WILL IN THIS
GOAL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND WE'RE ALL HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS CONCERNS. YEAH THAT
WAS ME DEPARTMENT FINANCIAL I'M
SORRY YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT I'M
BASED OUT- IT LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. SORT OF BORED
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE FIRST OF ALL WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THE
CONSOLIDATION BECAUSE WE AGREE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE IS
PROBLEMATIC CURRENTLY THERE'S
NO LEAD AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR
REGULATING CANNABIS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO KNOW WHO TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE
AS WELL AS FOR LICENSEES TO
KNOW WHO TO INTERACT WITH IF
THEY HAVE MULTIPLE LICENSE
TYPES. ACCORDINGLY WE THINK
CONSOLIDATION HAS SIGNIFICANT
POTENTIAL TO IMPROVE THE
REGULATION OF CANNABIS IN THE
STATE- HOWEVER WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE RESOURCES BE APPROVED
ONLY ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS
AND THIS IS BECAUSE THE ONGOING
NEED FOR RESOURCES AREN'T
CLEAR. RIGHT NOW THE CANNABIS
MARKET IS STILL IN THE PROCESS
OF MATURING AND THIS CAN BE
SEEN BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF
LICENSES ARE THAT WAY SINCE HE
IS THAT EACH OF THE ENTITIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR HAS FLUCTUATED
QUITE A BIT IN RECENT YEARS.
AND ACCORDINGLY WORKLOAD COULD
BE HIGHER OR LOWER THAN ASSUMED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. IN
ADDITION AS WAS REFERENCED- THE
NEW STRUCTURE COULD CHANGE THE
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES NEEDED ON
THE ONE HAND- THE NEW STRUCTURE
COULD CREATE EFFICIENCIES OVER
TIME. THAT WILL WORK WITH THAT
WOULD REDUCE OVERALL NEED FOR
RESOURCES AND ON THE OTHER HAND
IT COULD INCREASE THE NEED FOR
RESOURCES PARTICULARLY IF THE
NEW DEPARTMENT. OF CHANGES THE
WORLD THE- WE IT PRIORITIZES
THE ACTIVITIES AGAIN ENGAGES
AND FOR EXAMPLE THE NEW
DEPARTMENT MIGHT DECIDE THAT IT
NEEDS TO PLACE MORE EMPHASIS ON
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AGAINST ON
LICENSE ACTIVITY AND THAT WOULD
REQUIRE REBALANCING. OF
RESOURCES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
ACCORDINGLY WE READ. THAT THE
PHONE. ONLY BE APPROVED ON A
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS
IS THIS WOULD GIVE TIME FOR THE
CANNABIS MARKET TO MAKE SURE.
AND FOR THE EFFECTS OF THE
CONSOLIDATION TO BE MADE CLEAR.
IN ADDITION WE'RE ALSO
RECOMMENDING- REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO A WORK LOAD
REPORT. ON THAT WOULD COMPARE
THE AMOUNT OF WORKLOAD- SOON
FOR EACH POSITION WITH THE
ACTUAL WORKLOAD EXPERIENCED BY
THOSE POSITIONS. AS WELL AS
DESCRIBING ANY CHANGES IN THE
NEED. FOR RESOURCES DUE TO THE
CONSOLIDATION WE RECOMMEND THAT
THIS REPORT TO BE DELIVERED TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON NOVEMBER
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE. SO
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE
TIME TO CONSIDER IT AS PART OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE BUDGET PROCESS. ONE UNDER
OUR RECOMMENDATION THE LIMITED
TERM FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD EXPIRE THIS WOULD GIVE
THE LEGISLATURE THE INFORMATION
IT WOULD NEED TO MAKE. A
DETERMINATION ABOUT THE ON
GOING LEVEL OF RESOURCES NEEDED
FOR THE DEPARTMENT. I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY UESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR- THOSE
COMMENTS TEKASHI TO VERY MUCH-
I HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
THAT I CAN I CAN GO THROUGH
PRETTY QUICKLY- LET ME START%
OFF BY SAYING GIVEN THAT GIVING
GIVEN THAT THE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT ALL OF THE- OF THE
RESOURCES. IS DERIVED FROM
LICENSE FEES WHAT IS IT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO ENSURE
THERE ISN'T A SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE IN LICENSED BUSINESSES
AS WE APPROACH THE SUNSET ON
PROVISIONAL LICENSES. THANK
THAT WOULD GO TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. IT'S ACTUALLY GOING
TO HAND IT OFF TO ONE OF OUR
DEPARTMENT REPRESENTATIVES.
RICHARD YOU NEVER WALK AGAIN-
WERE SPONSORED THAT THANK YOU
SURE CABALLERO. WITH REGARD TO
GET BACK THAT- LICENSE YOU
SUPPORT HE- THE OPERATIONS OF
THE PROGRAMS AND WITH THE-
LOOKING SUNSET DATE FOR
PROVISIONAL LICENSES ALL OF THE
LICENSING AUTHORITIES CONTINUE
TO SEE. NEW APPLICATIONS AND-
WE ARE DILIGENTLY WORKING TO
ISSUE LICENSES I'M ALWAYS
LOOKING TO MISSION ANNUAL
LICENSE. IF WE ARE ABLE TO.
WHAT WE ARE FOR I. WE'RE DOING
IN OUR TO REVIEW THOSE
PROFESSIONALS WHEN THEY CAN BE
RENEWED AND ALL A- WITH THE
INDUSTRY TO TRANSITION OF THOSE
PROVISIONAL LICENSES TO HANDLE
LICENSES. ON THERE ARE SEVERAL
FACTORS THAT. COME INTO PLAY IN
GETTING RELICENSING LICENSE- WE
DO NEED TO WORK ON HAVING-
LOCAL AUTHORIZATION AND SEE FOR
PAROLE- ON ALSO IT'S REALLY
DEPENDING ON THE QUALITY AND
THOROUGHNESS OF THE
APPLICATION- BUT WE EXPERIENCED
THIS WHEN WE HAD TEMPORARY
LICENSES AND WE- TRANSITION.
POLICYHOLDERS MEANS YOU RENTAL
LICENSES TO WORK IN MINOR WITH
WORKING WITH THE INDUSTRY TO
ENSURE THAT LICENSEES DO NOT
FALL OUT OF OUR LICENSURE
STATUS I WILL EXPERIENCE THAT
WE NEED- TOWARD THE END OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND ALSO RECOGNIZING
THAT THERE IS LEGISLATION
CURRENTLY OUT THERE TO
CONTEMPLATE EXPANDING SUNSET ON
THE PROVISIONAL LICENSING-
ACCORDING. VERY GOOD- I THINK
THERE WAS SOMETHING. OVER SIXTY
OF THE LAW IS A PER SO WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THEY- THAT THEY
DON'T. EXPIRE BECAUSE- WHAT WE
KNOW IS THAT THE WE STILL HAVE
A VERY ROBUST BLACK MARKET- IN
THIS AREA SO LET ME LET ME GO
ON TO SOME OF THE OTHER
QUESTIONS WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
EFFORTS OF THE ADMINISTRATION
IS DOING TO ENCOURAGE
BUSINESSES TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE LEGAL MARKET. AND THEN- IN
IN IT AND THEN THE SAME
QUESTION WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO
ENCOURAGE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PERMIT CANNABIS WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION CHAIRED A KIMBERLY
HARVEST AND AGAIN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO I
THINK THERE ARE A FEW- BUCKETS
OF THINGS THAT WE WOULD. SAY
ARE WHAT WE'RE DOING TO SUPPORT
EDUCATE LITTLE BUSINESSES. AND
THOSE WOULD FALL INTO TAX
RELIEF. FUNDING ENFORCEMENT AND
PUBLIC RELATIONS AND
EDUCATIONAL OUTREACH SETTLED
FOR TAX RELIEF- THERE'S A
TEMPORARY FREEZE ON THE EXCISE
TAX MARKUP THAT WAS PASSED IN
TWENTY TWENTY- WE FROZEN
INCREASES THE CULTIVATION TAX
INFLATION ADJUSTMENTS. MODIFIED
THE TAX CODES IN THE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES CAN TAKE BUSINESS
TAX DEDUCTIONS LIKE ANY OTHER
LEGAL BUSINESSES CAN. AND WE'VE
ALSO- PUBLICLY COMMITTED JUST
CONSIDER PROPOSALS AIMED AT
REFORMING THE TAX STRUCTURE- IF
FOLKS WOULD LIKE TO SUBMIT
THOSE. AFTER FUNDING WE COME IN
FIFTY FIVE MILLION IN EQUITY
FUNDING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THAT GOES TO. LOCAL EQUITY
APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES- AND
WE'RE SEEKING TO COMMIT ANOTHER
FIFTEEN MILLION. IN THIS
BUDGET- YES YOU MAY HAVE SEEN
THE GOVERNOR ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER LAST YEAR.
DECLARING THAT CANNABIS
BUSINESSES WERE ESSENTIAL IN
ROUTE WERE ALLOWED TO REMAIN
REMAIN OPEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC- THIS RECOGNIZES THE
HISTORIC MEDICINAL NATURE
CANNABIS. ENSURE CONTINUOUS
ACCESS TO SAFE TESTED PRODUCTS
FOR THOSE WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
PURCHASING- TRAIN FOR STUDENTS
THAT WE HAVE ENHANCED FINES
AGAINST ILLEGAL OPERATORS THAT
WAS. AB NINETY SEVEN TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND WE HAVE SOME NEW
SWORN OFFICERS POSITIONS AT THE
BUREAU TO COME COMBAT LISTEN
ACTIVITY. FOR OUTREACH- WE DO
ONE ON ONE INTERACTIONS WE ARE
HELP DESKS THAT FOLKS CAN CALL
INTO. THAT INVOLVES LICENSING
STAFF AND COMPLIANCE TEAMS-
THEIR EDUCATIONAL TOOLS AND
OTHER MATERIALS AVAILABLE AND
THERE ALSO ARE SOME EDUCATIONAL
CAMPAIGNS LIKE. THIS IS
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS LET'S TALK
CANNABIS AND. TO GET WAIT WHY
IS. FOR YOUR SECOND PART OF THE-
WITH REVENUE AND TAXATION
COUNTY. BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS RECEIVES
AN ALLOCATION FOR THE CANNABIS
TAX FUND. FOR MAKING LOCAL
MAKING GRANTS TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES CERTAIN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT ASSIST WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT FIRE PROTECTION
OR OTHER LOCAL PROGRAMMING. TO
ADDRESS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY RELATED TO LEGALIZATION
OF CANNABIS IN CALIFORNIA.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN APPLY FOR
THIS FUNDING TO THE BOARD IF
THEY HAVE NOT IF THEY HAVE NOT
BANNED BOTH INDOOR AND OUTDOOR
CULTIVATION. OR BAND RESULT.
RETAIL SALES. OR CANNABIS
PRODUCTS. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES AN ESTIMATED SIXTY
POINT TWO MILLION FOR THE
BOARD'S PUBLIC. HEALTH AND
SAFETY GRANT PROGRAM- THE BOARD
APPROXIMATELY TEN MILLION TO
TEN JURISDICTIONS. AND THE
FIRST COHORT AND THEY'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON MAKING.
THE OTHER FIFTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE FOR COHORT
TWO AND THAT'S A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS. VERY GOOD IF I COULD
GET A COPY OF THAT INFORMATION
THAT WOULD BE TERRIFIC JUST TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT BETTER
WHAT. WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THOSE RESOURCES AND WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO THAT WOULD I
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE IT- IN
AND I'M JUST KIND OF ON GENERAL
PRINCIPLE- I'M A BIG BELIEVER
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR
CONSOLIDATIONS OR THE PROCESS
THAT HAS BEEN USED IN THE PAST
TO GO THROUGH THAT LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION- IT'S HARD TO
DO CONSOLIDATIONS THROUGH THE
BUDGET BECAUSE- THERE'S NOT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
IN PUBLIC PARTICIPATION THAT
ONE WOULD WOULD HAVE IF- IF
THIS WAS GOING THROUGH. A- A-
TRADITIONAL LEGISLATIVE POLICY
PROCESS. SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
IS THAT THERE BE THIS FULL
FLEDGED DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
PARTICIPANTS THAT THE LICENSEES
CURRENT AND FUTURE. AND THE
COMMUNITY SO THAT WE KNOW THAT.
THIS CONSOLIDATION IS IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF EVERYONE THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE AN EX IS AS
SMOOTH AS EXPEDITIOUSLY. AS
POSSIBLE AND THAT WE DON'T END
UP KILLING A FLEDGLING
INDUSTRY- THAT HAS WORKED HARD
TO BRING ITSELF INTO INTO LEGAL
COMPLIANCE AND INSTEAD- CREATE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE BLACK
MARKET TICKET. TO CONTINUE TO
GROW AND TO THEM. AND BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL SO I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT IT IT'S GOING TO WORK AND-
AND I'LL BE LOOKING AT THAT IS
S. AS THIS MOVES SORTED THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE HOLD OPEN I'M
GONNA SEE IF THERE ARE ANY MORE
COMMENTS. OF CONCERN FROM THE
COMMITTEE SEEING NONE- AT THE
END THIS IS A WHOLE OPEN ITEMS
SO I THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY.
AND THIS IS THE TIME. WE KNOW
THAT YOU'VE ALL BEEN WAITING
FOR. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO A
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS AS
A REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND
THE ACCESS CODEIS SIX FIVE
FOUR. TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN IT'S
REFLECTED ON THE SCREEN HERE
TODAY. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT YOU EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC PROVIDE DEBT WANTS TO
PROVIDE A COMMENT KEEP THEIR
REMARKS TO ONE MINUTE. NOW
LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY OF THE BILLS.
NOW IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
THERE'S ANYBODY THERE EITHER SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
WITH. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU LAYS ON THE PHONE LINE IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER. TWO YOU ARE
FLYING PLACE YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE PUBLIC CAMPUS. A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. AND OUR FIRST.
COMMENT WILL COME FROM WIND ONE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER ANY CHANGE CAN FINALLY
HAPPENED THAT CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OR CTA WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
CONSOLIDATE THREE CANNABIS
LICENSING AGENCIES OR THREE
UNIFIED DEPARTMENT OF. CONTROL
WHICH WE BELIEVE FOR THEIR
STRUGGLES OF LEGALIZATION AND
REGULATION WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
SOCIAL EQUITY PROVISIONS AND
ITS ON GOING COMMITMENT
ALLOCATE FIFTEEN AND A HALF
MILLION YOUR FUNDING TO FUND
LOCAL EQUITY PROGRAMMING AND
SUPPORT. THAT WE HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED FOR FUNDING RELATED TO THE
WAIVERS AND DEFERRALS FOR
EQUITY APPLICANTS WHICH WAS
ADVANCED BY SENATOR BRADFORD IN
SB FIVE NINE FIVE LAST YEAR I'M
I DON'T WANT TO BRING ATTENTION
TO THE PROVISIONAL LIKE THE
PROGRAM WHICH WAS- REFERENCED
BY THE CHAIRWOMAN- WE WANT TO
ESSENTIALLY STRESSED THE
URGENCY OF THE DRAFTING. OF THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSE
ACCELERATION AND COMMEND THE
CHAIRMAN FOR HER WORK IN THIS
AREA WITH HER AUTHORSHIP OF SB
FIFTY NINE WE BELIEVE THAT THE
IMPERATIVE THAT- ADDITIONAL
EXTENSIONS ARE PROVIDED SO
EXISTING OPERATORS CAN'T
CONTINUE TO UNDERGO. THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE A
REQUIREMENT THEN WE CAN KEEP
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND- SO
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK IN THIS
AREA THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
ANNEX WE ARE TO GO TO THE LINE.
OF ONE TWO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
FOR ADDITIONAL PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. HI CHAIRWOMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AUDREY
RETIRED CHECK FROM STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF SAN MATEO COUNTY-
JUST CALLING IN IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NINETEEN ON THE BOAT
ONLY- THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT BACK
STILL- THIS IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REQUEST FOR
REIMBURSE
MATTEO. FOR THEIR BLS SHORTFALL
INCURRED IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TWENTY- AND WE WANT TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT IN
THAT REQUEST. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT PLEASE. FRED I'M SURE
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME OUR
PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
ASK ONE MORE TIME. YES
ABSOLUTELY AGAIN FOR A PUBLIC
COMMENT LAYS IN GERMAN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. BUT
AGAIN FOR AS A FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND NOBODY IS
KILLING UP THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR APPRECIATE YOUR HELP
TODAY. SO THAT CONCLUDES OUR
PUBLIC COMMENTS ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SINGMAN I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY AND
WHO LISTENED TO OUR HEARING. IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD.
THANK YOU AND WE PUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
SO WE WILL BEGIN VOTING ON THE
ISSUES ON THE VOTE OWN THE ONLY
CALENDAR FIRST. WE WILL TAKE UP
ISSUES NUMBER. FIVE TWELVE
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN AND. SEVENTEEN
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS OUT
TO PROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ENTER CABALLERO HI AND
COVER YOUR EYES THUNDER NIELSEN.
THERE IS A NOTE SENATOR US
SENATOR ROTH HI. THOSE BILLS
ARE OUT TWO TWO ONE NEXT NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO TAKE
UP ISSUES NUMBER.
ONE TO THREE
FOR SIX SEVEN EIGHT NINE TEN
ELEVEN FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN OF THE
VOTE ON THE CALENDAR AND THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. MOTION IS MADE
BY SENATOR ROTH AGAIN. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ANNA CABALLERO BY
YOUR CAREER AYE SENATOR NELSON
SENATOR NIELSEN AYE SENATOR
ROSS. UNDER AUTHORED BY THE
MOTION PASSES THREE YESES NOS
ZERO. AND THAT OKAY SO THEN WE
WE'RE NOT DONE YET. WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE. THIS IS THE
DGS AND THE PER PROS
PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BILL TRAILER
BILL. THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. IS THERE MOTION.
MOVED BY SENATOR ROB PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ENTER CABALLERO
HI ANNA CABALLERO I SENATOR
NELSON SENATOR NELSON I SENATOR
US SENATOR AYE THAT MOTION
PASSES THREE TWO ZERO. ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY TWO THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
AND THE GREGORY BATESON
BUILDING RENOVATION THE MOTION
IS TO WERE APPROVED AS
REQUESTED. IS THERE A MOTION ON
THAT. SENATOR RON MAKES THE
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ANNA CABALLERO HI- CABRERA I
SENATOR NELSON SENATOR NELSON I
SENATOR US SANDRA HI THAT
MOTION PASSES AGAIN THREE TWO
ZERO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR.
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES AND THE RESOURCES
BUILDING RENOVATION THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE AS REQUESTED IS
THERE A MOTION. SENATOR ROTH
MOVES PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ENTER CABALLERO HI YOUR CAREER
AYE SENATOR NELSON SENATOR
NIELSEN AYE SENATOR ROSS.
FENDER OFF HI THAT MOTION
PASSES AS WELL THREE TO ZERO.
THE REST OF THE ITEMS WILL BE
HELD OPEN AND THAT CONCLUDES
OUR HEARING TODAY THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING. AND
THE BUDGET THE SENATE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
IS ADJOURNED.